[Musique]
j'espère réussir l'opposition de surfer
dessus et non gouvernement quoi la
Redoute c'est une journée de grève
bonjour bienvenue sur le Figaro live
nous suivons ensemble cette nouvelle
journée de mobilisation contre la
réforme des retraites après la période
de vacances la deuxième mi-temps du
conflit social débute aujourd'hui et
vous ne raterez rien de ces
manifestations notamment celle de Paris
tous les experts du Figaro viendront sur
plateau pour nous donner leur analyse on
aura les images en direct vous les voyez
ici première expert Marie-Cécile Renaud
bonjour bonjour
adjointe aux Figaro économie au service
économie du garrot on ira sur le terrain
dans un instant avec nos deux équipes
tiens on change de type de grève il y a
des styles de grève oui alors
effectivement là le mouvement
normalement se durcisse et ce qui avait
été annoncé
donc on a eu des mobilisations donc le
19 janvier c'était la première le 31 et
puis début février et donc là on en est
à la 6e journée il y a eu un ventre mou
pendant les vacances de février il y a
une relâchement une baisse pour les gens
étaient assez prévu c'était prévu il y a
eu la même les vacances il y a une
semaine de vacances parlementaire donc
il y avait plus de débat à l'Assemblée
donc les mêmes
donc les les syndicats eux aussi ont
fait relâche entre guillemets donc ça
correspondrait à la période de vacances
et puis là ça repart c'était attendu
c'était prévu ça doit repartir ils
annonçaient un redémarrage fort et dur
début mars donc on y est pour le 7 mars
et le 8 journée des femmes parce que
alors redémarrage en puissance nous
verrons les chiffres sont plutôt bons
pour les syndicats en tout cas au vu des
premières manifestations ce matin en
région je voulais vous parler du style
de grève parce que on avait l'habitude
depuis le début de l'année à une journée
de grève et puis on arrête là ça peut
changer grève reconductible style CGT si
j'ose dire voilà donc là il y a un
durcissement c'est les fractions les
plus radicales qui qui qui s'exprime et
donc on parle oui de grève
reconductibles on a plusieurs jours donc
et enfin les syndicats enfin certains
syndicats ont été très durs en parlant
de mettre la France à genoux de bloquer
le pays leur idée c'est que ça coûte
tellement cher au pays que le
gouvernement soit obligé de reculer
mais alors c'est vrai que ces grèves à
répétition elle coûte cher
parce que vous en pensez
de l'aime parce qu'on voit ces images en
hauteur de Paris Sèvres Babylone
Timothée quel est le parcours
aujourd'hui quel est le programme
alors aujourd'hui Thibault environ 3,5
km ça c'est la distance que doivent
parcourir les manifestants cet
après-midi dans les rues de la capitale
un des pages un départ pardon dont le
dont le un cortège pardon dont le départ
est imminent ici à Sèvres babylonou je
me trouve avec Julien Leclerc direction
la place d'Italie dans le 13e
arrondissement l'arrivée est prévue ce
soir aux alentours de 19h et les
manifestants qui vont donc traverser
Paris en empruntant d'abord le boulevard
Raspail il passera ensuite au niveau du
métro Rennes dans le 6e arrondissement
avant de bifurquer sur le boulevard du
Montparnasse et puis ensuite sur le
boulevard du Port-Royal et enfin
l'avenue des Gobelins d'où il
redescendront donc vers cette place
d'Italie Place d'Italie c'est la même
que la dernière journée de mobilisation
c'était terminé souvenez-vous c'était le
16 février dernier avec une
fréquentation qu'ils étaient effondré ce
jour-là une fréquentation qui s'était
effondré d'environ 50% par rapport
auprès de 93.000 manifestants qui
avaient été compté le 11 février d'après
les chiffres en tous les cas du
ministère de l'Intérieur aujourd'hui
selon nos informations aller service de
renseignement table sur la venue de 60
000 à 90 000 personnes à Paris une
grosse mobilisation donc qui est
attendue aujourd'hui une grosse
mobilisation notamment du côté des
jeunes et des enseignants ça se ce qui
nous c'est ce qui nous remonte du côté
de la de la place Bovo la police qui
redoute également la venue de de
casseurs aujourd'hui on estime du côté
de la Place Beauvau que pas moins de 400
à 800 ultra des gilets jaunes ainsi que
300 à 500 activistes de l'ultra gauche
pourraient et bien venir se fondre au
cortège dans les rues de la capitale
c'est la raison pour laquelle de
nombreuses effectifs de police et de
gendarmerie sont déployés en force
aujourd'hui dans les rues de Paris
qui
c'est manifestation ce sont déroulées
dans le calme jusqu'à présent
comment ça s'est décidé d'entrer
potentiellement dans des grèves
reconductibles la CGT la CFDT ne sont
pas tout à fait d'accord sur cette
question non la CFDT voulait maîtriser
continuer à maîtriser le mouvement et
donc été très favorable assez journée de
mobilisation forte
face auxquelles elle pensait que le
gouvernement ne allait ne pouvait pas ne
pas réagir
on voit quand même que le gouvernement
tiendront et reste dans même s'il a fait
beaucoup de concessions il a fait il a
porté quand même beaucoup de
modifications au texte et donc là il y a
les franges plus radicales qui estiment
qu'il faut maintenant durcir le
mouvement bloquer le pays donc on voit
que il y a effectivement une gradation
aujourd'hui puisqu'on avait 80% des
trains annulés
beaucoup c'est beaucoup oui c'est
beaucoup
beaucoup de RER aussi perturbés dans le
métro c'était aussi très bloqué sauf la
ligne et la 4 non la une est là et je ne
sais plus laquelle et la 14 voilà qui
sont automatiques donc bon et votre
porter parlé de l'éducation nationale
donc le mouvement était suivi dans
l'éducation depuis le début mais là
apparemment selon la FSU il y aurait 60%
de grévistes contre 32% annoncé par le
ministère donc ça reste très suivi dans
l'éducation on entend dire aussi que les
poubelles ne seraient pas ramassées à
Paris il y aurait trois incinérateurs
bloqués et puis ce qui inquiète beaucoup
et le gouvernement et les Français et
les entreprises c'est le blocage des
expéditions de carburant puisque il n'y
a plus apparemment d'essence enfin de
carburant qui sort des des raffineries
tout est bloqué si vous nous rejoignez
sur YouTube sur Le Figaro.fr et je
réponds évidemment à vos questions aussi
vous me parlez d'un potentiel blocage
total certains veulent mettre l'économie
du pays à genoux ça veut dire quoi
est-ce que c'est possible et des grèves
comme celle-ci une journée de journée
trois journées combien ça coûte à la
France
ça coûte très cher puisque bon il y a
d'abord le coup pour les secteurs
impactés il frappe avait fait un calcul
en 2019 lors des grèves de 2019 elle
avait calculé que une journée de grève
coûtait 20 millions d'euros à la SNCF 3
millions d'euros à la RATP 8 millions
d'euros Air France une journée donc ça
c'est pour les secteurs qui sont
directement
impactés mais il y a aussi tous les
secteurs qui sont touchés par rebond par
exemple l'hébergement restauration
comprenez bien que vous les chambres
d'hôtel vous les réservez plus si vous
n'avez pas de train pour faire votre
déplacement donc il y a aussi tous ces
coups ces secteurs touchés par rebond
parce que parce que les transports sont
bloqués et forcément leur entreprise est
impactée voilà exactement puis alors en
ce moment il y a quand même il y a
beaucoup de PME qui peuvent être
fragilisés on a vu qu'il y avait un
rebond des défaillances d'entreprise qui
ont augmenté de 51 plus de 50% en
janvier sur un an et donc c'est PME qui
sont fragilisés elles peuvent ah non non
non non non non ça c'est un retour à la
normale après après le covid où il y
avait eu voilà il y avait une baisse
mais donc il y a quand même des
entreprises qui sont fragilisées mais
qui avec ces mouvements de ces
mobilisation c'est grève peuvent des
entreprises qui sont un peu fragiles qui
peuvent perdre des clients des marchés
et puis ça peut être le coup de grâce
avec un coût économique et social parce
que les voilà et
donc
Mark Touati qui est un économiste dit
c'est bon en gros il y a le pipe c'est
2006 2600 milliards d'euros
la grève une grève dure on peut imaginer
perdre 10 à 15% d'activité donc ça fait
1 à 1 milliard et demi de perte par jour
alors je donne aussi le l'Insee un
scénario beaucoup moins pessimiste quand
il regarde l'Insee a regardé bon bah sur
les grands les derniers grands
mouvements de de mobilisation par
exemple sur les grèves de 95 ou sur les
grèves de 2019 sont aperçus qu'en gros
on perd 01 à 0,2 point de croissance
trimestrielle et des grèves durs ça fait
perdre entre 0 et 0,2 points de
croissance trimestrielle donc par
exemple sur on a un PIB
c'était quand même 2019 il y avait eu
plus d'un mois oui oui il y avait eu il
y avait eu plus de 30 jours de blocage
et puis 95 2010 il y avait eu aussi des
grosses des grosses mobilisations et
donc perdre 0 1 à 0 de pointe de
croissance trimestrielle en gros ça fait
si on prend un PIB à 500 milliards
d'euros au dernier trimestre 2022 ça
ferait perdre en gros un de l'or d'un
milliard d'euros mais pour pas par jour
enfin pour la totalité du mouvement de
de la période de grève parce qu'en fait
il y a l'Insee souligne qui a en fait
des des
effets de rattrapage d'ailleurs ce que
vous consommez pas pendant les graines
vous pouvez le consommer
après il y a aussi des effets de
substitution si vous prenez pas le train
ou si vous prenez pas le métro vous avez
peut-être prendre un VTC vous voyez donc
il y a des effets de substitution oui je
comprends mais il y a aussi tous les
coups induits en termes d'image vous
voyez d'image sur la France pour la
France de
face à ses partenaires financiers face à
ses partenaires européens c'est aussi
un coup d'image qui est peut-être plus
difficilement chiff mais de cette
incapacité de la France à se réformer à
rembourser sa dette je vous rappelle que
la France à 3000 milliards d'euros de
dettes et donc certains
pointent
une crainte de risque de d'augmentation
des taux la France elle va encore devoir
augmenter emprunter cette année de
l'ordre de 270 milliards d'euros mais à
quel taux c'est ça c'est ça le vrai coup
vous voyez si les taux augmentent parce
que la France n'arrive pas à se réformer
s'enfonce dans la dette les taux
augmenteront et alors vous allez me dire
bon pour l'opinion ça peut paraître
assez abstrait un peu éloigné mais ça
veut dire quoi c'est très concret ça
veut dire des crédits plus chers pour
les entreprises ça veut dire des prêts
plus élevés pour les pour les
particuliers et donc ça ça risque de
casser l'investissement des entreprises
ça risque de casser la croissance la
consommation des ménages et se reporter
sur l'emploi
er le gouvernement on en parle dans un
instant d'abord on retrouve Damien
canivelle sur le terrain
pour pour faire cesser les coups liés à
la grève mais il y a aussi ce je vous
dis cette histoire de taux d'intérêt
Damien vous êtes sur place alors avant
la grève dure potentielle il y a les
manifestations manifestations dans Paris
aujourd'hui on attend du monde est-ce
qu'il y en a autour de vous on attend
aussi des leaders syndicaux des leaders
politiques
absolument on attend tous ce monde là
bonjour Thibault bonjour à toutes et à
tous je me trouve actuellement au
boulevard Raspail c'est à cet endroit
normalement que la manifestation doit
s'élancer c'est même plus précisément
d'en faire Rochereau juste derrière moi
mais je peux vous dire que nous avons
marché de longues minutes avec François
le cadreur qui se tient juste derrière
la caméra et on arrive toujours pas au
niveau de la tête de cortège il y a
énormément de monde ici sur ce boulevard
Raspail vous le voyez juste derrière moi
ce sont les étudiants qui donnent de la
voix c'est ce qui peut être et aussi un
peu différent par rapport aux dernières
manifestations que l'on a pu suivre sur
Figaro live c'est tout c'est toutes ces
écoles toutes ces universités qui se
sont mobilisés pour battre le pavé
aujourd'hui on a vu des slogans voilà
pour
contre la réforme des retraites des
écoles d'architecture notamment qui sont
mobilisés contre ce projet de loi il y a
également l'université de la Sorbonne
Nouvelle qu'on a vu tout à l'heure en
passant pour rejoindre la tête de
cortège bref énormément de monde il y a
aussi des SL ogans tels que vous venez
de l'entendre Macron démission qui somme
toute son un petit peu plus classique
voilà la police attend ici entre 60 000
et 90 000 manifestants ce qui serait un
petit peu en deçà de ce qu'on a pu
connaître le 11 février puisque le 11
février c'était un record ici à Paris il
y avait 93000 manifestants
merci d'Amiens Canivez on vous retrouve
tout à l'heure et évidemment vous
n'hésitez pas à interviewer interroger
tous ceux qui se trouvent autour de vous
qui veulent bien de prendre la parole
pour nous expliquer pourquoi ils sont en
grève aujourd'hui et pourquoi ils
manifestent le gouvernement qui est donc
face à cette double problématique
Marie-Cécile il a envie que cette
réforme aille au bout mais c'est grave
elle coûte cher
pour sortir bah il est un peu piégé
parce que effectivement
le blocage du pays
coûte cher et puis retirer le projet de
loi ça coûte encore plus cher ça je vous
rappelle que cette réforme elle est
faite quand même pour
mettre d'aplomb les finances pour
combler un déficit qui s'élèvera 13,5
milliards d'euros en 2030
qu'il y a le gouvernement a fait des
concessions des concessions à répétition
de plus en plus coûteuses d'ailleurs
maintenant on se demande même si la
réforme suffira enfin si la réforme
couvrira la totalité du déficit
Olivier du socle qui a dit ça pourrait
oui et on pourrait avoir toujours un
petit déficit de 300 à 400 millions
d'euros le gouvernement commence à
assumer en disant on est encore des
visiteurs en 2030 mais beaucoup moins
alors ça va alors ce sera beaucoup moins
de les 13,5 milliards ce sera de l'or
300-400 millions c'est vrai que beaucoup
moins mais mais enfin cette réforme qui
était faite pour remettre les les
finances d'aplomb à force d'avoir cédé à
force d'avoir cédé du terrain
d'avoir lâché et bien voilà les ce
fameux équilibre de la réforme auquel le
gouvernement quand même s'accrochait
qu'il défendait qu'il affirmait
maintenir bien on s'aperçoit que et on
n'est pas encore à la fin du du débat
parlementaire on s'aperçoit que on y est
déjà plus or je vous rappelle que on
s'arrête à 2030 mais que le déficit il
se creuse encore derrière parce que
l'effet l'effet âge sa menuisera et puis
le déficit s'accentue donc on sait
d'ores et déjà que il faudra y revenir
que ça n'est pas une réforme définitive
donc voilà
ces journées de grève qui
les manifs
la frange radicale des manifestants des
des syndicats l'objectif c'est de que ça
coûte si cher au pays que le
gouvernement soit obligé de renoncer
mais je vous le disais tout à l'heure
retirez le projet ça coûte aussi très
cher que ça va coûter très cher en
termes de taux d'intérêt de capacité de
la France à continuer à emprunter de
l'argent et ça c'est ça ça va être très
difficile pour l'instant tous les
syndicats ne sont pas favorables à ce
blocage total même la direction de la
CGT il n'y appelle pas directement il a
sous-entendre que oui c'est ce qu'il
faudrait faire mais pour l'instant on
reste dans cette union inter syndicale
avec ce respect du choix de la CFDT de
ne pas entrer dans ce genre de grève oui
mais tout en disant qu'il y aura des
nouvelles
formes d'expression que il faut quand
même se faire comprendre durcir le
mouvement et c'est un peu la
responsabilité des syndicats si vous
voulez ils ont appelé les gens à
descendre dans la rue ils ont
fait monter cette cette contestation et
maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on fait de cette
de cette colère qui s'exprime dans la
rue
c'est bien la responsabilité des
syndicats après avoir fait descendre les
gens de
aussi
de répondre à ces gens qui sont dans la
rue effectivement mais là on a vraiment
l'impression de chacun campe sur ces
positions et il n'y a pas de depuis le
début il y a pas de de débat possible
puisque chacun est dans dans sa ligne
d'eau et ne regarde pas il y a pas de on
a constaté l'échec du dialogue social
donc le gouvernement justement il
prenait presque un air supérieur lors de
ses premières journées de mobilisation
dans bravo vous avez mis du monde dans
la rue bravo cher syndicats mais nous on
continue est-ce que en cas de
de blocage ça se corse est-ce que le
gouvernement peut et bien prendre les
choses différemment apporter de
nouvelles solutions et quels sont ces
solutions potentielles ils ont déjà
beaucoup beaucoup apporté de solutions
donc
je rappelle qu'il y a eu donc toutes les
mesures sur les carrières longues
l'extension des personnes concernées
il y a eu bon là apparemment le Sénat a
voté une mesure sur le les maires de
famille bon il y a eu une retraite les
1200 euros donc il y a eu qui sont
appliqués non seulement au futur
retraités mais aussi aux retraités déjà
voilà c'est pas très joli mais c'est ça
voilà le stock donc les les personnes
déjà en retraite et puis les nouvelles
bref ils ont déjà
lâcher beaucoup de terrain je c'est
compliqué pour eux de continuer
maintenant non je pense que ce que le
gouvernement espère c'est
arriver à
à ce que le texte soit accepté
maintenant le plus vite possible les des
syndicats légitimistes
au Parlement donc après le passage au
Sénat le texte ira en commission mixte
paritaire donc là il pourrait
éventuellement être accepté
et dans ce cas les syndicats
comme la CFDT qui sont légitimistes qui
une fois qu'un texte est voté et bien ma
foi
se range derrière le vote souverain du
Parlement
voilà à chaque fois il y a des il y a
des manifestations pour toutes les
réformes des retraites je vous rappelle
que en 2019 il y avait eu quand même
blocage quasiment d'un mois avec des
greffes durs et bien le texte avait été
voté en première lecture à l'Assemblée
alors certes via le 49-3 avec le 49-3
bon il était arrivé en
il était arrivé au Sénat et il a été
bloqué parce qu'il y a eu le covid mais
bon il était sur sa lancée et
donc là on va voir vraiment le texte
poursuit son chemin parlementaire
devrait être adopté et
et à partir de ce moment là les
mouvements pourraient se dégonfler alors
la CGT on ne s'affirme jamais on accepte
jamais je les responsables de la CGT
disent nous on sera toujours contre on
est pour la retraite à 60 ans et on
continuera à défendre ces mesures mais
on retourne sur le terrain avec Timothée
Timothée alors on sait que c'est cortège
en parfois du mal à se lancer Timothée
est-ce que vous êtes parti depuis
Sèvres Babylone alors ce n'est pas
vraiment une place c'était pas un
endroit très facile pour lancer un
cortège non
je peux être à la cam pour garder la
batterie tu peux pas passer maintenant
il est très étalé sur plusieurs
centaines de mètres en réalité là on
vient de remonter le cortège avec Julien
Leclerc vous le voyez encore beaucoup de
monde devant nous ce qui veut dire que
nous ne sommes pas encore arrivé en tête
de cortège beaucoup beaucoup de monde
cet après-midi vous le voyez cette foule
assez compact qui qui est en train et
bien de défiler derrière nous voilà
beaucoup de monde ce que je peux vous
dire aussi c'est que à vue d'oeil on a
vu beaucoup de jeunes davantage que lors
des précédentes mobilisations on est
également vu des sapeurs-pompiers voilà
il semble que voilà des jeunes des moins
jeunes des sapeurs-pompiers c'est vrai
qu'on a l'impression que la mobilisation
est assez forte cet après-midi on va
continuer de et bien de voir ça essayer
d'aller en interroger certains vous le
voyez en tout cas derrière moi beaucoup
de panneaux beaucoup de pancartes voilà
beaucoup de monde aujourd'hui dans les
dans les rues de Paris alors que on
craignait que la pluie est bien ne tombe
cet après-midi pour l'instant pour
l'instant il ne pleut pas et il fait
même plutôt bon plutôt doux dans les
rues de la capitale
merci merci Timothée Delem
on souhaite qu'il n'y ait pas de pluie
évidemment on fait un peu de technique
Marie-Cécile s'il vous plaît c'est que
c'est parfois compliqué est-ce que c'est
très forme elle ressemble à celle du
tout début alors où on se parle est-ce
que le texte a été modifié assez
largement ou non on garde l'essentiel de
la de la réforme reste sur
l'architecture de la réforme il y a eu
donc des concessions qui ont été faites
coûteuses je les souligné
donc c'est ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure il y a eu sur les carrières
longues sur les carrières longues donc
cette histoire des 44 ans de cotisations
et donc on a ramené ces personnes à 43
ans de cotisation ça ça a été une
première concession il y a eu ce dont on
a parlé tout à l'heure sur les 1200
euros qui de retraite minimale qui
s'appliquera pour une pour une carrière
complète à temps plein qui s'appliquera
pour les retraités déjà partis ce qu'on
appelle le stock j'ai pas simplement les
nouveaux retraités ce qu'on appelle le
flux
il y a également cette
réforme cette ce point sur les maires de
famille qui pourraient c'est ce
qu'aboter le Sénat avoir une une petite
bonus de pension puisque leur trimestre
pour enfant ne leur serviront des facto
plus à rien avec le recul de l'âge ça
c'est une petite avant les 64 ans parce
qu'elles avaient assez d'années de
cotisations grâce à ces trimestres
accumulées lorsqu'on a un enfance
à l'heure actuelle l'âge de départ est
de 62 ans beaucoup de femmes peuvent
partir à 62 ans à taux plein grâce à
leur trimestre de
maternités
au nom de la maternité finalement ne
servent plus à rien donc
ce droit ce bénéfice qu'elles avaient
tombent et donc pour compenser le Sénat
qui est favorable à une politique
démographique à une politique familiale
à compensé partiellement parce que ça ça
compense pas totalement mais a mis en
place pour une un petit bonus une
surcotte qui pourrait être au maximum de
5% quel que soit le nombre d'enfants
voilà
et donc oui donc le texte en lui-même
sur son architecture n'a pas varié
fondamentalement depuis sa présentation
le 10 janvier par Elisabeth borne mais
c'est compliqué un texte de réforme des
retraites vous changez pas comme ça un
chapitre c'est quelque chose tous ces
fonds
de retraite il est le fruit de
l'histoire il est fait d'empilement etc
donc dès que vous tirez un fil toute la
toute la pyramide s'effondre on dit
souvent que le diable se niche dans le
détail dans le social mais c'est c'est
la réalité
on va bientôt retrouver on est à
Bordeaux dans un sens qu'il y a des
manifestations à Paris vous le voyez sur
ces images on a partout en France et on
essaiera de savoir ce qu'il s'est passé
à à Bordeaux en l'état actuel des choses
quelle est la tendance pour que cette
réforme soit adoptée si vous deviez
donner un chiffre Marie Cécile 60 40 55
ans ou non quand même le gouvernement a
plutôt la main
je pense qu'on est le gouvernement a
plutôt la main il y a toujours eu des
mobilisations fortes pour toutes les
toutes les réformes des retraites mais
je pense que bien sûr qu'on vous a tous
les sondages montrent que les Français
ne sont pas favorables à cette réforme
personne n'est n'accepte de guetter de
cœur et encore de travailler deux ans de
plus mais je pense qu'il y a aussi une
forme de résignation chez les Français
et qu'ils ont bien compris que nécessité
fait loi et que donc toute façon enfin
quand je vois les jeunes qui manifestent
dans la rue je suis toujours étonnée
parce que cette réforme elle est quand
même faite pour eux si on ne fait pas
cette réforme et alors ça veut dire
notamment l'idée du soft en disant que
sa plateforme était de gauche et qu'elle
était sociale et elle a du mal à être
acceptée
ça veut dire que les jeunes
d'aujourd'hui nos auront des pensions
tellement faible enfin très très faible
demain ou alors on réduit la pension de
nos parents qui veut réduire la pension
de ces parents et qui veut amputer celle
de ses enfants personne donc bon bah
qu'est-ce que vous voulez il y a pas
d'autres solutions que travailler plus
longtemps ou alors il y a il y a
un dossier qui est monté qui n'est pas
dans la réforme paradoxalement qui n'est
pas dans la réforme de la retraite c'est
la capitalisation
un sujet qui qui révulte en parle mettre
une part de capitalisation
et ce sujet ce sujet pour tout le monde
la capitalisation le système actuel
français on répartition sont les actifs
qui paient la pension des des retraités
actuels donc vos cotisations elles ne
sont pas pour vous elles sont pour payer
les pensions les retraites sont utilisés
tout de suite pour le payer les
retraites des personnes
des retraités avec un système en
capitalisation vous mettez chaque mois
des cotisations de côté dans une caisse
qui fructifie et ça c'est pour vous
c'est pour vous pour votre retraite
alors donc vous allez me dire c'est
assez injuste parce que ceux qui peuvent
épargner qui peuvent capitaliser mettre
de côté ils auront une grosse retraite
et ceux qui peuvent pas ben ils n'auront
rien ben oui donc le système paraît
partition il est plus solidaire si vous
voulez qu'un système par capitalisation
et et
mais donc si c'est la solution qui qui
aboutit une fine les personnes qui
manifestent dans la rue auront tout
perdu merci beaucoup Marie-Cécile Renaud
merci de nous avoir éclairé d'avoir
lancé ce live avec nous parler des
personnes qui manifestaient dans la rue
bien on va retrouver une elle est avec
Timothée Delam Timothée
que soit ces gens est-ce qu'ils croient
encore ces manifestants au retrait de
cette réforme
et bien on va le leur poser la question
bonjour madame vous êtes vous avez fait
toutes les manifestations me disiez vous
depuis le début vous croyez encore que
cette réforme peut être retirée oui
absolument parce que je pense que
l'intelligence va leur porter et je le
pense que le Président de la République
même s'il est tenu par
les gens qui lui demandent de faire
cette retraite un moment donné il va
quand même dire bah non c'est
complètement stupide je vais pas me
mettre tout le monde à dos et personne
n'aide n'aime ne pas être aimé surtout
quand on est président de la République
vous me confiez à l'instant que vous
êtes déjà retraités vous n'êtes donc pas
directement concerné par cette réforme
alors effectivement on pourrait penser
que je ne suis pas concernée mais je
pense qu'avec tout ce qu'il peut y avoir
il risque d'y avoir une énième
comment dire est-ce proposition de
réforme
siècle on en soit encore là enfin je
veux dire la France est un pays prospère
riche
et je pense que c'est tout le monde le
dit enfin je veux dire je ne serai pas
la seule tout en étant pas au corps ni
économiste on sait tous qu'il n'y a pas
matière à faire une réforme de ce type
peut-être une autre n'est pas celle-là
mais alors quand Emmanuel Macron dit
cette réforme des retraites elle est
absolument nécessaire pour sauver notre
système par répartition selon vous il se
trompe il ment alors il ne ment pas ils
ne se trompe pas mais il a quelque chose
d'autre à proposer lui voudrait à mon
avis il voudrait proposer que les gens
payent leur retraite c'est à dire que
non seulement on fasse des économies on
ne sait plus comment et bien que on paye
aussi nos retraites et qu'on aille chez
les assureurs tout simplement que tous
tout le patrimoine de tous les gens qui
se sont battus et ben ça s'écroule
pour une poignée personne maintenant je
vois pas l'intérêt ça marche très bien
comme ça maintenant je ne vois pas
pourquoi détruire enfin peut-être que je
suis très bête
voilà Thibault pour pour cette
manifestante et vous le voyez ce cortège
qui continue d'avancer derrière nous
cortège assez fourni cet après-midi
beaucoup beaucoup de slogans beaucoup de
drapeaux et voilà une ambiance pour
l'instant plutôt plutôt bonne pour ces
manifestants qui sont donc partis dans
les rues de Paris pour rejoindre cette
place de cette place d'Italie merci
beaucoup
bonjour jean-y bonjour ma vie au service
économique spécialiste des transports
c'est un peu le bazar ce matin ah oui on
va en parler mais d'abord
plus facile pour nous la connexion
Bordeaux Paris que contrat j'encyton
vous êtes dans la manifestation
bordelaise Jean merci d'être avec nous
comment ça se passe est-ce qu'il y a du
monde aussi à Bordeaux est-ce que ça se
déroule dans le calme
[Musique]
alors dans le calme j'irai pas jusque là
à Bordeaux les manifestations sont plus
bon enfant que dans d'autres grandes
villes aujourd'hui les forces de l'ordre
ont quand même noté des dégradations
elle parle pas véritablement de Black
Bloc mais personne habillée en noir là
c'est assez brillant derrière moi en
tant que synthèse quelques
échaufferais mais pas de pas
d'altération direct avec les forces de
l'ordre pour l'instant
ce qu'il y a du monde autour de vous
gens quelle est la densité de la de la
manifestation même si c'est toujours
difficile d'établir un nombre je le sais
quand on est dans une manif est-ce que
vous qui avez suivi les précédentes
journées de mobilisation vous pouvez
comparer avec les derniers jours c'est
plus c'est moins
alors je pense que c'est pas moi en tout
cas visiblement la dernière le 17
février la préfecture parler de 8000
personnes et les manifestations et les
manifestants de 30000 là c'est sûr qu'on
en a plus que ça elle a été très très
étendue même deux heures après être
parti la fin de manifestation était
quasiment toujours au début il y a pas
encore de chiffres qui ont été donnés ni
par la préfecture ni par les
organisateurs mais c'est sûrement au
moins aussi important que le 11 février
ou le 31 janvier a priori Jean est-ce
que vous pouvez filmer un peu ce qu'il
se passe derrière à vous parce qu'on a
l'impression qu'il y a des gaz
lacrymogènes alors évidemment pas affolé
c'est vous qui nous montrez dans ce
passage m'entend plus bon c'est pas
grave on le retrouvera dans les gens
est-ce que je vois derrière vous des gaz
lacrymogènes est-ce que vous pouvez
filmer ça nous expliquer nous raconter
ce qu'il se passe derrière vous
c'est pas les gaz lacrymogène c'est des
manifestants qui jettent ça
des fumigènes visiblement bon jean merci
beaucoup vous nous dites qu'à Bordeaux
la manifestation se déroule plutôt dans
le calme derrière on entend des pétards
mais ce ne sont pas des gaz lacrymogènes
et puis on vous suit évidemment sur le
live stage du figaro.fr et toutes les
infos toutes les photos et on aura dans
l'après-midi le nombre de manifestants à
Bordeaux merci Jean votre Jean-Yves
Guérin en plateau Jean-Yves bon le bazar
ce matin on peut faire un point sur sur
la situation dans les dans les
transports ça a donné quoi alors la
situation c'est que comme il était prévu
d'abord si vous preniez le le train en
ligne il y en avait pas beaucoup hein un
TGV sur sur 5 ou soit ouigo ou inouï
c'était conforme aux prévisions mais
c'est très très peu pour aller à
Bordeaux à Lyon à Lille etc et alors par
rapport précédentes journées de
mobilisation ça c'est du niveau
c'est du niveau du 19 janvier
c'est-à-dire la première journée de
d'action contre la forme des retraites
dans la rue mais beaucoup de gens en
grève ouais tout à fait donc là on
retrouve faut pas préjugés de
visiblement le mouvement et très suivi
mais on n'a pas encore les les chiffres
des manifestants mais en tout cas il y a
une mobilisation qui est qui est très
forte pourquoi parce que d'abord ça fait
un mois véritablement qu'il y a pas eu
un mouvement il y a eu la trêve des des
vacances
se refaire entre Guille mets
voilà il y a quand même des tensions sur
le sur le pouvoir d'achat l'inflation
etc les prix des quand on fait ses
courses ou encore augmenter de 10% là en
mars donc c'est pas si évident que ça de
faire grève tous les jours etc on est le
premier jour
d'un mouvement de grève qui est présenté
par les syndicats comme une grève
reconductive c'est la deuxième mi-temps
ou le match retour d'une certaine
manière on a eu la première partie
janvier février avant les vacances grève
sèche une journée et puis on apprend le
travail là on peut entrer dans autre
chose là on peut entrer dans autre chose
en tout cas c'est ce que souhaite c'est
ce que souhaite les syndicats
[Musique]
on est plus dur que les confédérations
traduction
la CGT chemineau va plutôt poussé pour
qu'il y ait une grève renouvelable tous
les jours encore plus que Philippe
Martinez celui qu'on connaît à la CGT le
décalage il est encore plus fort je
dirais à la CFDT c'est que Laurent
Berger le patron de la Confédération
en revanche la base appelle à un conflit
tous les jours et à une grève
renouvelable d'accord donc ça illustre
bien le fait que il y a une il y a un
bastion
d'entreprises publiques où on recourt
plus facilement je dirais un mouvement
continu et renouvelable donc vous allez
nous expliquer pourquoi c'est presque
traditionnel d'abord on ressent sur le
terrain Damien Canivez vous êtes devant
un lieu emblématique de la MA cronie
c'est bien ça
absolument la rotonde pour ne pas citer
cet établissement ou Emmanuel Macron a
dîné le soir de son élection
présidentielle c'était souvenez-vous en
2017 c'est pour ça que vous voyez
actuellement des forces de l'ordre
devant cet établissement parce que il
faut bien savoir que les policiers les
gendarmes sont en nombre ici ils sont
très présents mais on ne les voit pas
pour sans doute de pas attiser une
certaine colère de la part des
manifestants les plus radicaux pour être
plus rapide nous avons remonté le
cortège en prenant une rue parallèle au
boulevard Raspail et ils sont là les
policiers ils sont dans des rues
parallèles invisibles mais cette fois-ci
ils sont visibles pour justement éviter
tout débordement et éviter bien
évidemment que que ce restaurant soit
saccagé alors nous avons donc rejoint la
tête de cortège et il y a quelques
instants nous avons vu Philippe Martinez
qui est passé voilà le leader de la CGT
avec les autres syndicats qui sont il
faut dire encore une fois de plus unis
pour cette journée de mobilisation avec
Frédéric Souillot par exemple le leader
de Force Ouvrière et puis tous ces
confrères de la CFC François homery ou
encore de la CFTC Cyril Chabanier et
puis sans oublier bien évidemment
Laurent Berger de la CFDT tous ces
syndicats sont unis on a vu également
des partis politiques Lutte Ouvrière la
France insoumise pour ne citer que ils
sont passés les uns à côté des autres
mais sans forcément se mélanger il faut
savoir que les syndicats n'ont pas
forcément l'intention d'être associé aux
partis politiques qui ont été assez
décriés ces dernières semaines en raison
du taux Hubohu qu'il y a eu à
l'Assemblée nationale Laurent Berger
avait d'ailleurs même publié un tweet le
soir du dernier débat à l'Assemblée
nationale en indiquant que le spectacle
était assez lamentable donc voilà ici à
peu près pour l'ambiance la
manifestation se déroule dans une
ambiance cordiale avec comme vous pouvez
l'entendre de la musique et parfois même
des musiciens qui essayent à la guitare
merci merci beaucoup Damien Canivez vous
avez une mission interviewée Philippe
Martinez si vous l'avez vu passer on
aimerait bien voir sa réaction sur le
Figaro live Jean-Yves Guillard on
continue à parler de ces grèves dans les
transports vous me dites que dans les
fédérations de cheminots on est plus dur
pourquoi c'est traditionnel il y a une
culture de la grève du rapport de force
dans ces fédération là ils ont plus à
perdre alors expliquez-moi pourquoi
parce que en 2019 le comprenais très
bien avec cette question des régimes
spéciaux là c'est traditionnellement pas
ils ont traditionnellement plus à perdre
parce que ils ont traditionnellement des
avantages
que n'ont pas les salariés du privé
d'accord la SNCF ça appartient 100% à
l'état la RATP ça appartient 100% à
l'état à ce titre là alors on l'a
beaucoup entendu mais je le je le répète
les
cheminots en tout cas ceux qui étaient
embaucher avant 2020 il y a eu un
changement 2020 il bénéficiait d'un
régime spécial de retraite d'accord ça
veut dire que en moyenne
ils partent un conducteur par à la
retraite à 56 57 ans ce qu'il faut
retenir c'est que il y a 50 décalages à
peu près entre quelqu'un du privé un
conducteur de de bus du privé un
chauffeur routier du privé d'accord qui
part à 62 ans comme tout le monde et un
conducteur de deux trains
donc
évidemment quand on agite le spectre de
supprimer ou de ratiboiser les régimes
spéciaux
ils ont beaucoup pas perdre donc il y a
des mobilisations qui sont très fortes
1995 pendant trois semaines il y a pas
de train il y a pas de métro et je vais
recul non donc et Juppé et je suis
recule d'accord de 2010 énorme énorme
mobilisation encore pour les retraites
ces gouvernements Fillon et finalement
le gouvernement ne recule pas comme quoi
la rue peut être très puissante
et pour autant une réforme peut peut
passer donc là il y a masse mais le fer
de lance de toute contestation d'une
réforme des retraites c'est les
transports c'est souvent les transports
comment ça s'est passé ces dernières
semaines vous me disiez vous étiez venus
sur ce plateau précédente manifestation
qui va rester tapis dans l'ombre les les
cheminots qui voulaient entrer en grève
mais pas forcément à fond
on a changé de braquet ou pas encore
alors là on est au milieu du on est au
début de la deuxième mi-temps j'aime
bien le j'aime bien l'image
et
on sait pas véritablement si vous
rentrez dans le match à fond ou pas je
m'explique
juste avant d'arriver en plateau j'étais
avec le patron l'UNSA ferrovia cette
deuxième syndicat la SNCF CGT et puis il
y a l'une ça ferroviaire
en France mais qui n'est pas la CFDT et
le quatrième syndicat donc
on va voilà la CFDT est moins fort ce
que dit l'INSA donc l'une ça c'est un
syndicat réformiste un peu comme la CFDT
d'accord
ceux qui disent eux c'est oui on appelle
à une grève renouvelable
on est sûr que il y a très fort
participatif taux de participation
aujourd'hui on le voit dans les rues
demain on est sûr que effectivement la
grève va continuer elle a été votée elle
a été revotée à la gare du Nord
on revote le soir même dans chaque gare
de travail attrape par exemple trap en
banlieue en banlieue parisienne d'accord
en revanche
si ils ont une visibilité ces élus
syndicaux sur aujourd'hui et demain au
delà ils ne savent pas pourquoi parce
que
vous avez beau lancer des mots d'ordre
et bien ça se décide à la base et ça se
décide jour par jour dans des assemblées
générales au plus près du terrain
on ne sait pas si de quel côté va
retomber la pièce pour ces gens là parce
que encore une fois il y a quand même
l'inflation d'un côté et de l'autre côté
il y a une exaspération de devoir
travailler de temps et c'est pour ça que
c'est très indécique et la réaction du
gouvernement je pense à Clément bonne le
ministre des Transports
qu'est-ce qu'il nous dit parce qu'il
redoute lui ce qui nous dit c'est
d'abord il essaye d'éviter la sortie de
route pour ne pas exciter
les syndicats et les cheminots de ce
point de vue là les les sorties par
exemple d'Olivier Veyron consistant à
dire que c'était dans la forme de gauche
ou du porte-parole du
de du somme pardon disons que c'était
une réforme de gauche
disons que ce serait une catastrophe
écologique de faire de faire la grève
pas super à droite nous l'avons veille
c'est pas très grave
lui ne fait pas de déclaration comme ça
parce qu'il sait très bien que ça ne
sert à rien pour l'instant il parle
juste aux usagers alors lui il parle il
parle plus directement au
cheminots que ne le font les autres le
ministre du Travail il parle à
l'ensemble des Français
le ministre des Transports il parle à
vous et à moi et il dit bah oui je
compatis ça va être compliqué dans les
transports merci merci mais pour
l'instant il sait que ça sert pas à
grand chose là aujourd'hui c'est la
journée des syndicats
la seule question c'est ils sont combien
et est-ce qu'ils peuvent tenir longtemps
et est-ce qu'ils ont les syndicats ont
envie de tenir longtemps est-ce que ils
vont être suivis par leurs troupes
le gouvernement attend le gouvernement
attend et nous aussi Damien canivelle on
vous retrouve sur le terrain vous êtes
avec avec une élue c'est bien ça
oui absolument je suis avec Céline
Malaisie présidente du groupe communiste
à la région Île-de-France bonjour merci
de répondre à nos questions est-ce que
première question déjà la mobilisation
est à la hauteur de vos espérances
aujourd'hui c'est une journée de
mobilisation qui est énorme on a alors
des chiffres que je ne connais pas
encore mais rien qu'à la vue rien
qu'auchi qui nous sont montés aussi des
mêmes des manifestations ce matin on est
vraiment dans une journée mobilisation
historique et qui signifie que la colère
est vraiment très importante et qui
Emmanuel Macron n'a plus qu'un seul
choix c'est d'écouter ce que veulent les
Français c'est à dire le retrait de
cette réforme le risque avec les
vacances scolaires c'est que le
mouvement s'essouffle or là on se rend
compte qu'il y a énormément de monde
est-ce que ça veut dire que c'est une
bonne augure pour la suite de la
mobilisation selon vous
après tout dépend des manuel Macron
c'est lui en fait qui bloque le pays le
gouvernement et lui ont pris la décision
de faire une réforme dont personne ne
veut voilà il s'entête plus il sentait
plus la colère qu'on prendra plus les
grèves seront d'importantes il n'y a
plus qu'un seul choix qui nous est
possibilité maintenant c'est de retirer
cette réforme qu'est-ce qui vous dérange
dans cette réforme très concrètement
cette réforme est une réforme qui ne
fait que des perdants contrairement à ce
que le gouvernement et la première
ministre disent tout le monde va devoir
travailler deux ans de plus pour des
pensions qui seront moindres et en fait
c'est en concert un nouveau coin dans la
retraite par système de répartition pour
casser le droit à la retraite ça n'est
qu'une étape pour aller vers une
retraite vers la capitalisation et ça
nous on en veut pas certains syndicats
se sont déjà prononcés pour la conduite
du mouvement et des grèves
reconductibles est-ce que vous êtes
favorable à une un durcissement
davantage encore de durcir davantage le
mouvement
syndicale est uni comme elle n'a jamais
été unie dans l'histoire du mouvement
social très récem enfin depuis très
longtemps c'est une Anders syndicale qui
fonctionne bien qui explique que le
blocage du pays et quelque chose d'obli
enfin de finalement de contraints
aujourd'hui à l'appel à des conduction
de grève dans plein de secteurs
finalement on relève la tête ce n'est
pas mettre à genoux l'économie c'est
relever la tête et la balle est dans le
camp de ceux qui peuvent finalement
retirer cette réforme là merci beaucoup
c'est une Malaisie je rappelle que vous
êtes présidente du groupe communiste en
région Île-de-France
merci Damien Canivez de d'avoir et c'est
entendre la parole des manifestants et
des élus qui sont qui sont dans le
cortège-guérin c'est les transports au
Figaro question très simple j'ai un
train vendredi soir est-ce que je vais
pouvoir le prendre ou non
et bien ça on le saura
la veille la veille alors on va attendre
jour par jour pour
en gros comment ça marche dans des
entreprises publiques ceux qui veulent
faire grève doivent se déclarer 48
heures avant d'accord donc par exemple
le trafic
d'aujourd'hui on en a eu une idée
puisque la SNCF et la RATP ont
communiqué dimanche soir en disant il y
aura quatre TGV sur cinq annulés donc il
y en a que 20% qui circuleront d'accord
mais précisément c'est la veille que ils
envoient des SMS en disant Paris
Bordeaux supprimer ou pas d'accord
est-ce que les les syndicats ont la main
sur les cheminots j'entends et je
rappelle ce qu'il s'est passé à Noël
syndicat n'appelait pas la grève
certains cheminots ont fait grève qui
décide parce que Philippe Martinez a la
moindre
puissance sur ce qui va se passer dans
les dans les transports ou non et
finalement il n'a pas la main et chacun
fait ce qu'il veut ah c'est un système à
trois étages est-ce que c'est Philippe
Martinez de la Confédération qui décide
ben c'est ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure
non
il peut il peut essayer mais
sans vouloir perdre nos auditeurs ou
téléspectateurs il y a un contexte
particulier il y a une élection à la CGT
fin mars c'est quand même Emmanuel
Macron quand on parle à la fin de son
mandat on perd du pouvoir et il se
trouve que
à la CGT Philippe Martinez n'est pas le
plus dur et se trouve que des gens de la
Fédération des cheminots CGT eux ils
sont sur une ligne plus dure que
Martinez Martinez soutient une femme
pour lui succéder qui vient de
l'éducation
et la CGT cheminot eux ils voudraient
quelqu'un de encore plus dur plus à poil
donc ils ont intérêt eux à durcir le
mouvement et si ça marche ils pourront
du coup pousser un candidat à eux de la
politique la politique politicienne mais
il y a aussi ça dans les syndicats je
j'en viens à deux autres secteurs qui
m'intéressent rapidement les
transporteur routiers est-ce qu'il y a
des appels à la grève alors il y a des
il y a des appels à la grève
et il faut pas beaucoup de grévistes
pour bloquer une route
il suffit de mettre un ou deux camions
pour bloquer un rond-point et faire des
embouteillages des embouteillages donc
ils ont un vrai pouvoir de nuisance
ils sont déjà il y a déjà eu des
conflits où ils étaient effectivement il
bloquait la France mais quand même
beaucoup plus rarement que les cheminots
ou les salariés à la RATP parce que
salarié d'entreprise privée c'est ça la
sécurité de plus difficile de faire
grève plus difficile de faire autre
secteur rapidement Jean-Yves l'aérien
n'en parle pas trop les pilotes ils font
en grève ou non est-ce que les
personnels au sol font grève ou non
alors les pilotes ne font pas grève
parce que comme les avocats comme un
certain nombre de
professions
ils sont en train de négocier de leur
côté
l'aménagement
il joue perso de toute façon les pilotes
jouent souvent personne pour la défense
de leur propre intérêts maintenant les
personnels les personnels au sol d'Air
France ou d'autres compagnies eux ils se
comportent comme des salariés
j'allais dire classique c'est-à-dire que
vous allez avoir une mobilisation
chez Air France réel
que ce n'est pas une entreprise d'État
mais c'est une entreprise où l'État a
quand même 28 % d'accord donc c'est pas
tout à fait une boîte privée classique
aussi sont c'est pas comme la SNCF
mais disons que il peut y avoir une
mobilisation pour l'instant ça se
traduit pas ça se traduit par des
retards
pas de gros blocage dans les aéroports
merci puis on suivra évidemment
Jean-Yves pas le temps s'il faut qu'on
enchaîne mais ce qui se passe dans les
raffineries parce que ça c'est très
important les transports les plus le
plus commun finalement la voiture et
nous verrons là aussi des questions à ce
sujet est-ce qu'on aura du carburant
pour faire le plein pour l'instant oui
pour l'instant si nous en aurons encore
dans une deux trois semaines merci
beaucoup Jean-Yves on retourne sur le
terrain Timothée delhem je vois beaucoup
de force de l'ordre derrière vous
oui beaucoup de beaucoup de CRS vous les
voyez là sur sur ces images plusieurs
plusieurs dizaines de CRS qui sont donc
en train d'avancer là on se trouve
vraiment tout devant tout devant de la
manifestation le cortège qui se trouve
derrière nous et vous les voyez là les
manifestants avec le cortège syndical
qui lui se trouve encore à quelques
mètres derrière d'ailleurs on ne
distingue pas ce stade les ballons et
les pancartes des manifestants ici vous
les voyez donc les CRS certains sont en
calotte d'autres pardon ont sorti leur
casque avec les visières et je discutais
avec l'un d'entre eux à l'instant qui
m'expliquait un petit peu le le
dispositif en fait ils ont des collègues
qui se trouvent dans les rues adjacentes
et qui voit sur les images de sur leurs
écrans et bien l'avancée du cortège et
donc vous l'entendez peut-être de temps
en temps un coup de sifflet du chef qui
qui leur dit à tous de s'arrêter l'idée
c'est de garder une distance avec la
tête de cortège je lui quelle distance
il me dit il y a pas de règle en fait
c'est vraiment du discernement en
fonction de l'évolution du cortège en
fonction des éventuels tensions ou non
et donc voilà évidemment ils sont en
communication avec les avec le leur les
moyens qui sont à leur disposition avec
leurs collègues qui se trouve donc dans
le cortège ceux qui se trouvent dans les
rues adjacentes pour et bien essayer de
contrôler au maximum l'avancée de ce de
ce cortège qui pour l'instant se déroule
dans le calme en tout cas ce que nous
nous constatons c'est que les choses se
déroulent voilà assez tranquillement ici
et puis un dernier mot pour peut-être
pour vous situer ici c'est le l'hôpital
du Port-Royal donc on vient de quitter
il y a quelques minutes maintenant le
boulevard du Montparnasse nous
trouverons actuellement au niveau donc
sur le boulevard du Port-Royal l'idée
c'est de continuer à avancer encore sur
environ 1 km là nous pourrons bifurquer
sur l'avenue des Gobelins et enfin faire
quelques quelques centaines de mètres
pour arriver sur cette place d'Italie le
point d'arrivée le point final de cette
manifestation
merci Timothée delaime voilà vous avez
toute la géographie parisienne pour
suivre cette manifestation et on voit
ses forces de l'ordre qui n'ont pas mis
leur casque souvent c'est bon signe du
déroulé des manifestations bonjour
Arthur Végéta bonjour Thibault bonjour à
tous ici journaliste au figata bon il y
a un record à battre aujourd'hui pour
les pour les syndicats tout à fait le
record c'est celui du 31 janvier celui
ces mobilisations qui avait réunies 1,27
millions de personnes à travers toute la
France donc le 31 janvier c'était le 31
janvier donc l'objectif aujourd'hui
l'objectif affiché par les syndicats que
ce soit la CFDT la CGT la CFTC c'est de
battre ce record et de mobiliser encore
un peu plus que le 31 janvier je
rappelle que ce sont les chiffres
officiels ce sont les chiffres des
préfectures effectivement les chiffres
ce sur lesquels vous basez au fil de la
table parce que évidemment des cabinets
indépendants les chiffres des syndicats
bon on a décidé de se baser sur les
chiffres officiels de architecture et
donc du ministère de l'Intérieur
vous savez donner quoi les cinq
premières journées de mobilisation il y
a eu des vagues c'était pas ça n'a pas
ça n'a pas été aussi Liné que souhaitait
par les syndicats on a d'abord eu deux
premières manifestations au-dessus du
million de de de personnes mobilisées
dans la rue donc une franche réussite le
19 et le 31 janvier et ensuite on a eu
un enchaînement d'une dizaine de jours
avec trois manifestations c'est ça le
mardi 7 le samedi 11 en plein week-end
et le jeudi 16 et ces manifestations
correspondaient également au début des
vacances scolaires en zone A et en zone
B donc on a eu des fluctuations on a eu
757 le 7 février 9 c'est un peu plus bas
vous pouvez le comparer une
manifestation en semaine on pouvait la
comparer aux deux premières journées
donc c'était plus bas plutôt 750 000 à
la place d'un million 100 millions 200
voilà ensuite on a eu la fameuse
manifestation du 11 février le samedi
qui a réuni 963000 personnes selon le
ministère de l'intérieur avec un record
à Paris avec un à Paris donc là on
revenait à des étiages autour du million
donc c'était plutôt une réussite pour
les syndicats et puis ensuite ce jeudi
16 février deux zones étaient en
vacances et la troisième la zone C la
zone parisienne à l'aile lettres ou les
syndicats n'avaient réunis que 440 000
personnes donc là on pouvait pas parler
d'essoufflement mais en tout cas on
pouvait parler d'un effet vacant d'un
effet météo d'une certaine manière et
puis d'un effet pour les grévistes qui
comment dire l'impact de ces greffes qui
commencent à se faire sentir sur la
feuille de paye quand vous faites grève
trois fois au mois de février qui en
plus qui nous compte que 28 jours à la
fin ça peut commencer à faire beaucoup
d'argent bon
aujourd'hui
il est important de montrer qu'il a
toujours du monde dans la rue quelles
sont les prévisions de mobilisation pour
aujourd'hui on a toujours les chiffres
la veille ou voilà l'estimation voilà
les chiffres donnés par notre collègue
Christophe Cornavin qui hier disait que
à Bobo on estimait la mobilisation entre
et 1,4 millions de personnes d'accord
nous aujourd'hui ce qu'on peut dire et
sur ce qu'on a vu déjà dès ce matin
parce qu'il y a des manifestations il y
a des manifestations le matin on a déjà
les chiffres des manifestations à midi
dont on a déjà les chiffres et qu'on
relève au fur et à mesure de la journée
sur le site du Figaro ce qu'on peut dire
c'est que la mobilisation semblerait-je
j'emploie le conditionnel à tes seins
parce que il peut y avoir des inflexions
des changements tout au long de la
journée mais pour le moment on
semblerait avoir une mobilisation
légèrement supérieure à celle du 31 juin
nous on voit une augmentation de 5% donc
de 1,27 on passerait 1,33 1,34 milliers
aux manifestants dans la rue aujourd'hui
nous verrons si ces chiffres se
confirment ce soir alors sur quelle
ville vous vous basez par exemple je
sais pas ce matin je sais pas si vous
allez chiffrer en tête à Nice par
exemple est-ce qu'on a une idée à Nice
tout à fait on a 6000 manifestants selon
la préfecture 30 000 selon les syndicats
un petit peu moins si ma mémoire est
bonne que le 31 janvier 31 janvier
c'était 7000 ce qu'on peut dire en sur
un premier panorama entre guillemets des
grandes villes c'est que les grandes
villes ne mobilisent pas plus que le 31
janvier d'accord les grandes villes
c'est restent dans dans la même
fourchette comme chiffre de ce matin
dans les grandes villes Marseille ni on
a Marseille qui était qui est à 30000
aujourd'hui contre 40 000 de 31 janvier
on a Nantes qui est à 30000 aujourd'hui
contre 28000 le 31 jours comment vous
trouvez une hausse là vous voyez non non
j'ai pas parlé d'eau j'ai parlé d'une
mobilisation semblable dans les grandes
villes oui d'accord mais alors vous
voyez une hausse sur l'ensemble du
territoire ou Mélissa pour cent en plus
ben alors si dans les grandes villes on
perd 10 000 personnes à Marseille par
exemple et on va quand même avoir une
eau effectivement puisque c'est dans les
villes moyennes d'accord je
j'en parle assez régulièrement à ce
micro pour que maintenant vous soyez au
courant les villes moyennes ont plus
mobilisées on a battu de nombreux
records dans des petites villes dans des
sous dans des préfectures je vais vous
citer Guéret préfecture de la Creuse
j'aime beaucoup
est un vrai symbole et je crois qu'on
est passé de 4900 à 7700 manifestants
aujourd'hui donc 6700 pardon 6700 donc
vous voyez de 4900 à 6700 c'est quand
même une belle augmentation je citerai
également Niort dans les Deux-Sèvres
12000 personnes qui défilaient ce matin
Reims 7500 c'est un record également
pour 15500 Bayonne 13000 donc c'est un
civil moyenne là qu'on voit une
véritable augmentation et où on bat
vraiment les records qui étaient établis
le 19 ou le ou le 31 janvier
Lyon par exemple 120 manifestants le 31
janvier et 800 aujourd'hui oui c'est
dans la Drôme la zone Drôme Ardèche est
particulièrement mobilisée contre cette
réforme des retraites donc effectivement
on a on a des petites villes où la
mobilisation parfois double comme ça par
rapport par rapport au record du 31
janvier et puis il y a des importante
comme Brest par exemple 19000 le 31
janvier 23000 aujourd'hui tout à fait la
Bretagne pareil extrêmement mobilisé
contre cette réforme des retraites je
pense également à Lorient où ils ont été
obligés de faire partir deux cortèges
qui se sont réunis ensuite à l'intérieur
de la ville et où l'Inter syndical
annonçait au moins 18000 manifestants ce
qui était quand même un chiffre assez
important Arthur je reviens vers vous
mais d'abord on va sur le terrain on va
dans la manifestation parisienne et on
va en parler des chiffres de la
manifestation parisienne Damien il a du
monde autour de vous est-ce que ça se
passe toujours dans le calme ou pas
vraiment
[Musique]
oui absolument alors ça se passe dans le
calme ce serait mentir que de vous dire
ça puisqu'il y a des feux de poubelle
ici ou là qui sont en train de s'allumer
Thibault après les débordements sont
assez comment dire sporadiques après la
grande question de cette manifestation
c'est de savoir si effectivement la
radicalisation va s'intensifier parce
que une note du renseignement
territorial selon nos confrères du
Figaro que nos confrères du Figaro ont
pu lire indiquent que des éléments
radicaux vont faire partie de cette
manifestation on parle de 400 à 800
gilets jaunes et de 300 à 500 personnes
considéraient comme Black Bloc et ils
viennent de passer devant nos yeux ces
éléments radicaux que l'on peut
reconnaître note avant vous savez à ce à
ce parapluie arc-en-ciel en signe de
ralliement et assez tenu de noir
d'ailleurs on a pu voir des slogans
anarchistes comme sang noir il n'y a
plus d'espoir voilà c'est ce genre de
slogan qu'on a pu lire donc voilà c'est
la grande question après la
manifestation se déroule dans le calme
avec des syndicats qui sont bien rangés
d'ailleurs vous allez voir sur ces
images
que la tête de cortège officiel des
syndicats va arriver avec Frédéric
Martinez qui traîne certainement se
trouve toujours dans ce groupe que vous
voyez que vous voyez à l'écran voilà
nous sommes actuellement boulevard de
Montmartre on va poursuivre notre chemin
direction boulevard de Port-Royal puis
avenue des Gobelins et puis ensuite on
va arriver Place d'Italie pour la fin de
la manifestation
beaucoup ce petit croisement entre
fabrexio de FO et Philippe Martinez de
la CGT que vous venez de nous faire mon
cher Damien qui baise vous pouvez le
retrouver peut-être si vous les voyez
n'hésitez pas à les interviewer à les
filmer voir si tout cela
reste dans une bonne ambiance avec
parfois des tensions entre les entre les
syndicats il faut toujours surveiller
ces villes moyennes dont on parlait il y
a quelques instants Arthur bijouta c'est
quoi une résurgence de ce qu'il s'est
passé il y a 4 ou 5 ans en arrière avec
les gilets jaunes effectivement beaucoup
plus que sur les premières
manifestations aujourd'hui ou les
syndicats ont appelé vraiment à bloquer
le pays à bloquer l'économie on voit ce
qu'on avait pu voir en de à la fin de
l'année 2018 au début de l'année 2019
avec des gens qui se réunissent sur des
ronds-points qui bloquent des routes qui
bloquent des sorties de zone
industrielle qui bloquent des entrées de
zone commerciale qui je pense également
à ces coupures d'électricité dans le
dans la région de Boulogne-sur-Mer ce
matin donc on voit également peut-être
pas de transformation mais en tout cas
un petit changement de ce mouvement
social qui pour l'instant c'était
cantonné à des manifestations plutôt
plutôt bonnes enfants plutôt calme et là
il y a quand même un petit changement il
y a quand même beaucoup plus de blocage
il y a le blocage des routiers il y a
des feux de palette sur certaines routes
etc etc donc il y a il y a quelque chose
d'un peu différent est-ce qu'on décide
de comparaison avec d'autres périodes
d'autres années à quoi vous comparez que
vous prenez ce chiffre 2018
95 c'est toujours compliqué de comparer
les époques mais on a pris quelques on a
pris quelques chiffres il y avait un
million de personnes au maximum en 1995
et la réforme le plan Juppé avait été
retiré il y avait 1,13 millions de
personnes en 2003 et le plan Fillon
était passé oui il y avait 1,23 millions
de personnes en 2010 et le blanc verte
était passé également donc on peut pas
corréler la mobilisation
au retrait ou au vote il me semble qu'il
y avait justement eu moins de monde dans
les rues peut-être mais un blocage total
du pays beaucoup de le blocage pendant
les trois semaines fin novembre et début
décembre et c'est ce qui avait entraîné
le retrait du plan Juppé peut-être ce
qui donne des idées au syndicats qui
veulent aujourd'hui bloquer le pays
plutôt que ces graisses sporadiques à
une semaine d'intervalle c'est peut-être
l'idée ça change que les syndicats
évoquent déjà une nouvelle date de
mobilisation ce serait samedi 11 mars
dans 4 jours et c'est ça mobilisation à
samedi toujours particulier ça veut dire
qu'on ne parle pas forcément
travailleurs on parle à l'ensemble des
Français parce qu'on ne demande pas aux
gens de se mettre en grève il y a moins
de monde qui travaille le samedi vous
avez surveillé les sondages aussi Arthur
alors les Français sont contre la
réforme
donc ils sont plutôt pour la pour la
grève mais ce qu'ils sont contre les
blocages où est-ce qu'ils sont pour les
blocages c'est ça qui est assez
surprenant entre guillemets selon notre
sondage le sondage odoxal Blackbone
consulting pour Le Figaro vous le dites
bien c'est pas si facile docteur
c'est un métier c'est un entraînement on
a environ allez on va dire deux tiers
des Français qui sont contre cette
réforme ça ça nous change absolument pas
on a commencé le baromètre début janvier
c'était 63 on l'a fini mi-février
c'était 68 il y a eu un pic à 71 ça n'a
pas beaucoup changé on peut dire que
deux tiers des Français sont contre
cette réforme et dans tout ça on pose
également la question est-ce que vous
êtes favorable pour aller contre cette
réforme à bloquer le pays à supporter
des blocages des grèves dans les
transports etc et là on voit de manière
peut-être plus surprenante que 60% des
Français sont prêts à ce que le pays
soit bloqué alors d'accord
donc une question donc il peut y avoir
une baisse pas beaucoup des degrés des
degrés différents de dans le sens de ce
qu'il y a un blocage mais effectivement
ça ne baisse pas beaucoup et on a
environ 3 Français sur 5 60 % qui ne
seraient pas contre un blocage pour pour
s'opposer à cette réforme des retraites
merci beaucoup Arthur bijouterie votre
travail et avoir toutes les infos sur le
live sur les flash sur le site du film
qu'est-ce qu'on peut voir une carte avec
les villes par exemple voir une carte
complète qui normalement à la fin de la
journée recensera les les 260
manifestations qui ont lieu en France et
puis une carte spécifique consacrée aux
grandes villes différents flashs
également sur les taux de grévistes donc
voilà on pourrait avoir une autre
estimation du nombre de manifestants en
temps réel et je vous donne un nouveau
chiffre 25000 manifestants à Lyon ça
vient de tomber vous allez sûrement
rentrer ça sur le fil data des chiffres
quasi similaires au mouvement du 31
janvier dernier merci beaucoup Arthur
nous on retourne dans les rues de la
capitale avec avec Timothée Delame
Timothée
que se passe-t-il autour de vous cette
manifestation avance c'est pas toujours
le cas les dernières journées il avait
du mal à partir de son point de départ
alors là ça avance d'autant plus qu'il y
a un petit moment de confusion là et on
va essayer de s'avancer peut-être un
petit peu avec Julien Leclerc on sent le
CET odeur de gaz lacrymogène donc voilà
il y a un moment de tension c'est vrai
qu'on voit pas très très bien parce
qu'il y a beaucoup de monde on va
montrer quand même à la caméra voilà une
forte odeur de gaz lacrymogène dans tous
les cas ça c'est certain et donc les
manifestants qui sont en train et bien
de ce de se disperser c'est certainement
la raison pour laquelle vous avez le
sentiment que le cortège avance assez
vite voilà un moment de confusion avec
une charge là-bas de CRS à l'instant sur
la sur la gauche je vais demander à
Julien
merci beaucoup Timothée delaime faites
attention à vous Christophe Cornavin
nous rejoindra dans un instant
spécialiste des questions de sécurité
service société du Figaro pour analyser
tout ça mais d'abord on parle un peu de
politique bonjour C'est latine bonjour
Merci d'être ici alors il y a eu une
pause dans les grèves à cause notamment
des vacances aujourd'hui c'est un
nouveau test qui a le plus à perdre les
syndicats s'il ne mobilisent pas ou le
gouvernement si ce mouvement prend une
amper folle alors je sais pas qui est le
plus à perdre en tout cas ce qui est
certain c'est qu'aujourd'hui c'est un
peu lors de vérité tant pour le
gouvernement que pour les syndicats pour
les syndicats effectivement ont mis ce
gros on veut mettre la France à l'arrêt
l'économie à genoux donc pour eux là
c'est une démonstration de force
peut-être plus encore que ce qui s'était
passé en janvier c'est la 6e
mobilisation on voit qu'il y a pas eu de
concession qui est qui ont été faites
par le gouvernement malgré la
mobilisation malgré le soutien aussi
et c'est ce que dit c'est ce que dit
Philippe Martinez dans le JDD notamment
on veut passer à la vitesse supérieure
donc là dessus je sais pas lequel des
deux va le plus à perdre en tout cas le
gouvernement fait le dos rond
aujourd'hui s'inquiète le gouvernement
il craint cette journée de mobilisation
l'imagine enfin en tout cas il la
regarde il la surveille ce qui le craint
les blocages et ce qui peut arriver
derrière parce que ça ce serait nouveau
ce qu'a dit Stanislas Guérini en tout
cas dans le monde c'est que ce qu'il
craignent le plus exactement c'est le
jour d'après c'est pas tant aujourd'hui
c'est ce qui va se passer c'est les
grèves reconductibles c'est les blocages
qui peuvent mettre la France à l'arrêt
donc il y a une crainte en tout cas le
on tente de faire passer le message que
on ne cédera pas à la rue on fait le dos
rond mais mais il suffit de regarder
aussi Olivier Véran le porte-parole du
gouvernement qui était monté un petit
peu au créneau quand il y a eu ces mots
de mettre l'économie à genoux lui avait
dit mais c'est un risque de catastrophe
écologique agricole cette histoire parce
que on parle des outrances des syndicats
qui ont lieu assez régulièrement c'est
vrai mais alors là le gouvernement est
tombé dans le panneau pourquoi
il s'est trompé comme ça parce que il a
tout mélangé Olivier Véran et je crois
que ça n'a pas servi ça cause là cette
sortie
mais ce qui est certain c'est qu'on
cherche aussi les deux camps cherchent à
se renvoyer la balle à renvoyer la
responsabilité s'il y a un blocage c'est
la faute des syndicats et syndicats
répondent ou comme Olivier Besançon ce
matin s'il y a un non c'était Yann
Brossard pardon ce matin c'est
exactement le communisme s'il y a un
bloqueur en chef il se trouve à l'Elysée
en parlant d'Emmanuel Macron donc chacun
se renvoie la balle pour savoir qui
bloque le pays parce qu'il a perdu pied
par un par moment ce gouvernement je
Licques Elisabeth borne n'est pas fan
d'Olivier du soft Véran ça sortiaza
hasardeuse dont on parlait à l'instant
qui prédit quasiment la focalypse j'ai
noté aussi du stop qui valide le RN à
l'Assemblée nationale Macron qu'on voit
quasiment pas est-ce que il a un peu
perdu la main et il laisse faire il dit
bon bah tant pis les gens sont dans la
rue nous on essaie d'avancer écoute
perdre du pied je ne sais pas ce qui est
sûr c'est qu'il y a eu des quoi que des
quoi comme questionnaires pardon
notamment sur les pensions à 1200 euros
sur des sorties qui ont été
effectivement qu'on est sorti
cette mesure de 1200 euros et des femmes
d'ailleurs oui exactement donc il y a eu
il y a eu un petit peu des difficultés
en termes de communication maintenant ce
qui est certain et c'est ce qui semble
passer comme message c'est qu'il y a pas
une volonté de de rompre avec l'esprit
de la réforme et tous s'accordent là
dessus c'est à dire qu'il y a pas eu de
c'est quand même un mot d'ordre du côté
du gouvernement de tenir bon quoi qu'il
arrive
l'oppositions
[Musique]
on y vient alors on parle de la de la
rue aujourd'hui il y a deux oppositions
finalement celles
au Parlement qui n'est pas représenté
par la gauche et celle de la rue qui est
représentée par la gauche ils ont fait
ce choix là est-ce que elle aussi cette
gauche portait par Jean-Luc Mélenchon
c'est déc
[Musique]
peut-être que vous participez vous même
au blocus challenge
expliquez-nous ça
fait une vidéo en doudoune sur son sur
son Twitter en invitant à les lycéens
les étudiants à participer à un blocus
challenge c'est-à-dire à prendre leur
plus belle photo devant leurs
établissements bloqués et celui qui sera
tiré au sort l'équipe de bloqueurs
pourra visiter l'Assemblée nationale
avec lui donc Louis Boyard pour pour
rappel c'est un jeune député insoumis du
Val-de-Marne et ça a provoqué beaucoup
de remous mais c'est aussi c'est aussi
symptomatique peut-être de cette volonté
de de
on va dire de de bordéliser comme Gérald
Darma
de faire participer la jeunesse parce
que c'est là c'est là aussi un enjeu de
la mobilisation on va poser la question
à Damien canive ah il me semble que son
image est bloqué vous voyez
Eric Coquerel sur notre image c'est pas
grave on va essayer de le retrouver
j'aurais bien aimé qu'il lui pose la
question sur ce blocus challenge est-ce
que la gauche d'une certaine manière
c'est fracturé alors qu'elle aurait dû
se rassembler ce solidifier peut-être ce
qu'elle s'est fracturé lors de ses
débats autour de la réforme des
retraites ce qui est certain c'est que
la stratégie qui a été celle de la
France insoumise notamment autour de
l'obstruction parlementaire du fait
qu'il y ait eu alors j'ai pu le chiffre
en tête mais beaucoup beaucoup
d'abonnement quand d'amendements qui ont
été déposés qui ont été empêcher en tout
cas à l'Assemblée nationale d'étudier
plus de deux articles si je me trompe
pas à provoqué quelques 20 il y avait un
articles là aujourd'hui au Sénat on
devrait peut-être
plateforme puisque c'est celui qui
détermine si oui ou non l'âge de départ
doit être reporté de 62 à 64 donc pour
revenir sur sur la stratégie de la
gauche effectivement ça a pu fracturer
parce que ça a limité aussi les débats
et les amendements étaient pas forcément
les plus constructifs parce que ça
jouait parfois à la virgule près et donc
là dessus ça a posé des questions et
notamment sur le retrait des amendements
de ce qu'il y a eu cette volonté
notamment des socialistes et des
communistes de retirer finalement leur
amendement pour faire voter cet article
7 il est arrivé il était favorable à la
France insoumise gagner par le camp
Mélenchon de très peu qui souhaitait lui
poursuivre cette
stratégie d'obstruction c'est ça
finalement ça ne s'est pas fait donc là
dessus effectivement ça a pu laisser des
traces du côté de la mifesse est-ce que
cette gauche politique aimerait être un
moteur et finalement elle n'a fait que
suivre le mouvement est-ce qu'elle est
dépassée par les syndicats qui eux
arrivent à mettre du monde dans la rue
visiblement c'est encore le cas
aujourd'hui alors dépasser en tout cas
ce qui est certain c'est que les
syndicats pas forcément beaucoup
d'intérêt on le voit à s'afficher avec
avec la gauche
c'est l'occasion aussi de redorer un
petit peu leur blason les vieux
syndicats retrouvent un peu leur force à
côté il y a une classe politique qui est
souvent mal aimée peut-être et c'est ce
que disait ce que disait Philippe
Martinez ce matin sur le plateau de
France Info il a pas eu de contact avec
Jean-Luc Mélenchon depuis l'année
dernière si on le croit
une question sur l'un ou l'autre il y a
pas d'amour réciproque peut-être
[Musique]
ils sont très précautionneux dans leurs
relations donc peut-être que c'est aussi
une réhabilitation des syndicats aussi
face à la gauche peut-être une photo un
jour entre un insoumis et un
syndicaliste il y a la rue qu'on voit
aujourd'hui il y a le Parlement on en
est où précisément c'est parfois
compliqué mais je voudrais qu'on puisse
expliquer à nos internautes où on en est
et où on va aller ok bah là si on prend
la journée une mission parce que c'est
pas simple je vais essayer de l'honorer
un petit peu mais si on prend la journée
là en ce moment on est sur on est déjà
au Sénat il y a 110 heures de débat
c'est un petit peu plus de débats qu'à
l'Assemblée nationale le texte est passé
de l'Assemblée au Sénat s'envoie on l'a
vu avec seulement deux articles alors
deux articles 3 mais je me pense que
c'est deux articles étudiés le Sénat là
a jusqu'au 12 mars pour examination en
partant de l'Assemblée nationale il
partait comme il était arrivé puisqu'il
puisque l'examen du texte n'a pas pu
arriver à son terme pas de vote donc il
part comme il est arrivé exactement donc
là aussi on a les débats les débats se
déroule de seconde 12 mars
avec exactement donc ça fait dimanche
ensuite il va y avoir une commission
mixte pariétaire dont je parlais tout à
l'heure c'est cette députés cette
sénateurs donc dans cette commission
mixte paritaire dit là on va s'asseoir
autour de la table on va discuter du
texte là le gouvernement du moins la
majorité à l'Assemblée pas la
sénatoriale mais aussi
le gouvernement a peut-être un petit peu
l'avantage parce que dedans il y a
seulement quatre députés du RN du
rassemblement national et de la nupaisse
qui sont hostiles à cette réforme donc
ça pourrait tourner en faveur du
gouvernement et de la droite et son
allié là-dessus et au terme de cette CMP
si cette CMP est conclusive il va y
avoir un vote solennelle c'est-à-dire
qu'on a réussi à se mettre d'accord et à
trouver un
produit sur un texte sur ce texte de la
réforme vu l'équilibre politique au sein
de septième P il est possible qu'il y a
un accord on a pas mais c'est pas il y a
rien de il y a rien de certain mais en
tout cas s'il y a une CMP conclusive on
repart et on fait voter aux deux
assemblées ce texte ce texte sans
modification possible d'accord et alors
là c'est là qu'on pourrait intervenir le
49-3 c'est ça c'est ça s'il y a pas de
car on en parle un peu moins c'est vrai
peut-être qu'il y a pas envie aussi de
de chauffer un peu plus la rue tu sais
je les oppositions politiques oui
effectivement on en parle un petit peu
moins mais là dessus je ferai certaine
que ce soit une option qui était
totalement enterrée
une autre option quand on n'est pas
spécialiste de la politique c'est
parfois compliqué une réforme promue de
gué par ordonnance qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire comment ça se passe je suis pas non
plus spécialiste
il y a pas de vote finalement
à l'Assemblée donc le gouvernement peut
signer directement cette réforme et
faire passer mais ça paraîtrait quand
même du moins ce serait ce serait
peut-être déclenché lire sans trop
m'avancer de la rue des oppositions et
évidemment
la tendance est-ce que Macron peut
reculer j'imagine que dans les services
politiques vous avez des retours des
impressions quel est son état d'esprit
quel est l'état d'esprit des conseillers
est-ce qu'il le sent bien ou il y a une
petite tension
là-dessus sur l'état d'esprit on sait
que c'est très dur aussi d'aller
savoir ce que pense Emmanuel Macron
aujourd'hui c'est très dur mais en tout
cas ce qu'on peut savoir c'est l'état de
ces troupes là-dessus on a quelques
quelques indices notamment ce matin en
réunion de groupe de la majorité il y a
eu des discussions autour du vote
solennelle parce que il y a eu des
députés de en commun le micro partie de
barbara Pompili l'ancienne ministre de
l'écologie qui a déjà fait savoir
qu'elle n'était pas très favorable et là
effectivement il y aurait peut-être une
poignée de députés donc trois à quatre
députés qui s'abstiendraient pour le
mode solennelle ce à quoi a répondu la
chef de fil des députés Renaissance au
nord berger qui a rappelé qu'en fait il
faut pas s'extraire se soumettre du
moins à l'opinion c'est à dire il faut
tenir bon il faut tenir le cap donc en
tout cas si on regarde sur les troupes
il y a quand même cette volonté de tenir
de garder cet esprit la réforme de ne
surtout pas rétropédaler sur la question
de l'âge
donc là dessus je sais pas quel est
l'état de sérénité mais en tout cas ce
qui est certain c'est qu'il y a pas de
il y a pas vraiment beaucoup de marge de
manœuvre qui sont laissés à la rue merci
beaucoup Sébastien aujourd'hui
on va retourner sur le terrain est-ce
qu'on a Damien canivelle on va me dire
et ce qui est toujours avec
Eric Coquerel oui je le vois demander à
Eric Coquerel
dans l'une de vos questions ce qu'il
pense de ce blocus challenge mon cher
Damien Canivez lancé par Louis Boyard
oui
et bien figurez-vous que nous sommes sur
la même longueur d'onde puisque j'avais
bien l'intention lui poser la question
bonjour Éric Coquerel merci d'accepter
de répondre à quelques questions déjà
toute première question est-ce que
l'ampleur de cette mobilisation vous
impressionne ou bien vous vous y
attendiez alors je m'y attendais mais
elle est impressionnante voilà parce que
tous les chiffres qui remontent c'est la
plus forte mobilisation depuis le début
de ce mouvement est très largement donc
je pense qu'on sera pas être loin de 3
millions de personnes ce soir en tout
cas à Paris c'est monstrueux parce que
vous avez deux cortèges qui sont qui
sont vraiment historiques la suite du
mouvement pour vous c'est quoi
exactement comment envisagez-vous la
suite de ce mouvement si jamais le
gouvernement continue à faire la sourde
oreille qui est très franchement c'est
un peu un grand classique dans les
mouvements sociaux c'est par la grève
reconductible c'est là où à un moment
donné le gouvernement peut entendre
raison parce que là il s'agit aussi d'un
problème démocratique quand vous avez
vraiment tout un pop qui est contre un
projet c'est pas raisonnable de vouloir
passer en force et le gouvernement
devrait monsieur Macron devrait entendre
raison bon s'il l'entend pas il faut une
il faut que la grève se poursuive avec
ce que ça comme conséquence
et puis sans fin convaincre cette
majorité que voilà on peut pas passer en
force vous en tant que parlementaire
est-ce que vous êtes satisfait des
débats qui sont actuellement au Sénat
avec cet article 2 qui a été voté avec
ce CDI senior aussi qui a été instauré
oh c'était assez attendu puisque les
républicains au Sénat on le sait eux de
manière presque globale avait un accord
avec
la majorité monsieur Macron donc c'est
assez prévisible en réalité si
maintenant il doit y avoir une surprise
au niveau parlementaire s'il doit y
avoir une faille ça sera en retour à
l'Assemblée c'est pas le plus probable
mais c'est là où on sait que les
républicains sont divisées on sait qu'il
y a quand même des gens dans la majorité
qui se posent des questions bon et puis
le gouvernant pourrait aussi d'ici là se
dire que ça suffit que c'est pas la
peine dans une année de crise économique
sociale très difficile d'ajouter de
l'attention et de vouloir passer un
projet dont manifestement personne ne
veut monsieur Coquerel une dernière
question par rapport à l'appel de Louis
Boyard ce blocus challenge qu'il a lancé
sur Tik Tok et c'est photos il a appelé
les étudiants à poster les une belle
photo des blocages et à la récompense
c'est une visite à l'Assemblée nationale
c'est une bonne manière de faire selon
vous enfin moi j'ai pris ça pour une
blague un peu au second degré et voilà
moi j'ai pas les mêmes codes de
communication mais c'est normal ce que
j'observe surtout c'est qu'il essaye de
de développer aussi la mobilisation dans
la jeunesse voilà il joue son rôle bon
je crois que lui-même le concours était
pas le plus important dans son histoire
c'est c'est ce que vous avez retenu mais
c'était c'était surtout l'appel à se
mobiliser à la jeunesse quoi vous pensez
que la clé de la réussite de ce
mouvement aussi c'est la jeunesse ah bah
ça c'est sûr enfin d'abord c'est des
salariés entendons-nous faire s'il y a
une grève reconductible ce qui est
important c'est que là il y a tous les
syndicats toujours unis dans le privé
aussi on fait grève donc c'est une grève
conductible c'est là où les choses vont
vont basculer mais c'est clair que on
sait qu'historiquement quand la jeunesse
il met aussi on va là ça devient
intenable pour un gouvernement quoi
merci beaucoup Eric Coquerel d'avoir
patienté avec nous sur cette
manifestation nous sommes boulevard de
Montparnasse toujours et nous nous
dirigerons vers l'avenue des Gobelins
pour rejoindre ensuite la place d'Italie
où s'arrêtera la manifestation merci
beaucoup
d'avoir répondu
au micro du Figaro live Christophe
Cornavin bonjour bonjour
adjoint au service société du figureux
spécialiste des questions de sécurité on
a vu il y a quelques minutes quelques
échauffes alors c'était très calme que
s'est-il passé vous avez des infos ouais
ouais tout à fait en fait la sur la
boucle police là on fait état d'une
intervention en fait des services de
sécurité après que qu'un groupe de de
radicaux certainement des Black Blocs ou
assimilés on va chercher à s'emparer de
barrière pour les jeter sur les forces
de l'ordre donc intervention immédiate
on peut aussi remarquer dans ce cortège
parisien qui semble relativement calme
pour l'instant on est incident qui a
assez déroulé à peu près dizaines de
minutes une vingtaine de minutes
peut-être il y a eu une tentative de
cortège sauvage qui a voulu se diriger
vers le boulevard Saint-Michel mais là
encore les forces de l'ordre étaient
pas très loin et donc empêchait ce
mouvement est-ce que Timothée Dolan nous
entend parce que lui il était sur place
peut-être qu'il peut nous expliquer nous
dire ce qu'il s'est passé Timothée
est-ce que vous m'entendez non j'ai
l'impression qu'il m'entend pas de
Timothée mais on va essayer de assez il
m'entend une menton Timothée on était à
Christophe on parlait justement de ce
qu'il s'est passé derrière vous avec
quelques échauffes fourrés racontez-nous
oui Thibaut quelques échauffes auraient
assez contenu vous les avez vu tout à
l'heure en fait ce qui s'est passé c'est
comme le disait Christophe à l'instant
une tentative de de cortège sauvage en
fait les manifestants enfin certains
manifestants tous les cas ont tenté et
bien de se diriger vers le Sénat depuis
le boulevard du Port-Royal c'est vrai
que ça n'est pas très très long le
Palais du Luxembourg et donc certains
effectivement ont pris des barrières des
barricades qu'ils ont commencé à jeter
sur les forces de l'ordre lesquels ce
sont tout de suite positionnés en ligne
pour les empêcher de partir vers en
direction du Palais du Luxembourg et
c'est la raison pour laquelle il y a eu
ce moment de de flottement avec quelques
gaz lacrymogènes et quelques quelques
tirs de projectiles également voilà mais
c'est ces petits affrontements qui qui
sont restés assez contenus le cortège
est reparti maintenant en direction de
cette place d'Italie et également un
moment aussi tout à l'heure qui nous a
qui nous a frappé c'est en fait là alors
vous le voyez derrière c'est toujours
cet hôpital de Port-Royal évidemment
avec ces moments de flottement on n'a
pas énormément avancé depuis quelques
minutes vous le voyez derrière nous
c'est l'hôpital de Port-Royal et alors
là ils viennent de rentrer il y avait
plusieurs plusieurs infirmières et
plusieurs infirmiers qui étaient qui
sont sortis en fait de cette de
l'hôpital et les manifestants qui ont
qui les ont applaudis pendant quelques
minutes et des applaudissements mutuels
voilà un moment qui illustre c'est bien
cette cette ambiance cet après-midi qui
est quand même plutôt bonne malgré on le
disait ces petits affrontements que nous
avons observé tout à l'heure en tous les
cas le cortège qui maintenant est
vraiment reparti la CFE-CGC qui vient de
de nous passer devant à l'instant et
puis voilà là ici vous le voyez encore
de nouvelles de nouveaux drapeaux
nouvelle pancarte tu vois du drapeau CGT
Force Ouvrière voilà en tous les cas les
manifestants qui continuent de d'avancer
maintenant vers la Place d'Italie merci
merci beaucoup Timothée de l'amour
Christophe on s'attend une déferlante
dans les rues de France aujourd'hui je
vous ai j'ai l'impression que les
renseignements sont
dithyrambiques concernant la capacité de
mobilisation de la CGT des autres
syndicats
les services de renseignement pensent
qu'on va certainement on attendait
jusqu'à 1,4 millions de manifestants
dans les rues
on s'est rendu compte lors des
précédentes
journées nationales d'action que
finalement leur jeu était plutôt plutôt
correct hormis le premier jour
effectivement le premier jour mais après
ils ont ajusté le tir les quatre les
deux trois quatre cinq
c'est à quel jour précédent donc le
sixième il prévoit 1,4 millions ce qui
est énorme en fait il s'attendent ce
serait en tout cas oui ce serait plus
que le que le 31 janvier qui était de
1,27 millions je crois donc c'est à dire
qu'on serait au dessus 270 000 voilà
1,270 000 donc on serait au dessus et on
serait finalement au niveau des pics de
l'automne 2010
au moment
du paroxysme de la fronde contre contre
la loi verte on s'en souvient du lors du
passage à la retraite de 60 à 62 ans
façon le but de la terre syndicale il
est clair c'est de faire mieux que le 31
janvier pour eux de toute façon je crois
qu'on l'a dit ici à ce micro il joue il
joue très gros il joue à qui tout double
on est en mode Blitz maintenant parce
que manifeste Blitz en mode rapide dans
la mesure où il va falloir
qu'il arrive qu'ils arrivent à cranter
le mouvement à imprimer les esprits
sachant que il semblerait que le vote de
la loi puisse intervenir dans une
dizaine de jours donc le sablier est
retourné pour les syndicats et pour eux
il faut absolument qu'ils marquent les
esprits aujourd'hui c'est fondamental
les termes techniques de Christophe
Cornavin cranter le Blitz là on est dans
le dans le langage
des manifestations pure exactement
est-ce que ça se confirme ce matin là
cette mobilisation parce que évidemment
il y a les chiffres de la veille ceux
que vous nous donniez hier sur le Figaro
et sur le Figaro.fr est-ce que ce matin
au vu des premiers chiffres ça se
confirme mais écoutez je serai plus
mitigé et plus prudent parce que là j'ai
pris quelques chiffres bon c'est vrai
qu'à Marseille par exemple on avait
200000 200000 personnes le 31 je prends
le 31 parce que c'est la journée
il y avait 200000 personnes selon les
syndicats selon les syndicats attendez
200000 selon les syndicats et préciser
parce que j'ai failli je vais préciser
200000 sommets syndicats et les
syndicats disent la 245000 donc on
aurait plutôt tendance à croire que il y
a une hausse
nihausse n'est pas forcément bon en tout
cas on est sur une tendance mais en
revanche si on prend les chiffres de la
préfecture qui pour moi ont pas mal de
valeur
on est plutôt vers une décélération dans
la mesure où on était passé de 40 000 à
Marseille à 30000 aujourd'hui c'est à
dire qu'il y aura une un repli et se
repli il se voit aussi à Nantes euh
non on est à peu près à Nantes on est
autour de 28 30000 en revanche à Nice
par exemple on est on est passé de 6000
à 5000
globalement on a l'impression même si
Laurent Berger dit urber une
augmentation de 20% de la fréquentation
dans les cortèges aujourd'hui les
chiffres qui sont en tout cas diffusés
par la préfecture ne vont pas dans le
sens d'un raz-de-marée donc il va
falloir être assez prudent en revanche
ce qui est très notable peut-être c'est
le durcissement du thon dans les dans
les messages bien sûr on va on va en
parler dans un instant je vous
propose vous attendez sur ces images en
haut à gauche et je sais pas si on peut
les avoir en plein écran sur Paris il y
a certaines tensions sur Paris
évidemment alors peut-être que pour
Paris on peut quand même observer que
l'ail effectivement alors ça c'est
toujours pareil il y a toujours le
fameux feu de feu de poubelle qui fait
croire que que Paris est à feu et à 100
il faut jamais tomber dans le panier
il faut se rendre compte que le cortège
s'étire quand même sur sur plusieurs
centaines de de mètres voire parfois
plusieurs kilomètres mais il est mais
pour l'instant
le bon l'idée selon laquelle le bruit et
la fureur soufflait dans les rues de la
capitale ne tient pas véritablement la
route aujourd'hui
donc on a eu on n'a pas eu beaucoup de
casse les six premiers jours il y a la
stratégie du préfet de police maintenant
qui pour l'instant il faut toujours être
prudent mais pour l'instant ça
m'intéresse on va parler dans l'instant
pardon parce que regarder Damien
canivels notre envoyé spécial est avec
une figure de la politique française
Sandrine Rousseau
membre d'Europe Écologie Les Verts
députés est avec vous Damien vous avez
la parole
absolument Sandrine rousse au député à
l'Assemblée nationale bonjour Sandrine
Rousseau merci d'accepter de répondre à
quelques questions déjà première
question est-ce que vous êtes satisfaite
de l'affluence que vous voyez
aujourd'hui dans les rues de Paris non
seulement chez satisfaite j'ai
l'impression qu'il y a un monde fou là
j'ai fait qu'une partie du cortège mais
j'ai l'impression que c'est vraiment
incroyablement plein et puis surtout
c'est très joyeux c'est très détendu
c'est très déterminé il y a une très
bonne ambiance enfin là je pense que
Macron a du souci à se faire vous pensez
que ça suffira pour faire payer le
gouvernement dans tous les cas il
devrait s'interroger parce que vu le
nombre de personnes qui ont pris une
journée là pour venir défiler c'est que
la volonté la détermination sont quand
même très très grandes de ne pas aller
dans une réforme qui nous personne ne
comprend l'objet en fait à part à part
faire du profit de la croissance etc
comment envisagez-vous la suite du
mouvement parce que aujourd'hui force
est de reconnaître que le gouvernement
n'a pas forcément fait de pas en arrière
si tel est le cas quelle est la suite
il va falloir penser au blocage les
syndicats ils pensent déjà très bien et
là il y a déjà eu des blocages
aujourd'hui et faut pas avoir peur de ce
mot parce que à un moment c'est un
rapport de force qui s'installe et là en
l'occurrence il faut qu'on monte le
rapport de force est-ce que vous êtes
aussi favorable au blocage des lycées
tels que Louis Boyard a appelé à ce que
ça se passe Louis Boyard qui a appelé au
blocus challenge qui vise en fait
publier sur les réseaux sociaux les
photos les plus jolies des blocages pour
gagner une visite Assemblée nationale
vous êtes favorable à ça mais je pense
que là ce qui joue c'est un système
économique et social qui met vraiment en
danger la jeunesse vraiment les
conditions de vie de la jeunesse dans le
futur donc oui la jeunesse doit se
mobiliser
Laurent Berger en particulier des mois
c'est dur vis-à-vis de votre groupe et
des débats qui ont eu lieu à l'Assemblée
nationale avec leurs culs vous feriez
différemment ou pas Sandrine Rousseau
bah moi j'ai déjà émis les réserves sur
la stratégie qui a été adopté après je
pense que finalement on a quand même
réussi quelque chose de très important
qui est qu'on a réussi à montrer que le
gouvernement n'avait pas d'arguments et
ça c'est quand même primordial merci
beaucoup Sandrine Rousseau pour deux
questions sur Figaro live voilà la
manifestation se poursuit avec les
syndicats qui défilent derrière moi
comme vous pouvez le le constater avec
là le mouvement des jeunes et énormément
c'est vrai aujourd'hui de deux jeunes
dans les rues de Paris des études et
également des lycées merci merci
beaucoup Damien caniveau et Christophe
Cornavin spécialiste des questions de
sécurité au Figaro et ça se confirme ce
matin alors on avait Arthur bilota il y
a quelques instants qui nous expliquait
que dans les grosses villes plutôt des
manifestations plutôt en baisse en
revanche dans les villes moyennes une
hausse c'est toujours pareil on
surveille c'est ville moyenne du côté
assez complètement nouveau c'est
complètement nouveau et ça montre que le
que le phénomène sévéritablement
enquisté dans les profondeurs du
territoire dans les replis les plus
éloignées de de la capitale la colère
elle est elle est elle est complètement
diffuse sur tout le pays
je vais vous donner quelques chiffres
à Rodez à La Rochelle Albi ou encore à
Blois dont on ne peut pas penser que ce
sont des des foyers d'insurrection
on attend jusqu'à 9000 personnes
aujourd'hui il faudra voir si ça s'est
confirmé mais c'est en tout cas c'était
les prévisions à Coutances dans la
Manche avec un bout de ville
qui qui a 9000 habitants il y avait
presque 2000 personnes dans les dans les
rues donc on est véritablement sur un
phénomène qui est à mon sens nouveau
alors ça a été bien décrit notamment par
Jérôme Fourquet c'est cette c'est cette
France cette France des déclassés cette
France des zones blanches médicales
je pense qui prend de plein fouet tout
ce qui est lié à la à la zone affable
émission qui ont du mal à celle de
vous me dites que ces gens-là de
manifestent pas que pour la réforme des
retraites quoi c'est autre chose c'est
un déclenchement c'est ça peut être un
sel mais ça ça ce n'est pas que ça ce
n'est pas que ça mais de la même manière
que les gilets jaunes les services de
renseignement disent que finalement
cette cette mobilisation dans les forces
de la sous-préfecture c'est ce n'est
rien d'autre qu'une cristallisation une
poursuite de la colère des gilets jaunes
sous une autre forme gardons en mémoire
quand même que les gilets jaunes ils
étaient ils étaient sur plusieurs motifs
de mécontentement voir des motifs
tellement diffus qu'on savait plus trop
pourquoi il descendait dans la rue mais
il y avait pas en tout cas de motor
spécifique si ce n'est un rejet massif
de ce qu'il considérait être l'élite le
les lentilles etc etc en fait c'est ce
que disait Benjamin Griveaux avec
beaucoup de maladresse à mon sens cette
cette France qui rouleau diesel et qui
fume des cigarettes
pas très à droite mais en tout cas c'est
c'est cette France là qui se sent un peu
méprisé et qui qui descend dans la rue
on peut aussi observer que parmi ces
manifestants dans les dans cette France
un peu périphérique il y a aussi cette
France des services publics pampelant la
France des du milieu hospitalier des
services publics qu'on laisse tomber
voir des collectivités territoriales qui
sont à vous de souffle donc en fait on a
quand même une colère générale
Christophe colère général on se pose
souvent la question des jeunes on va
retrouver Timothée d'Hélène dans un
instant qui est avec certains d'entre
eux est-ce que le mouvement prend chez
les gènes est-ce que on surveille ça du
côté des renseignements et les femmes
inférieur donc bien sûr en plus plus que
jamais parce que bah oui on regarde les
jeunes c'est une c'est une donnée
absolument fondamentale dans l'analyse
d'une d'une manifestation parce que les
jeunes dans une manifestation ça ça en
change la physionomie de manière
importante parce que parce que les
jeunes se sont parfois un peu les en
tout cas les syndicats de jeunes ont un
peu moins conséquent la CGT donc c'est
moins sécurisé
il y a les meneurs il y a le syndrome
malico sétine qui est toujours les
esprits des forces de l'ordre cette
étudiant qui était mort à Paris en 1986
il y a l'idée aussi que
qu'en fait les cette jeunesse allait
aller prête à parfois aller très loin
pour se faire pour se faire entendre et
évidemment si un jeune était touché par
les forces de l'ordre aussi il y avait
un incident avec un jeune évidemment ça
donnerait une toute autre tournure assez
journée nationale d'action qui pour
l'instant sont marqués par le calme oui
alors le calme mais regardez ces images
et elles sont assez rares Christophe il
faut jamais extrapoler on a dit ce n'est
qu'une image mais on voit c'est genre
regarder et vous savez ce qu'on appelle
des Black Blocs ça se sent complètement
des Black Blocs c'est pas une surprise
parce que
des sources gouvernementales m'avait
fait part on en décrit dans le Figaro
d'ailleurs
retrouver les plaques de Sophie
alors je reprends selon les services de
renseignement ils attendaient à Paris
entre 300 et 500 militants de l'ultra
gauche et
400 à 800 militants
ultrajeunes donc
ultra gilets jaunes radicaux d'accord
mais là on est on est manifestement sur
des des Black blockers
qui sont en train de de prendre le pouls
voir un peu comment comment il pourrait
éventuellement passer à l'action ou pas
une personne ça il faut le préciser le
Black Bloc c'est pas du tout
on vient de voir sur l'image à gauche
c'est manifestants qui forment un black
bloc voilà et là les CRS qui alors eux
sont prêts la casque
à l'action d'une certaine manière bah en
tout cas ce qui se passe c'est que le
donc le black bloc comme vous l'avez
bien la résumé c'est c'est un mode
opératoire c'est pas un c'est pas c'est
pas un profil c'est c'est des gens qui
s'organisent dans un mode d'action
violente qui s'appelle le black bloc qui
a une tradition historique assez
ancienne
et qu'on a vu à faire apparaître en
France depuis des années et qui est
monté en puissance jusqu'à les
manifestations contre la loi travail la
loi el khomri où là les Black blockers
étaient très très nombreux ils pouvaient
être jusqu'à 2 3000 dans les
manifestations en tête de cortège
donc on les repère évidemment par par
leur grande bannière noire qui les
déploie comme un comme un état en plus
qui sont souvent protègent des bannières
avec des bannières rigides qui leur
permettent de servir de bouclier et
aussi de ce de s'habiller ou de se
déshabiller enfin de changer de de de
d'apparence comme s'ils étaient des
comme s'ils étaient
finalement pour pour essayer de tromper
de tromper la vigilance de la police
qu'on vient de voir visiblement ce
monsieur qui avait sa voiture entre les
forces de l'ordre et c'est mouvement les
black-box la voiture qui est assez
frais c'est ça le principe d'un black
bloc hein c'est le principe d'un blablox
c'est que tout ce qu'on peut casser on
le casse on commence évidemment par la
stratégie numéro
que c'est un médecin une voiture de SOS
Médecins parfois on a semblé très
particulier non non mais ils attaquent
vraiment ils attaquent sans discernement
tout ce qu'ils peuvent attaquer donc
c'est à dire par ordre priorité
évidemment il se frotte aux forces de
l'ordre si vous voulez on reparlera de
la stratégie des forces de l'ordre
justement essayer de dire
et je compte sur vous pour m'expliquer
ce qu'on voit
j'avoue l'expliquer là ils sont en train
de ben là les forces de l'ordre là c'est
un peloton de gendarmes mobiles
particulièrement ce n'est plus le temps
d'intervention
la gendarmerie de chasse vous arrivez à
le voir à la tenue à la tenue ils ont
des casques un peu différents la couleur
de l'uniforme aussi est un peu est un
peu différente c'est des variations de
bleu mais je voilà
je le reconnais et puis de toute façon
les CRS généralement ils ont une barre
ils ont une bande sur leur sur leur
casque
une blanche mais en tout cas ils ont
besoin
ils avancent parce qu'en fait ils ont
protégé la voiture dans un premier temps
et ils vont ils vont essayer de prendre
maîtrise possession de cette rue là
jusqu'à l'axe je pense ils vont
s'arrêter là ça m'étonnerait qu'il
rentre plus loin
mais en tout cas ils repoussent ils ont
vu certainement les les bloqueurs et ils
essaient de les de les remettre dans un
de les de les remettre dans un coin où
ils vont pouvoir les les maîtriser plus
plus facilement alors vous me dites que
les bloqueurs c'est ça eux se disperse
très vite se déshabille et d'un seul
coup disparaisse et se fondement la
exactement en fait ils ont ce qu'on
appelle la technique dite de la
recomposition perpétuelle c'est à dire
qu'en fait je vous pose plein de
questions mais là c'est nécessaire
après avoir autant avancé c'est ça qui
peut paraître alors après c'est c'est en
fait ils font ce qu'on appelle des bons
foncifs c'est à dire qu'ils gagnent
quelques mètres pour pour repousser le
pour repousser ce qu'ils appellent
l'adversaire
là vous voyez là là devant ce ne sont
pas des CRS en fait les CRS sont donc il
y a les CRS derrière deuxième rideau et
on voit le logo et là devant c'est ah
c'est ou alors c'est peut-être la CRS 8
qui est une CRS un peu particulière
d'intervention mais en tout cas là c'est
son effectivement des policiers pas des
gendarmes mobiles et donc en fait ce
qu'ils font c'est qu'ils font des des
bons tactiques pour repousser pour
repousser l'adversaire et après il se
reculent parce que il y a une stratégie
du maintien de l'ordre en France qui
s'appelle la mise à distance pour éviter
le contact
alors il se recule pour deux raisons
c'est que
quand ils vont contact évidemment ils
peuvent tout d'un coup de découpes
peuvent être échangés et ça peut faire
des blessés parmi les manifestants et
donc ça peut faire
vriller une une manifestation et par
ailleurs les les
par rapport au black bloc et ça c'est la
stratégie du préfet de police c'est que
nouveau préfet de police c'est de faire
en sorte que les forces de l'ordre soit
le plus la plus furtif possible on les
voit qu'elle soit pas dans le décor
qu'elle disparaisse du TR quand vous
regardez les images ah c'est ce que nous
disait Damien qui a gagné tout à l'heure
il essaie de remonter
le le cortège et il passait par des rues
parallèles et c'est là qu'il voyait les
forces de l'ordre en fait il y a dit en
fait il y a quand même en France il y a
10000 membres des forces de l'ordre et
dans Paris il y en a presque 5000 et on
ne les voit pas sur le corps latte
cortège parce qu'elles sont sur les rues
adjac entes l'idée c'est d'éviter le
chiffon rouge devant les Black Blocs
on revient dans un instant j'ai encore
plein de questions alors que le calme
même si on voit les feux de poubelle là
dans cette rue semble revenue après
cette affrontement se fasse face à face
on s'est regardé pas de Dassault des
deux côtés on retrouve Damien Canivez
Damien vous êtes avec une personnalité
politique importante le patron des
socialistes
exactement
oui nous sommes avec Olivier fort qui
est un peu la star de cette de ce
cortège il y a beaucoup de gens qui qui
saluent merci d'être avec nous sur
Figaro live et d'accepter de répondre à
quelques questions déjà une première
réaction quel regard portez-vous sur
l'ampleur de la mobilisation aujourd'hui
dans les rues de Paris mais à côté c'est
la 6e fois qu'on manifeste je suis venu
à chaque fois dans les dans les rangs
des manifestants et c'est monstrueux
au sens où il y a un monde fou c'est
complètement
il y a un monde de dingue et des gens de
toutes les générations je vois beaucoup
de jeunes aussi qui se sont mobilisés et
dans les gens qui me parlent il y a
beaucoup de gens qui pour la première
fois manifestent pour la première fois
font grève ce qui n'était jamais arrivé
dans leur vie et qui dit cette fois-ci
on veut sauvegarder l'essentiel est-ce
que cette jeunesse là qui est en train
de défiler juste derrière vous c'est la
clé du succès de cette mobilisation
c'est l'une des clés en fait
je vois mes propres enfants qui vont ne
sont pas plus politisés que les autres
même s'ils ont un père qui fait de la
politique et qui qui regarde le sujet
qui se disent mais on a des parents des
grands-parents qui sont à un âge où a
finalement il y a besoin aussi de
s'arrêter en fait il parle pas de leur
père encore enfin ça viendra et
donc ils sont conscients de ce qui se
passe pour les aînés et ils sont
conscients aussi du fait que ce qu'ils
défendent c'est aussi un mode de vie un
mode de vie ou le travail n'est pas tout
en fait bien sûr que on aime son travail
bien sûr qu'on est fier de participer à
la création de richesse dans notre pays
mais il y a aussi un moment il faut
savoir s'arrêter et de ce point de vue
ils sont fidèles à ce que fut Ambroise
Croizat qui derrière à la Libération
avec le général de Gaulle mis en place
ce régime de retraite par répartition et
il avait cette phrase qui est restée
célèbre et que nous reprenons toutes et
tous il ne voulait pas que l'âge de la
retraite soit l'anti-chambre de
le retrait pur et simple de cette
réforme ou bien il y a quand même des
points d'accroche avec le gouvernement
que vous êtes capable justement de
saisir je ne sais pas très bien quel
point d'accroche on pourrait avoir le
gouvernement a commencé la discussion en
expliquant que ce serait 64 ans ou rien
donc en fait on dit rien dans ces cas-là
et bien sûr qu'on était prêt à évoquer
avec lui les carrières les carrières
difficiles les cari arrachées car il y a
des femmes toutes celles et ceux qui
dans le système actuel sont déjà en fait
les moins bien servis mais pas pour
arriver à faire pire donc pour arriver à
faire mieux et donc si le gouvernement
veut retirer son projet et veut ensuite
discuter sérieusement de ce qu'on peut
faire nous sommes prêts évidemment à
nous mettre autour de la table et avoir
avec lui quelles sont les ressources
disponibles captables nous avons donné
dans le débat parlementaire nombre de
sources de financement qui sont
concurrentes à celles qu'ils veulent
utiliser ce gouvernement n'a qu'une
seule religion c'est de faire payer ceux
qui ne peuvent pas se défendre et bien
nous sommes vous dire que s'ils peuvent
se défendre nous sommes là avec eux et
qu'il y a d'autres façons de faire merci
beaucoup Olivier je sais que vous êtes
attendus à l'Assemblée nationale donc
bon retour à l'Assemblée nationale et
nous on va continuer notre itinéraire à
la manifestation direction la place
d'Italie où s'achèvera la manifestation
du jour merci Damien Christophe Cornavin
spécialiste des questions de sécurité au
Figaro on a parlé de la manifestation on
a commenté les images ensemble de ces
affrontements pour l'instant rien de
très grave la suite parce que ce
mouvement entre dans autre chose des
blocages là aussi les renseignements s'y
intéressent de très près parce que il
pourrait là aussi avoir des déblocages à
faire en cas de blocage trop importants
on l'a déjà vu dans les dans les dans
leur dans les manifestations les les
mots d'ordre les vendeurs se sont
véritablement durci blocage sabotage oui
sont maintenant inscrits sur les sur les
pancartes on les a vu dans les dans les
Cort
les gens sont énervés par cette logique
de ce qu'ils appellent le métro boulot
tombeau
et en tout cas les les les services les
analystes du ministère de l'Intérieur
les services de renseignement
ont déjà répertorié une multitude
d'actions qui vise alors qui sont un peu
tous azimuts qui vise un peu à paralyser
le pays par tous les moyens c'est-à-dire
il y a il se renseigne ils savent ils
essaient de savoir où il y aura des
blocages et après quelle est la
stratégie on débloque ou pas ah bah
normalement oui depuis toujours
en tout cas dès que c'est possible ça se
fait la difficulté des blocages sans
être un grand technicien je crois que la
grande difficulté des blocages en tout
cas ce que m'ont dit les forces de
l'ordre c'est que pour débloquer une
raffinerie il faut s'y connaître
faut travailler dans une raffinerie
parce qu'un CRS ne peut pas relancer ou
un gendarmobile ne peut pas relancer une
raffinerie ne peut pas ne peut pas
peut-être faire bouger des engins ou
actionner des vannes sans prendre des
risques importants les parmi les
blocages qu'on a qui sont recensés que
redoute les autorités il y a évidemment
raffinerie non mais avant tout déjà les
héros les axes routiers donc les
ronds-points alors les fameux repas en
souvenez que les gilets jaunes
comme en 2018 en reprenant les
ronds-points comme à la à la grande
époque qui a lancé le qui avait amorcé
leur montée en puissance après il y a
les tous les axes giratoires et les
grands les grandes voies qui donnent
accès aux agglomérations qui sont
manifestement ciblées par par des
manifestants qui ne sont pas des gilets
jaunes qui sont vraiment pour les coûts
des membres de l'intersyndical
quand on va dans la gradation il y a
blocage des dépôts pétroliers ça on en a
vu déjà ça a commencé des hier
et après il y a des choses un peu plus
nouvelles qui ont été notées notamment
les blocages de stockage alimentaire
pour les grandes surfaces c'est-à-dire
que l'idée ce serait d'empêcher la
grande distribution de pouvoir fournir
de faire en sorte que certains certaines
denrées alimentaires les rayons voilà
les rayons se vident dans les
supermarchés et enfin la CGT qui essaye
de de comme d'habitude de ratisser assez
large
a fait appel aux éboueurs qui
potentiellement où voilà il y avait pas
de ramassage de poubelles et où les
incinérateurs étaient bloqués voilà
exactement donc l'idée c'est aussi de
d'obstruer les rues de la France avec
des poubelles et enfin il y a même les
livreurs à domicile qui sont appelés à
rester à lâcher leur vélo et à rester
chez eux merci beaucoup Christophe
Cornavin nous avoir donné toutes ces
explications nous sommes pas là pour
l'instant nous verrons il y a une
journée mobilisation demain c'est ça
tout à fait demain et après demain
c'est les femmes
ouais en fait et on attend on attend du
monde aussi il y a pas mal de points de
mobilisation il y a demain et on a il y
aura 142 actions et on attend 100000
personnes et c'est ça c'est ça que ce
que craint les autorités c'est à dire
que aujourd'hui
ça aurait pu s'arrêter comme ça mais
demain cette journée des droits des
femmes les femmes ayant été pointées du
doigt comme étant des grandes perdants
de la réforme donc bon embryer aussi sur
le thème des retraites donc ça
entretient la femme je dirais de la
contestation et le lendemain jeudi il y
a les les étudiants qui prennent le
relais la jeunesse et samedi nouvelle
journée de mobilisation visiblement à
l'appel de l'interse syndicale merci
beaucoup Christophe Cornavin les jeunes
vous venez d'en parler il nous attendent
depuis un moment désolé Timothée delaime
on vous rejoint ces jeunes ils sont dans
la rue désormais
fait l'amour et bien oui certains d'eux
en tout cas sont dans la rue c'est le
cas de ces trois jeunes que nous avons
croisés qui étudie à l'ESSEC donc du
côté de Cergy en école de commerce et
qui ont donc pris le RER B ce matin pour
venir manifester c'est la première fois
que vous manifestez contre la réforme
des retraites pour quelle raison
avez-vous décidé de rejoindre ces
cortèges
en fait on est surtout là principalement
pour montrer que les autres actions de
l'essai au delà de la caricature de
Ravon de boissons soif qu'on pourrait
faire de nous on est également des
hommes et des femmes engagés et
notamment dans ce combat pour l'égalité
sociale alors pourquoi ce combat pour
l'égalité sociale vous semble-t-il juste
est-ce que vous estimez que vous ne
pouvez pas dans votre situation
travailler au-delà de 62 ans
non alors moi je pense que c'est pas
tout à fait la question je pense c'est
Anthon une question générationnelle en
fait et qu'on va être les parties
semblent les genoux se départir
justement des astuces qui s'adaptent en
général en ce qui concerne le travail et
les retraites c'est pas dans une
question d'allongement de temps de
travail ou on travaille plus souvent
c'est une question générale des
retraites rend ce qui a pu unir notre
pays et avoir une bonne entente entre
les jeunes générations les vieilles
générations et qui permet de transmettre
en fait par la suite lorsque les gens
sont à la retraite tout ce qu'ils ont
appris au cours de leur vie et surtout
je pense qu'il y a ce qui m'offusque un
peu plus c'est les positions qu'adopte
qui sont un peu égocentriques mais en
fait les gens qui mettent en place
l'allemand en fait assimiler un peu tous
les travaux et sans prendre en route la
pénibilité du travail qui est
extrêmement importante et les travaux
par exemple dans un bureau à la défense
demande physiquement beaucoup moins de
force par exemple qu'un travaux qu'un
travail qui va ce qui va se dérouler
dehors pendant toute une vie et qui a 50
ans en fait ce sera tout simplement
impossible de travailler et donc je
pense c'est un peu ces deux points là
qui qui sont importants à mettre en
avant vous êtes vous êtes jeune vous
avez 20 ans je crois vous me la retraite
c'est c'est dans le montant voilà la
retraite c'est dans longtemps mais quand
il y a des gens qui restent là plus
longtemps à l'autre extrémité il y a des
gens qui peuvent pas rentrer sur le
marché du travail donc indirectement ça
peut nous impacter déjà et puis si on
commence par 64 ans aujourd'hui en 2023
ça sera la porte ouverte
en allongement encore plus encore plus
net quand on sera un peu plus âgé quoi
donc je fais ça aussi par solidarité
pour mes parents qui vont certainement
travailler plus longtemps et aussi pour
ma mère parce que je crois que c'est
assez inégalitaire pour les femmes cette
réforme également voilà qu'est-ce qui se
dit dans le dans le monde étudiant
est-ce que vous avez vous venez en
nombre est-ce qu'il y a par exemple
d'autres camarades de classe qui ont
décidé de venir aujourd'hui alors on
n'est pas forcément très nombreux mais
surtout les je pense qu'il est vraiment
les représentants cet esprit humaniste
de l'ESSEC
d'ailleurs qui se définit en trois
piliers rice together et
et je pense que c'est
[Musique]
bien d'incarner en vrai ces valeurs
humanistes et de sortir vraiment de
cette caricature de du Shark de Wall
Street pour vraiment vous intéresser
également aux autres sociales ce
qu'évidemment nous on n'a pas on n'aura
pas être au pénible à venir dans les
travaux plutôt simple bien améliorer etc
on est vraiment là pour
partager pour pour c'est ça pour ne pas
que nous préoccuper de notre sort mais
également sur des autres on a vu des
belles images aujourd'hui avec par
exemple tout à l'heure à l'écran un
clapping comme on dit on a vu également
des des champs d'étudiants avec des
sourires on a aussi vu malheureusement
des poubelles incendiées quelques
vitrines cassées c'est dommage ça ça
cache le ça gâche un petit peu le
message ceci il le fait ça fait chaud à
la peau mais ça me fait froid au cœur
c'est vraiment une dérive de les
manifestations qui hélas courante des
gens qui croient qu'ils peuvent exister
avoir une sorte de
[Musique]
fin de de notoriété en faisant ces actes
qui sont juste stupides qui nuisent au
poumons des nous tous qui nuisent
également à notre environnement
voilà pour cette cette réaction de de
ces trois jeunes étudiants alors que
vous le voyez derrière nous c'est le
cortège de Nanterre qui s'apprête à
passer à passer devant donc voilà les
les étudiants qui sont qui sont
mobilisés cet après-midi qui battent le
pavé dans les rues de la capitale merci
beaucoup Timothée Delam merci d'avoir
donné la parole à la jeunesse présente
dans cette manifestation gym Jarrassé
bonjour bonjour Thibault rédacteur en
chef du service politique du du figure
moi il y a une pause dans les grèves là
à cause notamment des vacances
aujourd'hui c'est un nouveau test qui a
le plus à perdre les syndicats si il
mobilise pas ou le gouvernement si
justement pour l'emploi je pense que
c'est les syndicats je vais m'expliquer
là on est rentré aujourd'hui dans une
dans une guerre des nerfs qui est aussi
une guerre du calendrier
et qui
qui sera de savoir qui va tenir le plus
longtemps qui peut tenir le plus
longtemps et dans cette gare là il y a
une tout le monde ne part pas sur un
même pied d'égalité puisque le
gouvernement finalement
a le temps pour lui c'est à dire que en
fait il se base lui sur l'examen du
texte au Sénat et à l'Assemblée
nationale donc ça là l'examen du taxi va
se terminer en fin de semaine au Sénat
puis qui donnera lieu à une commission
mixte paritaire
entre députés sénateurs donc là on est
parti sur encore minimum deux semaines
de débat par le notaire et deux semaines
c'est très long potentiellement pour les
syndicats dans le cadre on verra ce soir
ce qui est dit par l'intercy syndical
mais dans le cadre d'une éventuelle
grève reconductible suivi
quotidiennement tous les jours des
grèves tous les jours des blocages ça
veut dire tous les jours une perte de
salaire exactement c'est très long à
tenir et il va falloir réussir à garder
le niveau de mobilisation suffisamment
haut pour que et bien ce mouvement ne
s'essouffle pas donc là évidemment sur
cette journée on s'attendait à une forte
mob avec le cas là on est à 6% de
mobilisation on a eu les derniers
chiffres il y a quelques il y a quelques
secondes je vais vous les donner si vous
voulez
alors attendez je vais vous retrouver ça
dans quelques secondes mais on est on
est sur une mobilisation accrue par
rapport on parle voilà donc 692
000 manifestants contre 675 000 le 31
juin janvier soit
environ 6,5% de plus que la journée du
31 janvier
parce que à cette heure-ci au total il y
avait eu un million 270 000 manifestants
en France le 31 janvier donc évidemment
aujourd'hui qu'on a une sur une journée
réussie de la part des syndicats c'était
attendu il y a pas de grande surprise la
question c'est combien de temps ils vont
pouvoir durer oui et là là dessus je
pense que l'exécutif lui a déjà annoncé
la couleur c'est à dire qu'il n'allait
pas donner de nouvelles concessions au
syndicat sur le fond du texte il mise
sur le vote du Sénat qui doit intervenir
d'ici la fin de la semaine
qui va permettre de renforcer la
légitimité de ce texte puisque pour la
première fois ce texte va avoir le
il y a c'est bien parti c'est très bien
parti d'accord ce texte va avoir le saut
de la représentation nationale oui c'est
important symboliquement et donc oui ça
légitimise voilà et bien sûr et si
jamais
la commission mixte par État qui sera
donc proposé de cette sénateurs et 7
députés qui se réunira la semaine
prochaine représentative des chambres
donc c'est ça représente l'équilibre les
équilibres où ça en échange donc par
exemple pour le l'assemblée il y aura
environ 3 députés de la majorité et 3D
enfin deux députés nups ARN et un LR
donc ça sera le député LR qui sera un
peu le faiseur de roi 3 3 et elle a
l'air faisant à l'Assemblée
ça semble être le cas réussir à réussir
à trouver un deal à la fois au scénar et
l'assemblé avec le gouvernement et bien
ce texte sera voté et la question c'est
est-ce que les syndicats peuvent
continuer à mobiliser
leurs adhérents et les Français contre
un texte qui a été voté qui a reçu l'as
sentiment de la représentation de la
représentation nationale ça s'est déjà
vu mais c'est compliqué Marie-Cécile
Renaud disait que certains syndicats
étaient légitimistes elle parle de la
sève d'été qui pourrait dire c'est voter
Laurent Berger en privé le dit et il le
dit très clairement c'est pas le cas la
CGT mais la CFDT à partir du moment le
texte est voté définitivement la sfdt
arrête ces mouvements alors vous me
dites que ça peut être très long pour le
syndicat mais
demain nouvelle journée de mobilisation
si ça prend après demain nouvelle
journée immobilisation samedi est-ce que
ça peut devenir long pour le
gouvernement l'histoire n'est pas écrite
c'est pour ça on peut pas donner de
réponse définitive par définition un
mouvement social et imprévisible et
c'est comment dire finalement la
tectonique des plaques sociales qui va
dicter l'agenda des prochaines des
prochaines semaines mais
si la mobilisation est très suivie on ne
sent pas non plus que le cœur je veux
dire l'état profond des Français va se
mobiliser contre cette réforme et il
peut même y avoir un effet
inverse un verre pour les syndicats
c'est à dire que les blocages peuvent
aussi retourner les Français contre les
syndicats totalement exclu non plus pour
l'instant
l'opinion publique est en faveur de la
grève en tout cas contre la réforme de
tiers et selon certains sondages ils
sont un peu moins être en faveur des
blocages mais une majorité le son quand
même il y a une donnée aussi qui est
importante en ce moment je pense c'est
celle de l'inflation je pense qu'on est
dans un contexte d'inflation continue
depuis plusieurs mois que l'inflation se
poursuit on parle d'un mois de mars Au
mois de mars rouge voir le printemps
rouge avec des prix qui dépassent les
les niveaux l'inflation notamment sur
les prix alimentaires qui dépassent les
10% je pense que ça c'est la donnée
centrale aujourd'hui pour les Français
et que ils ne peuvent pas mener de front
la prise en compte de cette de cette
inflation et donc l'impact sur le
pouvoir d'achat des
les Français et puis ce combat pour la
réforme de retraite qui coûte aussi de
l'argent bien sûr
et donc alors de façon un peu
machiavélique on peut penser que c'est
une bonne chose pour le gouvernement que
ça va pouvoir permettre de circonscrire
cette cette mobilisation en tout cas
c'est sûr que ça haute des possibilités
de mobilisation massive des Français
contre cette réforme nous sommes
toujours en direct on voit ces images
avec ces forces de l'ordre CRS ces
gendarmes mobiles qui encadrent cette
manifestation en quelques incidents
visiblement rien de très grave pour
l'instant selon nos reporters même si il
y a quelques tensions on parle un peu
des du gouvernement est-ce qu'il a perdu
pied pardon ce que j'ai lu par exemple
qu'Elizabeth borne n'était pas fan
d'Olivier du soft si c'est vrai j'ai vu
que
ils s'entendent très bien voilà ils se
parlent beaucoup ils sont en contact
très régulier c'est ce que je dis en
tout cas Olivier du socle après c'est
vrai que
comment dire il y a eu il y a eu des
erreurs de communication
qui prévoit une sorte d'apocalypse du
soft qui valide le rassemblement
national à l'Assemblée bon je sais pas
si c'était très bien tactile et puis
Macron quasiment absent alors on le voit
beaucoup sur la scène internationale
mais qui peut sur cette réforme des
retraites ce que je trouve très
intéressant vous parlez de mélange
peut-être d'Olivier Véran et et
du soft c'est que
ces deux ministres viennent de la gauche
oui et que en fait les deux ministres
qui aujourd'hui sont chargés de porter
la parole sur d'ailleurs c'est ok aussi
le cas pour Elizabeth borne sur la la
réforme des retraites son tissu du Parti
socialiste et et ont un discours
finalement et défendre une réforme qui
réforme de droite on va pas on va pas se
colorer parce que Olivier du sable dit
l'inverse oui alors ça il dit l'inverse
mais personne n'y croit je veux dire et
je pense aussi à Gabriel lui aussi porte
cette réforme en tant que ministre du
Budget et qui a fait c'est une réforme
la preuve le Sénat l'avote depuis des
années et c'est d'ailleurs cette version
qui va certainement prévaloir à l'issue
des débats donc oui c'est une réforme de
droite et on se retrouve avec des
ministres qui doivent défendre une
issue de la gauche qui doivent défendre
une réforme de droite et qui du coup
faut un peu de l'excès de zèle et se
retrouve à dire des des âneries comme la
mobilisation va nous exposer à une crise
écologique et sociale sans précédent
ou alors c'est une réforme de droite et
le RN alors je mettrai une peut-être une
exception sur le ce qu'a dit Olivier du
sol sur le sur le rassemblement national
parce que il faut voir la violence avec
laquelle les insoumis se sont adressés à
lui pendant plus d'une semaine à
l'Assemblée on a parlé des voilà des
menaces de morts
traité d'assassin donc que finalement
sur cet épisode très précis et pas de
manière générale Olivier du SO disent
que la responsabilité a plutôt été
personnelle voilà je pense que plutôt
été du côté du RN que des insoumis
honnêtement ça me ça me ça me choque pas
mais pour vérande d'ailleurs il s'en est
ils sont excusé il a retiré ses propos
il a bien compris qu'il était allé un
peu loin et je pense que même un
ministre
issu de la droite n'aurait pas n'aurait
pas n'aurait pas dit cela nous verrons
si cela continue et j'ajoute j'ajoute
quand même je pense que le principe la
principale erreur de communication sur
cette réforme à nouveau elle incombe
notamment à au niveau du sub c'est le
quoi que sur les 1200 euros on en a
beaucoup parlé mais c'est vrai que ça
inspire ça a vraiment essayé le doute
sur les femmes également dans l'esprit
des Français sur Le le bien fondé de
cette de cette réforme et en fait
finalement on a compris assez rapidement
en tout cas dans la communication
gouvernement que cette réforme avait
avant tout un objectif purement
comptable économique et que derrière il
manquait quelque chose il manquait du
sens en fait à cette réforme et
d'ailleurs si j'ai encore une minute
là-dessus vous avez tout le temps ils
vont
le gouvernement d'ores et déjà essaye de
préparer les esprits à ce qui va arriver
au printemps c'est à dire une loi sur le
plein emploi en tout cas c'est comme ça
qui a le quel porte son nom pour
l'instant ce sera un ensemble de mesures
alors on dit des mesures sucrées je sais
pas si le terme est très compréhensible
les mesures sociales voilà en tout cas
des mesures plus sociales sur
l'organisation du travail on parle
notamment de l'expérimentation sur la
semaine des quatre jours ça peut être
aussi des améliorations sur le compte
épargne temps sur les seniors sur le
travail des femmes ça ça doit arriver
dans la foulée de du projet de loi
immigration donc d'ici printemps été
d'accord ce sera à nouveau Olivier du
SOP qui sera à la manoeuvre le ministre
du Travail et donc ça va être l'occasion
pour le gouvernement de redonner
justement un peu de sens à sa vision du
travail mais peut-être aurait dû t-il le
faire avant l'arrivée de cette réforme
des retraites parce que j'ai
l'impression qu'ils ont mis un peu la
charrue avant les boeufs sur ce sur ce
sujet Emmanuel Macron
il a disparu de ça ne l'intéresse pas
cette réforme des retraites si je suis
absolument tout on a même vu je disais
récemment dans un article
qu'il avait félicité
ministre Attal qui porte aussi
d'ailleurs qui est aussi au banc sur la
réforme des retraites et qui voilà qui
vient d'ailleurs lui aussi de la gauche
en effet et qui et qui avait lors du
début des de l'examen du texte à
l'Assemblée livrer un discours très très
offensif et qui avait été apprécié au
sein de la majorité et par Emmanuel
Macron lui-même qui avait envoyé un
petit message comme il s'est souvent le
faire assez
[Musique]
mais en tout cas tout ça pour dire que
le Président de la République regarde de
très très près ce qui se passe à la fois
dans les chambres et dans la rue au
niveau des syndicat mais ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'en effet il n'en doute
absolument pas la responsabilité
politique et le portage politique de
cette réforme il laisse Elisabeth borne
et ses ministres en première ligne sans
doute a-t-il raison puisque en fait
finalement il n'y a que des coups à
prendre sur cette réforme sans nul doute
il retrouvera je pense une forme de
d'offensive politique si jamais le texte
est voté je pense que Emmanuel Macron à
ce moment-là un moyen de se réapproprier
cette réforme de télévision
assez rapide déjà il a fait deux visites
une première visite
sur l'alimentation
à Rungis pardon je cherchais à Rungis où
il a déjà défendu la valeur de travail
et la réforme des retraites et puis à
nouveau au salon de l'agriculture lors
de l'inauguration oui à la fois il a
encore soutenu cette réforme mais
c'était vraiment
service minimum quand même je suis
d'accord et je pense que le président
derrière va donner un peu plus d'élan à
cette réforme une fois qu'elle sera
votée mais pas avant on a parlé de
gouvernement parle un peu de
l'opposition d'une si vous le voulez
bien tiens l'opposition de la rue parce
que certains ont choisi la rue pour
manifester même s'ils sont à l'Assemblée
je pense à la gauche
pourquoi la choisisse cette méthode-ci
pourquoi elle a choisi le combat plutôt
que le débat
non mais il faut faire la différence
quand même entre les différents
partenaires de la nupesse sur cette
question là vous avez raison mais à la
fin il y a eu ce que décision qui a été
il y a une décision non il y a de la
décision au sein de la nups était
d'aller jusqu'au vote de l'article 7 à
l'Assemblée ça n'a pas été suivi par les
insoumis qui ont tout fait pour que les
amendements ne soient pas tirés
d'ailleurs ils ont il y a une injonction
très très ferme de la part de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon via Twitter à ses camarades je
sais pas si on peut encore les appeler
comme ça à ses anciens camarades
communistes pour les invités à ne pas
retirer leurs amendements et pour
bloquer l'avancée des débats à
l'Assemblée les socialistes les
communistes et une partie des
écologistes pas tous étaient pour mener
le débat à son terme et pour avoir cette
discussion de fond quatre temps de je
pense une majorité de Français à
l'Assemblée alors là on voit Olivier
fort en effet aujourd'hui dans les dans
les vous l'avez interviewer il y a
quelques minutes dans les dans les
cortèges
il ne leur reste plus que ça en fait
finalement à la gauche pour s'opposer à
cette réforme puisque maintenant en fait
le l'étape crucial qui était celle de la
première lecture à l'Assemblée est
passée alors il va rester l'étape de la
commission mixte paritaire mais ça va
être beaucoup plus stratégique et
beaucoup plus politique il y aura
seulement quelques représentants
on peut alors ils sont pas encore
totalement nommés mais chacun décide je
pourrais pas encore vous dire
chaque groupe décide chaque groupe
décide donc évidemment ça va être je
pense que non ça va être plutôt les
rapporteurs et ceux qui sont en charge
vraiment de la partie de
l'accompagnement technique sur le taxis
vont être est-ce que ça va être une
discussion justement sur le fond sur les
amendements sur les fonds
[Musique]
les représentants des différents con
quand n'auront pas de liberté de vote
lors de la CNP
suivront ce qu'on leur a demandé de
faire je pense notamment aux
représentants de LR évidemment je pense
qu'il va être fortement incité à voter
pour cette réforme en tout cas si c'est
là
exactement
de des républicains lors de cette
commission mixte paritaire je reviens
vers vous Jim dans un instant mais on va
sur le terrain d'abord avec Timothée
delhem le cortège qui s'est arrêté un
instant parce que on le voit sur les
images depuis tout à l'heure Timothée il
y a pas mal de CRS pas mal de forces de
l'ordre cela veut dire qu'il y a pas mal
d'incidents
oui Thibault pas mal de forces de
l'ordre qui ont comme vous le voyez sur
ces images sorties et bien les casques
les visières le bouclier il faut dire
que là il y a une scène de tension des
scènes de tension même pour tout pour
tout vous dire et pour être tout à fait
juste c'est vrai qu'il y a eu de longues
de nombreux lancés de de
projectiles il y a également eu des des
gaz lacrymogènes qui ont été qui ont été
lancés pour et bien tenter de disperser
la foule nous nous trouvons au niveau de
l'arrêt Port-Royal Berthollet voilà et
le cortège qui du coup est arrêté le
cortège syndical en tous les cas qui est
à l'arrêt et donc une période un petit
peu bizarre parce que les gens les gens
s'observent les gens ne comprennent pas
vraiment ce qui se passe parce que les
échauffourés sont quelques dizaines de
mètres plus loin donc évidemment on voit
pas précisément ce qu'il se passe il y a
voilà du coup quelques quelques échanges
avec les forces de l'ordre alors que là
voilà projectile qui vient d'être lancé
en leur direction c'est pas passé loin
on va faire attention donc voilà c'est
vrai que c'est assez tendu on sent que
voilà ça peut ça peut partir ça peut
déraper à tout moment même si pour
l'instant ça reste ça reste contrôlé
quelques invectives aussi à l'égard des
des forces de l'ordre qui pour l'instant
sont j'allais dire replier sont tous les
cas positionnés voilà sur le côté de la
rue alors que un petit peu plus loin
et bien ils ont bloqué bloqué la la rue
pour tenter de et bien de faire en sorte
que cela revienne dans le calme alors
que précisément à l'instant je vous dis
ça il semble que le cortège commence à
repartir
merci merci beaucoup Timothée Delam
faites attention évidemment on continue
de parler de la gauche est-ce qu'elle
s'effracturé sur cette sur cette
séquence alors qu'elle aurait pu se
ressouder se solidifier là elle était
d'accord c'était un sujet sur lequel il
y avait pas de débat ils étaient tous
contre la réforme point il faut il faut
voir quand même le contraste entre un
front syndical uni une intercendicale
qui affiche un visage totalement uni
c'est la première fois depuis plus de 10
ans c'est le cas avec Monsieur Martinez
et Monsieur berger qui sont qui
s'affichent côte à côte dans les
manifestations
et puis le visage de cette mupes qui
était une coalition qui a été créée au
moment des des
législatif qui était finalement une
coalition de circonstances qui étaient
une bonne idée
j'en parle au passé alors qu'elle existe
encore mais la preuve qu'il y a eu
énormément de d'épisodes dans cette news
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui qui font
qu'aujourd'hui
elle n'a de collection que le nom
puisqu'en fait ils ne vote pas la même
chose il ne pense pas la même chose il
ne veut il ne vaut pas s'allier ensemble
aux prochaines élections que ce soit des
élections sénatoriales qui vont avoir
lieu à la fin de l'année
je peux pas le dire de façon définitive
mais ça en prend le chemin d'ailleurs
toute façon les insoumis sont très peu
présents au Sénat donc en fait ce sera
ce sont les sénateurs socialistes qui
ont la la main sur ces sélections et les
européennes il y a ces peu de chances
également que y ait une liste commune de
la nupesse aux élections européennes en
tout cas les socialistes et les
écologistes n'en veulent pas donc voilà
la question c'est quel avenir
aujourd'hui pour cette gauche qui avait
en effet une opportunité avec cette ce
combat fédérateur quand on voit le taux
de soutien des Français il y avait
quelque chose à jouer au niveau
politique pour pour la gauche elle n'a
clairement pas su le faire aujourd'hui
et c'est aujourd'hui les syndicats qui
ont tirent le les principaux bénéfices à
commencer par Laurent Berger le
représentant de la CFDT qui est
aujourd'hui finalement
le principal représentant de cette
gauche sociale démocrate ou réformiste
comme on peut l'appeler ok merci Jim
alors si j'ai une dernière question
parce que c'est un peu technique est-ce
que vous pouvez me faire ça en deux
minutes je vais essayer on s'attend à
quoi au Sénat quel est la suite du
programme parce que c'est pas facile
alors donc là on en est à l'article 6 en
ce moment
l'article 7 devrait normalement être
voté aujourd'hui cette nuit d'accord les
débats ont terminé à 3h du matin le
fameux le plus important qui est le
l'article central de la réforme que
c'est article sur le l'allongement à 64
ans de l'âge de départ à retraite à 64
ans donc évidemment c'est le cœur de la
réforme en tout cas c'est là-dessus que
les Français attirent
enfin mettre leur attention
donc votre de l'article 7 cette nuit
est-ce qu'on va aller au bout de ce
texte on doit aller au bout de ce texte
le en tout cas le le Sénat la la affirmé
genre l'archer dans son interview Figaro
la semaine dernière en a fait un
engagement personnel le président du du
Sénat il a sa disposition plusieurs
articles du règlement intérieur du
scénario qui lui permettent d'écourter
les débats de réduire le temps de parole
notamment des oppositions et donc et ben
d'espérer accélérer la la poursuite des
débats donc sans nul doute le il y aura
un vote solennel sur l'ensemble du texte
avant le dimanche sachant que en effet
les sénateurs débattent la nuit ce qui
est assez inédit au Sénat on a très peu
l'habitude de voir des débats à deux
heures du matin
sauf que là il y a un enjeu politique
fort pour la chambre haute 99% de
chances vous me dites que ce texte soit
voté et ensuite et ensuite donc la
semaine prochaine commission mix
paritaire d'accord cette députée cette
sénateurs il trouve un accord en CMP
c'est cette version du texte qui sera
ensuite définitivement soumis pour un
dernier vote finale à l'Assemblée au
Sénat mais finalement ça voudra dire que
il y a une majorité qui aurait été
trouvée puisque la CNP se sera mise
d'accord deuxième scénario il n'y a pas
d'accord en CMP le scénario 1 est plus
probable ça c'est compliqué à dire je
pense que je pense que c'est le plus
probable si jamais il y a un deal qui
qui est pérennisé avec les républicains
OK et que c'est la version du Sénat qui
qui survit finalement à cette CMP ce qui
pour l'instant je pense va être le cas
deuxième scénario c'est il n'y a pas de
Deal et donc là on c'est un peu le
scénario catastrophe pour le
gouvernement puisque c'est une nouvelle
navette qui recommence avec deux
lectures à l'Assemblée vidéo Sénat on
refait tout le jeu etc aussi long que ça
alors ce sera peut-être accéléré je il y
aura peut-être pas tous les 50 jours ah
oui de toute façon d'ici au 28 mars le
le Parlement de grâce au pronoms en fait
il ne restera 7 le 12 se termine il y a
une semaine
petite dizaine de jours dernière navette
le cas échéant donc ça ira plus vite et
donc là tout peut arriver y compris 49-3
si jamais le gouvernement est plus court
et dernière question l'ordonnance j'en
entends parler le gouvernement peut
faire passer ce texte par ordonnance ça
j'y crois assez peu d'accord là il a il
a un texte de loi qui est prêt qui a été
amendé
et qui lui permettra
de faire passer sa réforme je pense que
le gouvernement dans s'il veut passer en
force à tout intérêt plutôt à passer par
le 49 3 et pour avoir l'application de
ce texte qui finalement sera
l'application d'un d'un deal qui aura
été négocié plutôt que passer par
ordonnance qui serait vécu par les
oppositions comme vraiment là un coup de
caniche dans le pacte politique qui aura
pu être passé
puisque là les ordonnances c'est
uniquement le l'exécutif qui a la
manœuvre et en plus c'est un champ très
restreint les ordonnances on ne peut pas
tout faire passer par ordonnance donc ça
aurait pour effet de limiter aussi la
portée législative et juridique de cette
réforme merci beaucoup Gilles verra ses
rédacteur en chef du service politique
du Figaro on retourne sur le terrain
Damien Canivez est-ce que vous avancez
oui vous êtes avec des manifestants
visiblement
oui exactement je suis avec Christian 75
ans retraité Christian bon vous venez de
la région parisienne vous hein c'est ça
vous venez pas très loin on vient de oui
de à côté de Fontainebleau voilà vous
venez à côté de Fontainebleau Christian
quelles sont vos motivations pour
quelles raisons êtes-vous ici dans ce
mouvement contre la réforme des
retraites sachant que vous-même vous
êtes déjà en retraites
on est là aussi pour les autres pour les
jeunes il y a énormément de jeunes ici
mais de toute façon
le problème c'est de savoir si oui ou
non on estime que cette réforme est et
logique et donc voilà on suit
effectivement l'opposition à cette
retraite c'est elle est injuste il y a
pas de raison de faire travailler les
gens comme ça enfin sans aucune
sans aucune raison quoi voilà l'argument
du gouvernement qui consiste à dire que
l'espérance de vie s'allonge donc du
coup qu'on doit travailler plus
longtemps celui-là vous ne l'entendez
pas mais non c'est pas un argument ça
ça s'allonge et alors la fin de la vie
ça doit être une fin de vie de de de de
loisirs de loisirs exactement c'est pas
on n'est pas voilà on est on est pas là
pour travailler jusqu'à la mort bon donc
on travaille pas jusqu'à la mort on
travaille il y a une date de retraite et
on en profite et je peux vous dire que
moi je suis justement retraité mais
quand on est retraité on sert à la
société on garde les petits enfants on
est on émerve si on peut l'être on voilà
donc il y a plein de raisons qui peuvent
faire que on a on a une période de la
vie qui doit être efficace à la fin quoi
vous cristaux il y a beaucoup de monde
là autour de nous est-ce que c'est la
première fois que vous participez à
cette manifestation la première fois moi
je suis militant depuis toujours donc
vous avez fait les 5 mes mobilisations
précédentes
bien sûr et vous êtes étonné de ce
mouvement assez assez impressionnant il
faut dire les choses comme elles sont de
cette foule qui défendent parce que
l'autre là il entend rien Emmanuel
Macron c'est ça
il entend rien donc il faut bien lui
faire entendre les choses quoi faut
qu'il comprenne quand même bon en tout
cas pour l'instant on n'a pas les
chiffres officiels à Paris mais je peux
vous assurer que nous sommes toujours
boulevard du Montparnasse depuis tout à
l'heure et le cortège n'en finit plus il
y a énormément de monde ici dans les
rues de Paris
merci beaucoup Damien cadeau avec donc
un manifestant pour les premières images
en bas à gauche de la place d'Italie
vous arrivez de ce cortège bonjour
Sophie davinel alors porter journaliste
au service politique du Figaro en charge
de la gauche vous étiez dans la
manifestation tout à l'heure
[Musique]
qui qui débutent et surtout pour aller
rencontrer le Parlement de la news la
news les représentants tout le cortège
politique qui s'était donné rendez-vous
au 116 du boulevard Raspail à quelques
quelques centaines de mètres de l'hôtel
Lutetia donc du départ à peu près place
Babylone
mais je pense que Olivier fort n'avait
pas Solférino en tête là ils sont tous
Olivier fort le patron du PS ils sont
tous fixés sur
l'évolution du du débat au Sénat j'ai
entendu que vous en parler avec Jim
juste avant moi et de fait c'est
vraiment leur préoccupations de faire à
tous ces parlementaires
insoumis écologistes socialiste et
autres
écologistes je les dis communiste je ne
sais plus lesquels j'oublie
socialiste écologiste insoumis voilà
alors la nupette en tant que tel
n'existe pas au Sénat elle n'existe que
à l'Assemblée nationale
des réunions très très régulières entre
eux ce qui n'est pas le cas donc encore
une fois au Sénat mais une gauche unie
c'est ce que nous a dit Laurent c'est ce
que nous a dit Pierre Laurent pardon
sénateur de Paris ancien patron
communiste
euh qui a souligné que contrairement à
l'Assemblée nationale
au Sénat la droite était unie au
gouvernement et que donc malgré cela ils
espérait faire barrage mais globalement
ils sont à peu près tous d'accord pour
dire qu'il faudra attendre le retour à
l'Assemblée nationale pour espérer
pouvoir s'opposer de façon concrète
c'est tout ce qui nous ont dit tous dans
la rue cet après-midi
même au sein de l'Assemblée nationale
à ceux des députés de droite qui sont
comme le dit
Olivier Faure donc le patron des
socialistes les vrais gaullistes s'il en
reste donc ceux autour d'Aurélien
Pradier sur lesquels ils peuvent espérer
compter pour s'opposer à l'Assemblée
de faire barrage à ce texte je me disait
il y a un instant que cette nuit pêche
elle se défacturé là tout à l'heure
quand vous les voyez ils sont ensemble
est-ce que vous avez un écologiste en
sociologiste un insomnie et un
communiste absolument ils étaient à côte
à côte ensemble je ne dirai pas Manon la
main puisque Jean-Luc Mélenchon
un vrai projet commun non non comme
d'habitude Jean-Luc Mélenchon était
parti à Marseille
disons qu'il y a une préoccupation
commune il y a une lutte commune qui est
cette lutte sociale contre la réforme
les les fonctionnements internes à
chaque partie leur importe peu dans ce
cas-là à ces moments là
moi je les ai trouvés tout à fait
uni après c'est vrai qu'il y a des
différences j'ai entendu donc manuel
Bompard le numéro 2 les insoumis dire il
faut absolument que
Mélenchon
[Musique]
du noyau autour de Jean-Luc donc député
de Marseille dans la circonscription qui
était celle de Jean-Luc Mélenchon dire
que la dissolution serait la solution
pour Emmanuel Macron pour sortir
disons la tête haute de cette crise ce
que ne soutient pas du tout Yannick
Jadot écologiste que j'ai interrogé sans
mettre plus loin qui disait mais ça il
est pas question de plaquer un agent de
la politique sur un agenda social et de
fait les écologistes voient d'un assez
mauvaise oeil et Yannick Jadot en
particulier d'un mauvais œil cette idée
de de dissolution parce qu'évidemment
c'est toujours l'agenda de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui se dit je pourrais bien
redevenir Premier ministre justement
vous me dites Mélenchon Jean-Luc
Mélenchon était à Marseille souvent et
de fait une de manifestation à Paris il
me semble il en a fait une
en fait quand on mélange on n'est pas là
les souris dansent et tout le monde se
sert à rien c'est lui qui crée
[Musique]
Jean-Luc Mélenchon il ne crée pas tout à
fait l'unité autour de lui il le sait en
ce moment en particulier c'est peut-être
une des raisons qu'il pousse à rester à
Marseille qui est sa terre d'adoption
d'origine
oui depuis peu enfin disons depuis qu'il
a été élu député il y a quelques années
il a beaucoup tourné dans toute la
France dans voilà on s'interroge
d'ailleurs à chaque élection savoir à
quel endroit il va il va s'implanter
et de fait non en fait il y a pas
vraiment aucune figure de la nubes qui
ne fédère autour de lui
François Ruffin qui fédère une partie de
cette de cette gauche était lui à Amiens
aujourd'hui sur les ronds-points et et
en marche là-bas
et en fait bon voilà chacun avait un peu
son propre agenda géographique politique
de territorial mais je pense que
aujourd'hui vraiment la priorité ça
n'est pas l'action politique mais c'est
l'action des organisations syndicales et
je crois que ça ils l'ont tous en tête
aussi
ils sont un peu en retrait par rapport à
ça Laurent Berger tout le mois de
janvier a dit qu'il était pas question
de saluer les cortèges de tête là il
cherche même plus à aller secours
je pense pour ceux qui ne connaissent
pas les habitudes des manifestations non
pas l'habitude des manifestations on ne
se sert pas la main surtout pas il faut
surtout pas qu'il y ait une photo d'un
syndicaliste qui prend qui sert la main
politique disons que les responsables
politiques sont dans des points fixes
les les responsables syndicales donc
circule c'est leur cortège c'est le pré
carré des organisations syndicales c'est
une séparation nette et claire
entre voilà il y a pas de mélange partie
d'air syndicale
et je pense qu'effectivement on peut
traditionnellement faire remonter ça au
lien historiques entre le Parti
communiste et certain syndicats dont la
CGT
aujourd'hui bon il y a peut-être des
ambitions de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
d'essayer de réunir un peu tout le monde
dans un seul en tout cas là il ne se
salue donc il se croisent évidemment
mais il y a pas de photo officielles il
y a pas de marche commune parce que
cette gauche au fond cette gauche
politique aimerait être un moteur de ces
manifestations et finalement non elle ne
fait que prendre la route et syndicats
qui eux arrivent à mobiliser parce que
on a vu par exemple un appel à
manifester Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'était au
début dans le mois de janvier ça a
beaucoup moins bien pris que lorsque les
syndicats appellent à manifester
manifester encore pourquoi c'est au
syndicat de le faire c'est eux qui le
font c'est leur responsabilité les
politiques n'aiment pas du tout quand
les syndicats se mêlent de politique
comme il y a eu en février quand
Laurent Berger et Philippe Martinez ont
exprimé le souhait que soit voté le
fameux article 7 qui était celui sur le
prolongement de l'âge de la retraite le
retard de l'âge de la retraite ou le
fait de repousser plutôt on ne cherche
les bons termes l'âge de la retraite de
62 64 ans
et donc les politiques l'ont bien dit au
syndicat ça n'est pas à vous de de de
nous parler de ça
non c'est vraiment pas qu'ils sont dans
la rue ou quoi c'est que en fait chacun
a son propre chacun à son propre tempo
et d'accord chacun son temps son rôle
mais est-ce que finalement en faisant
qu'ils ont fait à l'Assemblée les
membres de la nupes ne se sont pas
trompés qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait et
mettre bordéliser les débats comme les
insoumis oui comme oui mais de fait
toute la gauche et entachée de cette
réputation et de cette action là est-ce
qu'ils ne se sont pas trompés et
d'ailleurs Philippe Martinez s'en est
élu il est pas d'accord avec ça oui
enfin
c'était la stratégie insoumise qui a été
largement critiquée à gauche par les
communistes par les socialistes et par
les écologistes donc peut-être que les
Français associés en tout cas les
militants de ces parties là font bien la
différence
reste que ces débats à l'Assemblée et la
façon dont il se déroulent
à mon avis ne marque assez marcassé peu
les Français mais vous avez raison la
l'enjeu aujourd'hui pour les politiques
c'est aussi de marquer de leur présence
dans les cortège syndicaux parce que
jusqu'à aujourd'hui en tout cas et
jusqu'à cette heure-ci même s'il y a
encore s'il y a un petit peu de bazar là
dans la manifestation visiblement avec
quelques
actions des forces de l'ordre
pour l'instant c'est réservé voilà c'est
mineur
et bien l'enjeu là les syndicats ne
veulent surtout pas retourner l'opinion
politique contre eux donc les services
d'ordre des sont très très attentifs à
ce que les jeunes
casseurs les lignes noires ne viennent
pas bordéliser la manifestation
et c'est vrai que pour les politiques il
faut qu'ils trouvent un peu le l'issue
aussi un résultat à une façon pour eux
d'exister merci beaucoup Sophie de
Ravinel merci de vous libérer parce que
vous avez des articles à écrire pas tant
que ça mais on va suivre surtout la le
suivi de la manif merci
politique
nous on a les images depuis la place
d'Italie vous êtes où vous approchez de
cette place d'Italie
[Musique]
oui on approche on est à environ un
kilomètre de cette place d'Italie
toujours boulevard du Port-Royal bientôt
au niveau de l'avenue des Gobelins qui
nous permettra de redescendre sur cette
place d'Italie et pour le moment et bien
le cortège qui est complètement à
l'arrêt vous le voyez d'ailleurs sur ces
sur ces images en fait c'est assez c'est
assez frappant parce que ce ne sont même
pas les les forces de l'ordre qui ont
stoppé le cortège comme cela arrive de
temps en temps en fait il y a eu un
moment de de trouble de tension avec des
nombreux lancés de de projectiles en
direction des CRS que vous voyez juste
derrière moi et en fait maintenant les
gens s'arrêtent spontanément parce que
ils ont envie de regarder de voir ce
qu'il se passe et c'est ça qui est assez
frappant
voilà alors
vous choisissez de montrer juste il
semble avoir des choses à dire
ça me fait chier que toujours vous
montrer en tous les cas vous avez des
sens comme vous le voyez
de tension on va on va essayer de
continuer à terminer ce ce duplex parce
qu'on est en train de se faire avec TV
en tous les cas voilà un moment de de
tension malheureusement on a vu tout à
l'heure
nous ne montrions que des images de la
police n'est pas du tout le cas nous
sommes en direct depuis 14h et nous ne
cessons de répéter qu'il y a très peu
d'incidents et que ces incidents sont
mineurs on a vu quelques images tout à
l'heure Christophe Cornavin qui était
avec nous spécialiste des questions de
sécurité très bien informé auprès des
services de police et qui nous disaient
que même dans les boucles de messages de
la police et très peu d'incidents que
tout était plutôt bien géré tu vois un
grand bonjour bonjour journaliste au
service économie du Figaro
un nouvelle journée de grève aujourd'hui
alors pour l'instant on est à peu près
ce mardi 7 mars dans
le même état d'esprit que ce qu'on a vu
lors des premières journées de
mobilisation c'est demain que nous
verrons si la les manifestations
prennent une autre tournure c'est ça
alors oui et non déjà
dans l'annonce ça fait quelques jours
que
enfin depuis l'annonce le 7 mars doit
être une journée France à l'arrêt c'est
comme ça qu'elle a été appelée c'est
quand même un ton qui diffère des
journées précédentes
la phrase est différente il y a vraiment
envie de dire quoi ça veut dire qu'il
faut se mettre plus en grève au bloquer
oui exactement c'est à dire que les
autres journées c'était vraiment le but
c'était de rassembler on veut des
cortèges impressionnants on veut
beaucoup de monde voilà donc
effectivement ce qui sous-entend qu'il
faut par exemple limiter les grèves dans
les transports sinon vous bloquez les
les militants les sympathisants qui
peuvent venir vous rejoindre là au son
frère il a été clair de dire le message
était clair fait grève au maximum ça
c'est un mot de Laurent Berger même si
vous pouvez pas faire grève toute la
journée bloquer une heure bloquer deux
heures mettez des stickers voilà c'était
vraiment au maximum d'accord donc il y a
quand même une petite différence cette
marque avec les autres jours journée de
mobilisation en tout cas dans l'esprit
dans l'esprit effectivement voilà et
après il faut pas oublier qu'il y a ce
que dit l'Inter syndical qui est un peu
la tête de proue de la contestation
voilà mais il y a aussi tout un tas
d'autres acteurs y compris à l'intérieur
des syndicats qui ont aussi leurs
propres règles leurs propres agenda leur
propre vision et eux très clairement
autant les semaines précédentes ils ont
pu être canalisés par les bureaux qu'on
fait d'héros qui qui avait mis vraiment
l'enface sur avant tout l'unité l'unité
donc voilà et là on a depuis la semaine
dernière certaines fédérations notamment
au sein de la CGT qui sont passés à
quelque chose de complètement différent
qui sont sortis en quelque sorte du mot
d'ordre enfin qui sont allés au-delà on
va dire de ce que demandait la
Confédération en lançant des grèves
reconductibles voir ce qu'ils ont appelé
des actions coup de poing des coupures
ciblées on en a vu aujourd'hui oui alors
c'est ça on en est où aujourd'hui là il
est 16h50 on commence à avoir un aperçu
on a certains chiffres d'ailleurs par
exemple ce que je peux vous dire 39% de
grévis
à la SNCF c'était 46 le jeudi 19 janvier
c'est plus c'est mieux que le 31 janvier
qui était la journée de mobilisation la
plus importante par exemple
41% selon à EDF de grésist 46 le 19
janvier 40 le 31 janvier donc on est à
peu près dans le meilleur de grandeur
est-ce que en revanche sur le terrain
très précisément dans les zones qui
qui sont où les points de blocage sont
potentiellement les plus nuisibles
est-ce que aujourd'hui il y a des
blocages alors il y a deux choses il y a
effectivement d'une part un taux de
grévistes qui
ressemble un peu à ce qu'on a connu lors
des précédentes journées mobilisation
vous savez cité effectivement chez EDF
chez engie on tourne autour des 40%,
voilà des cheminots aussi il y a pas
d'explosion donc ça si c'était enfin
voilà c'est un peu quand même un échec
je pense de la part des syndicats qui
voulaient effectivement une journée à
l'arrêt donc on veut faire la même chose
que les journées précédentes c'est c'est
pas une franche réussite je comprends il
y a eu effectivement on a entendu de 6
de là tout un tas d'actions coup de
poing avec son combat des bois enfin on
les appelle comme on veut voilà des
coupures des pH gratuit enfin des
ouvertures de pêche des choses comme ça
des blocages aussi quelques-uns dans les
raffineries des choses comme ça
à l'heure actuelle on n'est pas du tout
sur sur un blocage du pays et puis en
plus pour ce qui est qui est des dépôts
c'est parfaitement inutile de bloquer un
dépôt 24h les relever le lendemain les
stations c'est justement donc on appelle
à la grève reconductible certains
syndicats appellent à la grève au
conductible est-ce que ça va cela va
avoir lieu demain alors c'est justement
cette journée importante et on peut se
poser la question de la Grande Peur des
cheminots la grande peur des
énergéticiens et de la CGT tout ça
c'était de sentir un peu seul que les
autres Français soient dans ce qu'on
appelle la grève par procuration c'est
en gros on vous soutient on a un tout
cœur avec vous mais nous par contre on
va bosser parce que voilà et vous bon
courage et c'est surtout ce qu'ils ne
veulent pas donc quand on voit
qu'on voit que les chiffres de la
mobilisation sont pas sont pas
exceptionnels on est en droit de se
demander est-ce que ça va tenir
longtemps d'un autre côté
ils savent aussi que
l'agenda parlementaire fait que il y a
une semaine deux semaines où il faut
vraiment y aller à fond et voilà donc
est-ce que c'est se dire que bon allez
après tout si on a que quelques jours
quelques semaines ça va donner un regard
d'énergie en quelque sorte ça c'est
difficile d'arbitrer sur ce qui prendra
le pas
ce qui prendra le pas l'un sur l'autre
l'une ça par exemple pas dans le faire
vire a déjà dit qu'elle elle vérifiait
elle vérifierait tous les jours le taux
de mobilisation de savoir si elle
continuerait ou elle continuerait pas
après elle a pas dit à partir de quel
pourcentage de grévistes elle estimait
que le mouvement n'est pas assez suivi
et elle-même se retirait donc en fait
c'est tous ces petits détails qui qui
peuvent vraiment faire effet papillon et
flancher d'un côté ou de l'Autrement on
était ensemble hier pour la question du
jour nous mendions si
nous devions craindre un blocage du pays
pour l'instant l'Inter syndical vous me
le disiez hier ne demande pas de grève
reconductibles c'est ça et elle ne le
demandera pas vous en êtes sûr ce soir
ils doivent s'exprimer comme tous les
soirs de manifestations aux alentours de
19h 20h21 il ne demanderont pas de rêve
conduite que ce n'est pas leur rôle ça
c'est le mot d'ordre aujourd'hui en gros
il eux cachent on peut dire derrière
[Musique]
ils veulent se voir comme une sorte de
réceptacle de la colère populaire et
donc en fait c'est aux entreprises aux
militants à l'intérieur de leur secteur
de leur usine de décider ou pas de la
grève reconductible pour eux enfin c'est
ce qu'ils disent c'est pas un message un
peu qui doit venir du ciel en mode
l'Inter syndical vous appelle c'était
une phrase je crois de Phil Martinez ce
qui disait j'ai pas le bouton de la
grève générale sur mon bureau
de Philippe partner ce matin qui disait
presque moi je suis pas chef mais ce qui
est très paradoxal si Philippe partitage
vous de la CGT c'est ça mais en même
temps effectivement ils doivent compter
avec une base qui
qui prend qu'à une certaine liberté
d'action et c'est surtout vrai pour
Philippe Martinez qui en fait à la CGT
les chefs de la n'est tout-puissant chef
de la CGT si je peux dire que pour un
mois un petit mois il faut pas vraiment
légitimité il y en a d'autres sûrement
qui sentent si je puis dire à l'odeur du
sens vous me permettez l'expression et
qui se disent voilà on sait qu'en plus
ces histoires de succession à la CGT
sont plus compliquées enfin c'est
compliqué assez j'étais voilà et donc il
y a une candidate désignée marabie son
qui ne fait pas duanimité certains
voudraient éventuellement tâter le
terrain voilà et donc ce jeu
amplifie le sentiment de liberté de ces
certaines fédérations déjà assez
puissantes et en fait ils veulent jouer
la carte de l'extrémiste un peu comme
une rampe de lancement en vue
d'éventuellement d'élections fin mars la
sève d'été au milieu de tout ça
qu'est-ce qu'elle veut qu'est-ce qu'elle
dit alors elle a donné le la lors la
première journée la CGTC s'est rangé
derrière la CGT en disant d'accord on va
faire ces journées de mobilisation coup
par coup
aujourd'hui elle ne dit plus grand chose
la CFDT elle a vu que ça ne marchait pas
sa manière de faire ben c'est un peu ça
effectivement au bout de cinq journées
de mobilisation ils n'ont pas obtenu ce
qu'ils espérait à savoir le retrait des
64 ans le retrait de l'article 7 ça
c'est très clair et c'était le deal dès
le départ en quelque sorte avec les
syndicats radicaux c'était vous me
suivez dans un premier temps sur des
grandes mobilisations
on teste le terrain et en plus ça nous
permet de progressivement se mettre dans
la poche l'opinion publique et dans un
deuxième temps si une fois qu'on a
l'opinion publique avec nous une fois
que on peut montrer que le gouvernement
n'a pas répondu à ce premier appel ça
nous laisse une une marge de manœuvre
pour
augmenter enfin durcir le combat tout en
pouvant un peu utiliser un moment de
dire bah vous voyez c'est le
gouvernement qui nous pousse dans cette
extrémité nous on voulait on voulait on
voulait pas voilà donc en fait c'est
très pratique donc effectivement les
syndicats Ré
ne sont pas dans leurs habitudes à la
reconductive la totale c'est des trucs
qu'ils ne font pas habituellement mais
ils vont plutôt dire effectivement
laissez leur militants se saisir de
leurs armes à disposition
sans juger sans critiquer mais même
probablement pas compliqué le cortège de
Force Ouvrière
accompagné de plusieurs autres milliers
de manifestants visiblement s'approche
et arrive Place d'Italie de fin de cette
manifestation parisienne en ce mardi 7
mars jusqu'où ça peut aller quand on dit
blocage total ça veut dire quoi bah
c'est une très bonne question il y a pas
de définition officielle de
du blocage total
pour la CGT ça veut dire être en
capacité de mettre à l'arrêt tous les
secteurs dans lequel elle a encore un
pouvoir de nuisances qui est très fort
c'est donc les ports les pores et les
dockers tout ce qui touche à l'énergie
on sait qu'elle est toujours puissante
du côté de EDF
voilà aussi totale les raffineries les
dépôts et ensuite le dernier point c'est
effectivement les transports SNCF voilà
je pense peut-être et éventuellement les
profs aussi même si effectivement la CGT
n'est enfin il y a un autre syndicap
plus important la FSU au sein des profs
mais en soi c'est effectivement toujours
un secteur dans lequel les syndicats et
notamment les syndicats les plus
radicaux ont une marge de manœuvre
encore importante je pense que si la CGT
arrivait déjà bloquer tous ces secteurs
de façon un peu durable et voilà général
elle estimerait qu'elle elle a réussi
son son blocage mais surtout elle si
elle fait ça son argument c'est de dire
qu'en fait elle veut que le patronat
prenne position elle estime que
enchaînant l'économie ça va obliger le
patronat à prendre position et à faire
pression c'est ce qu'elle espère sur le
gouvernement en disant ça suffit vous
nous empêchez de travailler reculer
voilà je pense qu'en fait un blocage
réussi pour la CGT c'est le jour où le
patronat fait pression sur le
gouvernement j'entends mais on en est
loin pour l'instant clairement c'est pas
c'est pas L'Express c'est pas la
tendance pour l'instant l'opinion
publique est plutôt du côté des
syndicats puisqu'il est plutôt contre la
réforme est-ce qu'il y a
s'il y a un blocage total du pays venait
à survenir à subvenir ce qu'il y a un
risque de perdre l'opinion bien sûr il y
a un risque de perdre l'opinion c'est
pour le moment c'est quelque chose qui a
été plutôt mis en avant par par les
syndicats c'est de réussir à mobiliser
sans embêter c'est vraiment quelque
chose pour lequel s'est battu d'ailleurs
Laurent Berger et la CFDT en général
les syndicats disent qu'il y a aucun
souci reste parfaitement convaincu que
il garderont l'opinion publique derrière
notamment pour ce que j'ai dit parce
qu'ils vont essayer de faire passer le
message que la radicalisation ne vient
pas de mais bien en fait d'une
obligation du gouvernement voilà donc
ils sont très confiants dans les faits
je pense que quand l'une ça a fait
revient dit on va regarder tous les
jours
le taux de pourcentage de mobilisation
ce qu'elle veut savoir en fait c'est
est-ce que ils vont continuer d'être
soutenir aussi et voilà et clairement si
l'opinion publique c'est rode tout va
s'arrêter très rapidement il est 17h
nous sommes en direct merci de nous
suivre sur le Figaro.fr sur Youtube vous
voyez ces images de Paris avec le
cortège qui arrive Place d'Italie
dernière question Thomas point qui peut
on dit souvent faire basculer les choses
les jeunes les étudiants les lycéens on
a toujours l'exemple de Mai 68 est-ce
que ça peut être le cas ça semblerait
étonnant aujourd'hui alors on a vu ce
blocus challenge lancé par le député
insoumis qui appelle les étudiants les
lycéens à bloqué leur lycée leur fac et
envoyer une photo sur les réseaux
sociaux avec ce hashtag effectivement
alors bien sûr un déficit de trier entre
les informations des syndicats ce qui
est le vrai ce qui est exagéré la FSU
disait 60% de grévise je crois que du
côté des préfectures on était plus
autour de 30%. voilà donc on n'est pas
encore sur un arrêt total et un blocage
intégral pareil certains syndicats
étudiants parlaient ce matin de 3 00
établissements 300 lycées bloqués ou
avec des actions mais sans savoir si ça
voulait dire qu'il y avait trois
personnes qui étaient devant pour
rentrer donc on a clairement pas à faire
en tout cas pour le moment un arrêt
général du secondaire ou du supérieur
merci beaucoup merci Thomas grand
journal et ce service économie du figa
on parlait des jeunes c'est ce qu'on va
faire on va aller rejoindre Damien
Canivez Damien vous êtes avec des jeunes
tiens ont-ils participé à ce fameux
blocus challenge
alors justement on va leur poser la
question parce que les jeunes avec
lesquels je me trouve c'est Martin et
Laure ils sont à l'université de Tolbiac
donc à Paris et effectivement leur
université est fermée comment s'est
passé le le blocage de l'université bah
du coup la rentrée lundi il y a eu un
blocage qui a été fait par des militants
et militantes sur la fac donc qui ont
commencé à bloquer les ascenseurs dans
l'objectif d'avoir une assemblée
générale qui soit réussie et qui soit
importantes et ça c'était bah comme ça
avait déjà été fait dans les différentes
journées de mobilisation précédente
parce que à Tolbiac il y a des
assemblées générales qui sont massives
de manière durable c'est sûrement les
plus grosses dans les universités en
France avec 400 personnes à peu près qui
se maintiennent là-bas et
qui se maintiennent dans ces assemblées
générales et même ça prend un peu de
l'ampleur parce que c'était pas
forcément le cas au début du mouvement
et ça prend vraiment de l'ampleur donc
il y a une vraie ce qui commence à se
créer sur Tolbiac mais là en fait ce qui
a décidé la présidence c'est que pour
éviter justement que ce tienne cette
assemblée générale dès le moment où les
ascenseurs de Tolbiac ont commencé à
être bloqué ils ont décidé de évacuer
l'établissement du coup après
l'évacuation de cette établissement ils
ont envoyé un email à tous les étudiants
étudiantes de la fac pour leur dire que
il fermeraient jusqu'à jeudi
la fac et donc bah peut-être qui
rouvriront jeudi ou pas et en fait on
sait pas trop et là du coup aujourd'hui
bon bah la fac était fermée dès le matin
par la présidence et demain ça sera
pareil je dis on sait pas on sait pas
trop ce qui se passera on verra bien
mais jusqu'au bout vous êtes capable
d'aller vous en tant qu'étudiant
étudiante en l'occurrence si jamais la
réforme des retraites n'est pas retirée
bah en fait on continue et on amplifie
ce qu'on est déjà en train de faire
évidemment on participe aux dates de
mobilisation faisait par
l'interventigale mais en fait on a un
peu proposé de dépasser ce cadre ce
cadre-là et ces dates là on parle
beaucoup du 7 en reconductible on pense
que la jeunesse elle a le pouvoir
justement de partir de suite en
reconductible là on a demain c'est le 8
mars la Journée du coup des pour les
droits des femmes et en fait on pense
que justement la jeunesse elle a la
force de pouvoir se mobiliser tous les
jours contrairement au grévistes nous on
perd pas d'argent quand on va en
manifestation quand on va en nager quand
on rate les cours alors c'est pas que on
rate les cours par plaisir mais en fait
dans le cadre de la mobilisation de
pouvoir aller en manifestation de
pouvoir s'organiser de pouvoir
multiplier les assemblées générales et
en fait ça c'est surtout les jours c'est
c'est ça permet à la jeunesse d'être un
peu un élan et et un moteur de la
mobilisation et je pense que c'est ça
qu'on continue à faire en fait c'est
c'est de continuer le 8 et puis le 9
aussi il y a une journée de mobilisation
étudiante donc avec une manifestation
étudiante en fait nous on appelle les
travailleurs à rejoindre cette
manifestation aussi et en fait on pense
que c'est ça le pouvoir de la jeunesse
c'est de pouvoir se mobiliser tous les
jours et de façon rapprochée de pouvoir
se déplacer dans Paris etc de pas être
restreint à son le travail et de pouvoir
aller parler au monde du travail et
amplifier le mouvement je vais vous
relayer une question de Thibault
Gauthier le présentateur sur Figaro Life
qui souhaitait savoir si vous aviez été
sensible à l'appel de Louis Boyard le
député de la France insoumise et ce
fameux je sais pas si vous en avez
entendu parler le blocus challenge qui
vise à bloquer non seulement
l'université mais envoyer les plus
belles photos du blocage qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez de ça alors moi je pense
que c'est un peu de la récupération si
je peux me permettre en fait je pense
que les étudiants ils ont pas attendus
de louboyard pour bloquer leur lycée et
que on a tout intérêt à ce que ce soit
initiative qui viennent de la part des
étudiants des étudiants mobilisés qu'en
fait on fait pas une story insta on fait
pas ça pour montrer à nos copains qu'on
a fait un super blocage pour pouvoir
être invité à l'Assemblée si aujourd'hui
les jeunes ils leur lycée c'est pour
demander une nouvelle société c'est pour
demander le retrait de la réforme c'est
pour demander un changement de système
plus de démocratie etc c'est pas pour
aller faire une visite guidée de
l'Assemblée je pense et de fin je remets
pas en cause le bien fondé enfin
peut-être qu'il a voulu amplifier les
blocages par ce moyen là mais je pense
que les étudiants n'ont pas attendu et
non pas attendre qu'un député qui n'est
plus enfin qui n'est plus scolarisé leur
demande à leur place quoi ils le font
déjà et ils le font bien et d'autant
mieux quand ils sont organisés entre
quoi pour moi ça c'est dit merci
beaucoup à vous deux Martin et Laure
pour le temps que vous nous avez accordé
sur Figaro live nous nous trouvons
actuellement en boulevard de Port-Royal
et comme vous pouvez le constater les
manifestants continuent de défiler
derrière nous direction la place
d'Italie voilà merci merci Damien qui a
niaise réponse direct pierre lepetier là
oui bonjour bonjour journaliste au
service politique en charge de la gauche
blocus challenge ça a fait des les émuls
au sein de la gauche un certain on
apprécier d'autres noms oui c'est moi je
trouve ça assez étonnant comme sorti on
comprend que Louis Boyard veut prendre
tous les outils qu'il est à disposition
pour à sa disposition pour amplifier le
mouvement là j'ai un peu un doute sur le
côté Tic-Toc le challenge Tik Tok c'est
en fait je trouve ça assez infantilisant
pour ces lycéens qui se qui se disent
conscientiser et qui effectivement je
rejoins ce que dit la jeune femme du NPA
donc plutôt dans la tendance voilà mais
elle a pas de problème je pense qu'ils
ont pas eu besoin de Louis Boyard pour
avoir envie de bloquer leur lycée et je
suis pas sûr que ce soit une visite de
l'Assemblée nationale qui va les motiver
je sais pas si compliqué de visiter la
santé
parle de la de l'opposition la gauche
donc
cette opposition qui est dans la rue la
gauche a fait le choix de la rue et pas
vraiment du débat parlementaire bah en
tout cas il y a une stratégie à
l'Assemblée nationale qui a montré quand
même ses limites avec l'obstruction des
insoumis on a vu que voilà que ça a été
très critiqué donc ça a apporté de la
confusion un peu à la confusion donc la
gauche politique se va dans la rue va
derrière les syndicats et en fait on la
voit on la voit sans la voir c'est à
dire qu'elle est là mais bon ce qui ce
qui mène la lutte ce sont les
organisations syndicales donc il y a un
équilibre pour elle a trouvé en montrant
que les voilà en première ligne tout en
disant que voilà une cherche pas à
remplacer les syndicats et d'ailleurs en
fait toutes les enquêtes d'opinion le
montrent ce sont les organisations
syndicales qui sont plébiscitées par les
Français et non les leaders de gauche
politique qui aimerait être un moteur
dans le fond on n'arrive pas à se
tromper en choisissant mal sa place je
pense qu'il y a une erreur d'analyse dès
le début depuis qu'il en monta plusieurs
mois et je pense que nous les
journalistes aussi qui est de en fait la
les syndicats reviennent en force oui
alors vous avez raison parce que il y a
eu la période gilet jaune voilà et où on
avait signé l'arène mort des syndicats
le légiste était sur le corps encore
chaud en
énormément de manifestations en fait les
syndicats semblaient voilà à bout de
souffle et donc les insoumis je pense à
eux mais une partie de la gauche aussi
mais surtout les insoumis dont Jean-Luc
Mélenchon théoriser le fait que les
syndicats avaient du mal et que donc
c'était la place du politique des
fédérations voilà de fédérer quelque
chose de nouveau autour du politique de
prendre la relève preuve d'être constaté
qu'en fait les syndicats ne sont pas
morts et qu'ils arrivent encore à mettre
des centaines de milliers de personnes
dans les rues donc je pense qu'il y a
une erreur d'analyse je pense que les
politiques ont été un peu pris de court
et ce qui explique pourquoi il se
retrouve un peu dans cette situation il
y a des tensions entre les politiques
les insoumis notamment et Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui est une figure la figure
de la gauche et
Philippe Martinez on sent une crise
passion là entre les entre les personnes
et entre les groupes il y a clairement
une crise passion il y a une
incompréhension il y a une défiance les
insoumis aimeraient davantage parler
avec avec les syndicats faites une
comprennent pas pourquoi les syndicats
refusent à ce point de discuter avec eux
en disant les insoumis disent regardez
si on serait vraiment tous ensemble on a
réparaitrait unis et donc ça créerait
des convergences et donc de la force au
mouvement et les syndicats disent
laissez-nous il y a une charte qui
s'appelle la Charte d'Amiens donc il
date de 1906 expliquez-moi ça c'est une
charte qui date de 1906 et qui c'est une
strict séparation du monde syndical et
du monde politique pour éviter que le
monde politique immerge le monde
syndical et donc les syndicats
s'appuient là-dessus pour dire
laissez-nous faire nos affaires et on se
débrouille très bien sans vous épreuve
est de constaté que c'est effectivement
le cas bon nous verrons si les relations
se réchauffent c'est pas parti pour
visiblement est-ce que cette gauche
c'est fracturé alors qu'il aurait dû se
solidifier pendant ces débats sur sur la
réforme des retraites comme on disait
c'est vrai que les débats à l'Assemblée
nationale ont apporté de la confusion où
il y a eu des stratégies différentes au
sein de la loupe est avec des insoumis
qui étaient pour l'obstruction et qui
voulait qui ne voulait pas en fait
arriver au vote de l'article 7 qui était
pour exporter ce qu'ils ont fait une
erreur alors c'est toujours facile à
dire après c'est peut-être pas facile à
dire pendant parce que nous verrons à la
fin des bouchers de cette séquence mais
est-ce qu'ils ont fait une erreur selon
vous en gros les insoumis disent euh ils
étaient persuadés que si l'article 7
était soumise au vote l'article 7 aurait
été voté et que donc tous les Français
qui ont une minimum une application
d'astuce leur téléphone au-dessus une
alerte en disant regardez l'Assemblée
nationale approuve le report de l'âge
légal et que du coup
et que du coup ça aurait mis un gros
coup de frein à la mobilisation voilà
après c'est un débat stratégique
effectivement
démocratie en disant nous on veut pas
parler on veut pas discuter avec eux
disent que cette vidéo de struction et
que ça fait partie des outils quel
Parlement enfin voilà mais c'est un
destin débat stratégique certains m'ont
n'était pas d'accord au sein de la
gauche je pense aux écolos je pense au
communisme je pense au socialiste ça
fait du monde quand même oui parce que
les séries je pense à la moitié des
insoumis oui parce que le reste de la
nupesse une bonne partie de la nuqueuse
en tout cas considérait qu'il fallait
écouter les syndicats pour ne pas
apporter encore une fois de la confusion
à la confusion or les syndicats
voulaient déplier un débat sur le report
de l'âge légal à la retraite et se débat
n'a pas eu lieu donc ça a créé de la
crispation un peu de tension ce qui est
franchement mal joué dans un contexte où
le contestataire devrait être uni s'il
veut faire face au gouvernement vous
voyez les forces de l'ordre des CRS
visiblement qui protègent ce restaurant
fast-food très célèbre des Black Blocs
qui visent souvent ce genre d'enseigne
nous sommes en direct de 17h12 je suis
avec Pierre Le Peltier pierre on a parlé
de la rue on a parlé de ce qui s'est
passé à l'Assemblée en ce moment il se
passe des choses au Sénat l'attitude de
la gauche là est très différente
expliquez-moi il n'y a pas d'insoumis au
Sénat de fait la stratégie de
l'obstruction tombe et finalement ça
revient à la stratégie des socialistes à
l'Assemblée à savoir en débat en débat
sur le fond et on bat le gouvernement
sur le fond après voilà on sait que le
Sénat est majoritairement à droite et
que du coup pour les socialistes ce sera
très compter pour la gauche ce sera très
compliqué d'imposer son point de vue et
pourquoi ils n'ont pas décidé si ils ont
une certaine manière subie c'est ça que
vous me dites de toute façon on est en
infériorité bon voilà on va essayer
d'amander et puis on se bat pas c'est
difficile de de ne pas subir quand on
est dans l'opposition
dans un dans un parlement et c'est ce
qu'on constate au Sénat et socialistes
ont du mal à lutter contre cette droite
qui voilà 100 ans avec le gouvernement
sur plus de développement pas mal de
points et donc
ça semble très compliqué pour elle de
d'empêcher en tout cas d'un point de vue
législatif cette réforme pierre on
revient dans un instant mais d'abord on
va sur le terrain Damien Canivez vous
approchez doucement tranquillement de la
de la place d'Italie bon il est 17h13
est-ce que vous pouvez faire un bilan
vous avez fait déjà plusieurs
manifestations est-ce qu'il y a plus de
monde que lors des précédentes
alors très certainement oui Thibault
c'est vrai que nous n'avons pas les
chiffres officiels on a pourtant sondé
quelques responsables syndicaux ici hors
caméra pour savoir quel était
l'affluence de cette manifestation à
Paris aucun n'est capable de nous dire
réellement quelle est l'influence mais
tout son unanime pour affirmer que oui
c'est un succès aujourd'hui dans les
rues de Paris pourquoi parce que il y a
toutes les générations qui sont
rassemblées dans les rues des jeunes des
moins jeunes des retraités vous les avez
vu sur l'antenne de Figaro life
puisqu'on est allé à leur rencontre il y
a beaucoup plus de monde que lors de
notre dernière que notre que lors de
notre dernier direct pardon dans les
rues de Paris vous pouvez voir que là il
y a un cortège essentiellement composé
de jeunes et c'est vrai que c'est ce que
je retiens particulièrement de cette
manifestation c'est la présence de
lycéens d'étudiants qui sont
ultra mobilisés et ultra motivés à
l'idée que cette réforme des retraites
soit jetée aux oubliettes par le
gouvernement nous avons parlé aussi avec
une étudiante tout à l'heure qui ne
souhaitait pas réagir face caméra mais
qui nous a dit que à Nanterre dans son
université elle avait bien l'intention
de bloquer jusqu'à ce qu'elle obtienne
gain de cause c'est ce que c'est les
mots qu'elle a utilisé et ses camarades
sont aussi sont aussi motivés et je peux
vous dire que parmi les syndicats qui
sont armés de leur sono et ben je peux
vous dire que les étudiants sont au loin
ceux qui faisaient aujourd'hui le plus
de bruit à Paris
vous me disiez à l'instant lorsque vous
écoutiez Damien canivelle ce que c'est
assez nouveau cette mobilisation des
jeunes oui en tout cas on la voyait
moins dans les premières mobilisations
donc ça montre aussi que le la
mobilisation change un peu de dimension
des jeunes on peut traiter plus attirés
par ce côté blocage du pays
parce que le rapport de force est de
fait plus important par ce genre de
d'opération
mais en tout cas effectivement les voyez
moins et d'ailleurs c'était un peu
regretté par la gauche ce poétique et
syndicale là si elle commence à
descendre dans la rue et si on voit des
blocages dans les universités etc c'est
vrai que ça peut donner une nouvelle
dimension mouvement
nous allons donc dans un instant
retourner sur le terrain mais vous aurez
qu'on parle un peu du gouvernement
pierre je sais que vous êtes spécialiste
de la gauche mais en tant que
journaliste politique vous avez
forcément une analyse fine de l'attitude
du gouvernement est-ce qu'ils se sont un
peu emballés ces derniers temps ce
qu'ils ont un peu perdu la main
notamment sur certaines déclarations je
pense à Olivier Véran qui prévoyait
quasiment l'Apocalypse en cas de blocage
total du pays on sent qu'il y a voilà il
y a une tentative un peu d'impressionnée
de faire un peu peur quand il parle
voilà de la cocaïne je sais plus
exactement
je pense que le gouvernement comptait
sur les vacances scolaires pour dire bon
tout ça va un peu se calmer va un peu
redescendre aujourd'hui on a les
vérifier ça bon il y a priori s'il y en
a pas d'Amiens autant de monde dans la
rue voire plus que d'habitude donc déjà
c'est un premier pari raté et ensuite il
faudra voir si la mobilisation dure et
en fait le gouvernement a tout intérêt à
jouer la montre parce que des journées
grève coûte cher en fait ce qu'il a fait
deux semaines à tenir à peu près il y a
deux semaines à tenir donc deux semaines
c'est quand même beaucoup pour des gens
parfois des des ouvriers des employés
qui ne sont pas très bien payés enfin
voilà ça c'est quand même un coup de
bloquer des établissements c'est quand
même compliqué enfin tout ce que ça
implique c'est quand même compliqué donc
le gouvernement peut très bien attendre
en fait et attend de voir si ça continue
ou pas il peut aussi jouer sur la
lassitude des Français parce que
finalement si les Français n'ont
toujours pas de train n'ont toujours pas
de métro ou autre et bah il peut y avoir
une certaine lassitude et ce que
l'opinion tiendra est-ce que l'opinion
suivra toujours le les manifestations
les mobilisations on vous verra dans les
prochains jours
ou pas pour l'instant pas beaucoup
[Musique]
on en a parlé du socle qui Olivier du
sable qui a validé le rassemblement
national à l'assemblée par exemple était
réprimandé par Emmanuel Macron alors
[Musique]
effectivement en tout cas les
oppositions en profitent pour dire
regardez c'est une acceptable et ça
donne ça remet dans la machine de la
manif de la mouton mobilisation en
disant regardez en plus ils s'entendent
bien avec le rassemblement national
alors évidemment c'est des arguments qui
dans un des manifestants de gauche et
ceux qui se manifestent enfin ceux qui
se mobilisent dans le monde de gauche
fait mouche tout de suite quoi donc oui
c'est pas c'est franchement pas très
malin est-ce que ça étonne certains que
les ministres
issus de la gauche porte cette réforme
plutôt à droite même si au lieu d'une
seule tu as déclaré récemment que
c'était une réforme de gauche je pense à
Isabelle borne je pense à Olivier du
socle je pense à Olivier Véran et je
pense à Gabriel Attal bah il constate ça
va être déjà un petit peu c'est que le
monde politique est très cynique et en
fait il est considère comme des
opportunistes
pour pour être dans un gouvernement ils
sont obligés de porter des textes qui
n'approuvaient pas il y a encore
quelques années et donc ça les fait rire
jaune entre guillemets merci beaucoup
pierre Lepeltier merci de nous avoir
apporté votre éclairage journaliste au
service politique en charge de la gauche
on retrouve on retourne sur le terrain
Timothée delhem vous êtes au milieu de
ces CRS c'est force de l'ordre il y a
quelques tensions visiblement
tu peux si vous vous m'entendez est-ce
que vous m'entendez bien Thibault ouais
je vous entends parfaitement vous avez
la main
alors voilà
vous le voyez peut-être sur ces images
grosse gros moment de de tension là ça a
éclaté il y a quelques quelques secondes
ce qui s'est passé c'est que
certaines personnes tout de tout de noir
vêtue ont commencé à s'en prendre à une
à une boutique de d'épargne ils ont
les vitres
donc grosse star derrière de des forces
de
disperser toute le monde donc c'est
voilà
de chant tout le monde déteste police
les manifestants
aucun moment de grande tension plusieurs
minutes qu'en fait le cortège comme je
vous l'expliquais
les manifestes
et on voit ces images on va rester
dessus
des images d'affrontement ce sont les
premières véritables de la journée et
presque les premières de ce mouvement en
espérant que cela ne prenne pas trop
d'ampleur Florent barako je reviens vers
vous dans un instant on va écouter et
essayer de s'imprégner de l'ambiance sur
place
on a du mal à avoir le son parce que
vous savez que dans ces moments là il y
a toujours beaucoup de monde je sais pas
merci d'être ici directeur adjoint de la
rédaction du Figaro.fr tiens ça vous
étonne ces images là ce sont les
premières depuis le début du mouvement
oui c'est les premières vous l'avez dit
Thibault c'était le Grand Paris réussi
de syndicats c'est que après deux années
de gilets jaunes avec des manifestations
qui étaient perturbées chaque samedi bah
là il y avait très très peu de de
perturbations de violence et on avait
dit ça y est c'est le retour des
manifestations à l'ancienne bien
maîtrisé par les syndicats et on voit
que en cette fin de journée alors c'est
compliqué avec ces images de voir
l'ampleur si c'est toute la
manifestation qui est impliquée mais en
tout cas il y a des images qu'on n'avait
pas vu avant il y a eu une seule fois il
me semble lors d'un des rassemblements
qui se terminaient derrière l'Hôtel des
Invalides place Vauban où il y avait eu
aller un petit quart d'heure
d'échauffourée mais ça avait été un
petit peu à Nantes en Provence
nous voulons certainement pas affolé
dire que Paris est à feu à 100
certainement pas le cas pour l'instant
il y a eu une pause dans ces greffes
Florent à cause notamment des vacances
aujourd'hui qui a le plus à perdre selon
vous entre les syndicats si il n'arrive
pas à mobiliser et le gouvernement si au
contraire se mouvement prend une ampleur
dingue alors les syndicats avaient
beaucoup pas perdre aujourd'hui parce
que après cette pause il fallait qu'il y
ait enclenche une polémique on a les
premiers chiffres si on voit ville par
ville et on a notamment un article sur
le sur le Figaro qui analyse les les
augmentations
tout à l'heure c'est très intéressant
que c'est plutôt en progression donc les
chiffres qui vont nous mettre
communiqués normalement dans les
prochaines minutes devrait soit égaler
soit battre le record du mois de janvier
du 31 janvier donc les syndicats
devaient réenclencher une dynamique et
le danger pour le gouvernement c'est que
cette cette manifestation c'est ces
manifestations pardon reprennent et dur
et là maintenant ça va être la durée
est-ce que la grève va être prolongée
massivement demain et ce qu'il va y
avoir du monde samedi avec un autre
public plus familial c'est ça les c'est
ça les enjeux de ces prochains jours de
chiffres à 17h que nous avons recensé au
figures au 944000 manifestants se mardi
en France à 17h record de participation
dans plusieurs villes et donc on
comparaison cette grande joie de
mobilisation du 31 janvier qui est le
record depuis le début du mouvement à la
même heure 932000 donc hausse légère
mais hausse quand même et plus que la
dernière mobilisation février qui était
à moins d'un million bien sûr moins de
500 millions il me semble même la toute
dernière qui était derrière
une mobilisation correcte elle fait
moins d'un million est-ce que la le
mouvement va prendre une autre dimension
une autre ampleur les syndicats sont-ils
divisés c'est la question qu'est-ce
qu'ils veulent ces syndicats on n'a pas
bien compris il y a les fédérations qui
disent nous blocage total et alors
l'interd syndical sont des douanes
complètement en disant oui vous savez on
sait pas peut-être qu'est-ce qu'ils
veulent qui joue la stratégie parce que
en fait tout l'enjeu de ce de ce
mouvement c'est de garder un équilibre
ça veut dire s'opposer sans bloquer
totalement le pays pour ne pas que
l'opinion se retourne parce que les
Français sont en majorité contre la
réforme sont en majorité favorable au
mouvement mais si ça venait à durée si
il n'y avait plus d'essence il ne
pouvait plus prendre le train plus
prendre les transports plus plus rendre
à leur à leur travail ça basculerait et
il serait en opposition et c'est un peu
le retour de l'ordre quoi les Français
aiment l'ordre donc ils sont sur un
équilibre en disant on s'oppose mais
attention à ne pas basculer dans quelque
chose de plus radical ouais mais alors
ils prennent souvent l'exemple de 95 en
les syndicats c'est bon le cache total
c'est la dernière fois qu'un
gouvernement vraiment reculé après
c'était une autre époque il y avait pas
le télétravail il y avait pas les les
RTT ça à prendre en compte vous avez
raison c'est très différent et certains
me prennent l'exemple de Mai 68 c'est
encore encore plus différent
là selon la tendance
qu'est-ce que craint le plus le
gouvernement c'est blocage j'imagine oui
c'est ça lui fait pas grand chose
de voir ces images un million un million
et demi de manifestants ce qui sera en
mode complètement ils s'en moque pas ils
regardent ça laisse traîner une petite
musique c'est les blocages c'est un pays
à l'arrêt qui est déjà confronté à une
crise économique à une inflation c'est
ça qui va poser problème au gouvernement
mais vous remarquerez que depuis le
début du mouvement les syndicats
n'obtiennent rien c'est finalement le
droit de parlementaire qui contient des
soit des avancés du côté des gens qui
veulent faire bouger la réforme ou des
concessions mais ce n'est pas ce ne sont
pas les syndicats qui obtiennent ces
avancées ou ces concessions d'ailleurs
ce mystère est-ce que quelqu'un va
l'éclaircir à un moment un autre ces
mesures sucrées donc plutôt social ont
été proposés par la droite qui depuis
des années réclame un durcissement sur
la question des retraites la grande
force d'Aurélien Pradier qui a réussi à
vous pensez que tout tourne autour de
lui et de ce là il a quand même réussi à
inverser un peu la tendance parce que au
début la droite voter caricature un
petit peu mais comme un seul homme un
peu la réforme et finalement il a il a
il instit un petit peu de doute
notamment sur les carrières longues sur
les petites les petites retraites et le
gouvernement comme ils ont absolument
besoin de LR ils sont venus un peu sur
le sur le chemin et pourquoi la droite
ne vote pas comme un seul homme cette
réforme des retraites telle qu'elle
était proposée à la base d'accord
Aurélien Pradier il y a un côté tactique
aussi oui alors vous allez pas donner la
victoire au gouvernement alors c'est une
droite opportuniste mais qui n'est pas
fidèle assez va leur première ah mais ça
c'est sûr puisque si on regarde la
campagne Fillon et la campagne Pécresse
il proposait une réforme des retraites
beaucoup plus dure que celle défendue
par Elizabeth borne bien sûr bon
toujours très étonnant de passer la
politique c'est la politique mais
d'accord mais il y a des gens qui votent
pour vous quoi qui le grand gagnant
c'est là d'ailleurs point de vue
politique est-ce qu'on le sait alors la
séquence n'est pas terminée l'heure où
on se parle qui est le gagnant
politiquement de cette séquence
peut-être les syndicats parce que on
avait annoncé que les syndicats
n'existaient plus
et qu'ils étaient mis en difficulté dans
une nouvelle manière de contester avec
notamment les gilets jaunes et
finalement on voit qu'ils sont capables
de mobiliser que ça se passe globalement
bien et qu'ils arrivent à parler presque
d'une seule voix ou à Laurent Berger
Laurent Berger d'ailleurs parliez de la
droite c'est très intéressant demain
Laurent Berger et rencontre des députés
LR vous imaginez ça il y a 5-6 ans voilà
c'est pour vous dire que les syndicats
et Laurent Berger il a une place forte
dans ce dispositif bien sûr mais il ne
semble pas vouloir prendre de décisions
clair et net Laurent Berger finalement
la droite et Laurent Berger sont dans la
même situation ils sont le pivot de la
situation mais c'est parfois un costume
trop grand apporté on parle un peu du
gouvernement
il a voulu agiter à la peur mais
certaines manières avec
le blocage du pays je pense Olivier vers
là après
notamment les syndicats notamment
Martinez ou la gauche avait promis un
blocage total donc ils ont un peu aligné
leur élément de langage sur cela Olivier
Véran il a rétropédaler des désirs en
disant qu'il avait peut-être
etc le gouvernement est et comment
dirais pris un peu en étau c'est à dire
qu'il essaye d'agir très très vite
puisqu'il a voulu que la réforme soit
votée très vite oui alors c'est un choix
en le faisant passer par ce projet de
loi de finance donc un vote comme le
budget et en utilisant donc cet article
47 ans qui permet de raccourcir les
débats il y a une deuxième chose c'est
que Emmanuel Macron joue la suite de son
quinquennat sur cette réforme donc en
disant oui je suis face au blocage face
à une France complètement arrêtée moi je
continue j'y crois je fais passer la
réforme des retraites et je suis un peu
seul contre tous et pour le bien de
l'intérêt général
contre l'opinion le seul contre
l'opinion puisque il y a un sondage ELAB
de d'hier 67% 69% des Français étaient
hostiles encore à la réforme parce que
le gouvernement a perdu le pied par
moment je j'ai plusieurs exemples j'ai
vu par exemple qu'Elizabeth borne pas
une grande fan d'Olivier du sol qui qui
porte le la réforme on parlait de cette
sortie d'Olivier Véran je pense au
rassemblement national validé par
Olivier du stop lui-même Emmanuel Macron
quasiment absent que fait le
gouvernement est-ce qu'il se laisse
porter en faisant on sert les fesses on
croise les doigts et on espère que ça
passe ou il est actif et il y croit et
il porte ce projet ils ont fait quelques
heures de comme je pense que typiquement
l'interview de d'Olivier du soft dans le
ce week-end dans le Parisien où il
déclare que la réforme des retraites et
de gauche c'est une sorte de petite
provocation c'est un élément de langage
qui va souder le camp le camp de la
gauche en disant bah regardez si on
regarde les la réforme notamment c'est
ce que pointe la gauche défavorable aux
femmes des favorable au carré longues
etc etc donc il y a eu quelques petites
quelques petites frictions après le
gouvernement a les cartes en main
c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont le Sénat qui est
plutôt favorable à la réforme des
retraites donc le Sénat a jusqu'au 12
mars pour déb voter les articles après
tout ce petit monde va se retrouver dans
une commission mixte paritaire cette
cette députée cette sénateur et pas
d'après les calculs ça peut passer
majorité LR au Sénat majorité
à l'assemblée
de la majorité dans cette commission
xparita dans cette partie députée tout à
fait et un lr7 on dit 8 7 voilà donc et
après on est vraiment dans du calcul
politique
et tout cela revient à l'Assemblée aux
alentours du 16 17 mars
et normalement si les gens si LR et
Renaissance se sont mis d'accord en
commission ça devrait passer mais là
c'est un dernier qui est arrivé cet
après-midi une sorte de tête de petit
inquiétude vous avez vu que le groupe de
la majorité a dit que les députés qui ne
voteraient pas la réforme ou qui
s'abstiendrait serait exclu du groupe
donc on va dire que certains députés de
la majorité sont pas hyper il faut les
convaincre l'idée de voter comme il faut
convaincre les la l'ensemble du groupe
LR bon on y revient dans un des calculs
politiques oui c'est vrai mais vous avez
raison on a sorti la calculette vous
aussi chez vous et en attendant on
retrouve Timothée délai qui est sur le
terrain on avait du mal tout à l'heure à
vous entendre Timothée au milieu des
manifestes tant avec certains
échauffourés visiblement qu'en est-il
alors on se parle
et bien Thibault les échauffourés qui
qui continuent là depuis de longues
minutes maintenant vous le voyez
d'ailleurs sur ces images de de Julien
Leclerc c'est c'est une une boutique la
de la Société Générale qui est en train
de se faire de se faire caillerasser les
manifestants qui viennent de partir
voilà alors j'entends où j'entends ici
ou là il y a un blessé il y a un blessé
c'est vrai qu'on a du mal à tout voir en
tous les cas voilà des grandes tensions
depuis maintenant de bonnes de bonnes
minutes voilà là c'est un magnifique
festan qui qui vient qui vient un peu
nous nous jeûner voilà grande grand
moment de confusion des tensions les
forces de l'ordre qui qui font quelques
charges pour essayer de disperser tous
ceux tout ce monde et en fait les
manifestants qui ne se dirigent plus du
tout vers la Place d'Italie ils sont
vraiment entre le boulevard du
Port-Royal et la place d'Italie donc sur
cet avenue des Gobelins avec voilà
complètement stagné là c'est un
manifestant qui demande à
Julien Leclerc derrière la caméra
d'arrêter de filmer donc voilà c'est un
peu tordu on va on va vous laisser
l'antenne dans tous les cas voilà
situation très confuse ici
merci beaucoup Timothée faites attention
Julien aussi en tout en essayant de nous
fournir au maximum un maximum d'images
pour que nous puissions nous rendre
compte de ce qu'il se passe dans les
dans les rues de Paris ça semble
continuer à ces tensions Florent ça en
tâche le mouvement la finalement et
c'est souvent comme ça que ça se passe
parce qu'il y a des manifestations de
genre avec de la violence c'est là que
le gouvernement réagit oui bah là ce
sont des images je pense que les
syndicats ne voulaient pas voir puisque
depuis le début du mouvement on le
disait tout à l'heure ça se passait
plutôt bien il y avait quelques
incidents là on voit des des incidents
avec la police qui se qui se déploie et
ça peut nuire au mouvement si ça prend
de l'ampleur pour l'instant je veux dire
que c'est quand même maîtrisé vous avez
raison ça sent le maîtriser et on va pas
parier à feu à 100 ou sans le contrôle
d'une certaine manière même s'il y a des
violences on revient la à la politique
de parler un peu de l'opposition si vous
voulez bien Florent alors on a parlé un
peu de la droite normalement dans votre
position sur cette question parle de la
gauche
elle a choisi la rue pour se poser plus
que l'hémicycle et le débat
parlementaire pourquoi alors elle a
choisi la rue pour sa frange à
l'Assemblée nationale parce que au Sénat
la gauche elle travaille dirigée par
Patrice Patrick
il bosse il apporte des abonne des
amendements etc oui la gauche elle joue
elle joue la rue parce que il y a un
terreau favorable c'est une réforme qui
comment dire qui touche un peu les
acquis de la gauche et donc ils y vont
on voit beaucoup la France insoumise
très très puissante on voit peu le Parti
socialiste
mais oui c'est vrai
minoritaire au sein de la gloire on voit
on entend assez peu les les écolos aussi
c'est vraiment la nupes avec Louis
Boyard dans son excentricité sur le
blocus challenge on a François Ruffin on
a Jean Mélenchon après c'est assez
habituel que la gauche choisisse la rue
pour se poser oui mais elle aurait pu à
l'Assemblée nationale lors des dernières
semaines utiliser une ils ont choisi
pourquoi cette attitude là pourquoi il
n'ont pas voulu entrer dans la
discussion on discute plus à gauche par
cette prise de pouvoir des insoumis ils
étaient vraiment dans dans le show j'ai
envie de dire médiatique après est-ce
que discuter à la semaine seul il savait
que en gros Renaissance et c'est 200 et
quelques députés plus la droite était
plutôt d'accord donc là quel était leur
part pour améliorer le le texte ils ont
choisi le show médiatique est-ce que
cette gauche c'est d'une certaine
manière fracturée alors qu'elle aurait
dû solidifier comme vous le dites c'est
un thème qui sont tous d'accord contre
la réforme des retraites et pourtant ils
n'ont pas réussi à s'accorder sur la
manière de faire et certaines sanctions
sont sorties bonjour
la nupesse fracture depuis le deuxième
tour des législatives vous savez que
c'était un accord de circonstances donc
chacun ayant son agenda
on le sait qu'ils ne sont pas d'accord
pour nucléaire par exemple on peut en
trouver d'autres celui-ci il y a pas de
débat ils sont tous d'accord pourquoi il
n'arrive pas à s'accorder mais vous avez
la nupes en tout cas les filles pardon
ils sont dans une organisation totale
ils ont toujours été ça c'est ils ont
toujours adopté cette attitude c'était
l'attitude de Jean-Luc Mélenchon depuis
en gros 2012 même du temps de François
Hollande ils ont joué le bruit et la
fureur c'est à dire s'opposer
systématiquement il n'est pas
constructif d'autres et moi je prends
toujours l'exemple du des socialistes au
Sénat se disent il faut qu'on construise
parce qu'on joue notre crédibilité en
tant que partie de gouvernement en fait
c'est plutôt ça c'est-à-dire vous avez
vous avez un camp qui aspire à gouverner
et l'autre qui sait que ça va être très
compliqué de gouverner ces images avec
les forces de l'ordre qui avancent
progressivement vers la Place d'Italie
et qui semble repousser certains
manifestants assez violent on regarde
ces images et on rejoint aussi Damien
Canivez Damien vous êtes sur le terrain
vous aussi est-ce que vous voyez des
échauffourés une tension qui qui monte
des forces de l'ordre prêt à en découdre
avec des manifestants violents
écoutez Thibault l'ambiance que je peux
vous décrire et celle que qui a l'image
actuellement sur figaroless c'est
d'ailleurs des personnes qui manifestent
plutôt paisiblement mais quelques
grabuches quelques échauffourés comme
vous pouvez le voir derrière un panneau
publicitaire en verre qui a été qui a
été cassé et là effectivement les gaz
lacrymogènes que vous avez décrit
précédemment Timothée Delenne nous sont
parvenus parce que on a la gorge qui
pique on voit là-bas au loin au loin
là-bas des gaz lacrymogènes qui sont à
nouveau tirés en en à la destination des
manifestants parce que les éléments
radicaux dont on parlait tout à l'heure
en début d'émission c'est à dire à peu
près 500 selon les renseignements
territoriaux et bien ils sont là en
cette fin de manifestation ils sont de
plus en plus actifs de plus en plus
mouvants et tout de noir vêtu bien
évidemment donc on se méfie parce que
c'est vrai qu'ils ont vraiment gagné la
fin de la manifestation ça reflète pas
vraiment l'ambiance que l'on a vu
jusqu'ici parce que nous voyons jusque
là des syndicats qui étaient quand même
tous bien rangés avec des revendications
qui étaient faire beaucoup de de
désespoir aussi quelque part de la part
de certains salariés qui étaient
vraiment remontés contre cette réforme
des retraites et cette radicalisation
malgré tout elle commence à se faire
entendre aussi dans la bouche des
manifestants qui sont paradiquaux en
réalité parce que c'est manifestants
sont prêts non pas en découdre avec les
forces de l'ordre comme c'est le cas de
certains
éléments radicaux que l'on peut voir en
cette fin de manifestation mais ce sont
des personnes qui ont finalement envie
de faire des des actions coup de poing
vous voyez comme des opérations
d'escargot des blocages de d'axe
routiers ce genre de choses et c'est des
paroles qu'on avait pas l'habitude
d'entendre jusque là si vous voulez
Thibault jusque là c'était des
manifestations qui visaient simplement à
réclamer la fin de de enfin en tout cas
le retrait de la réforme des retraites
et puis se projeter vers d'autres
manifestations cette fois-ci on se
projette plus vers le lendemain alors
que là la foule rebrousse chemin très
certainement parce que les policiers
sont en train euh de scinder le cortège
en deux comme il en va comme c'est le
cas habituellement parce que voilà il y
a un peu de d'échauffes fourrés là-bas
au loin des gaz lacrymogènes d'ailleurs
nous parviennent dans les yeux puisque
le vent nous est défavorable je dois
être honnête avec vous en tout cas si je
dois faire un un bilan de cette
manifestation là elle se passe plutôt
bien bon voilà c'est une fin de
manifestation un petit peu houleuse
comme on a l'habitude de les voir
à Paris voilà vous pouvez le voir sur
ces images filmées par par François
Carpentier qu'effectivement la
manifestation est un des en deux au loin
là-bas vous voyez la place d'Italie et
d'autres manifestants qui sont sur le
point d'arriver là-bas voilà Thibault
merci beaucoup Damien reprenez votre
souffle remettez-vous dans le sens du
vent et tout ira mieux on va essayer de
rejoindre Timothée d'Hélène parce que
Damien nous explique et c'est la
tendance depuis le début de cette
journée et depuis le début de ces
manifestations que le cortège se déroule
dans le calme tout va bien Timothée
delhem il y avait quelques tensions tout
à l'heure est-ce que tout est revenu
dans le calme ou pas encore
non on peut pas dire que ça soit revenu
dans le calme c'est vrai qu'il y a eu un
gros moment de tension tout à l'heure et
vous le voyez certainement derrière moi
je vais laisser Julien filmer cela en
fait c'est une colonne de CRS qui est en
train de remonter l'avenue des Gobelins
pour faire en sorte que que les
manifestants évacuent cette avenue parce
que je me disais tout à l'heure que
voilà les gens étaient stagnés sur cette
avenue qu'il ne cherchait plus vraiment
à avancer jusqu'à la Place d'Italie et
voilà donc que les les CRS en colonne
sont en train et bien de de faire en
sorte que que tout ce tout ce beau monde
avance vers cette place d'Italie on a vu
je peux pas vous décrire tout ce qu'on a
vu mais c'est vrai que l'avenue des
Gobelins a été a été partiellement
saccagé par par certains certains
manifestants vêtus de noir beaucoup de
vitrines ont été ont été endommagés des
distributeurs de des distributeurs
pardon de tickets
finalement et quelques quelques bruits
de pétards c'est vrai qu'on a du mal
aussi à distinguer si ce sont des
pétards ou bien des des bombes
assourdissantes en tous les cas voilà et
là vous le voyez d'ailleurs c'est ces
projectiles qui sont qui sont dirigés
contre contre je crois
vitrine de pompes funèbres voilà ici
vraiment la situation est toujours assez
tendue et c'est vrai qu'on a le
sentiment que les forces de l'ordre font
ce qu'ils peuvent pour que la situation
ne s'envenime pas mais pour l'instant
c'est pas encore c'est pas encore sous
contrôle totalement et surtout ce moment
où chacun se regarde et on sent que
voilà ça peut déraper à tout moment
[Musique]
toujours un peu angoissant ces images à
tomber de la nuit avec ces personnes non
moi masquées et ses gaz lacrymogènes qui
se répand dans les rues de la
capitatoires avec Florent barako ça vous
étonne de voir ces images ou finalement
ça vous étonné de ne pas les voir on
était tellement habitués à les voir
qu'on était étonné de voir là où
j'ajouterai jusque ce qu'a dit Damien
c'est qu'on ressent aussi une
radicalisation dans le discours de
certains manifestants qu'on a pu le ton
bon enfant des débuts pour aller à la
manif voilà en faisant des jeux de mots
sur les pancaresters on sent que la la
situation c'est un peu tendu alors ça ne
ça ne comment dire ça n'explique pas les
les affrontements de cette fin de manif
mais on sent qu'il y a quelque chose qui
est en train d'un peu de se radicaliser
peut-être parce qu'on approche du moment
fatidique du vote de la réforme est-ce
que ça peut changer quelque chose ce
soir sur les plateaux de télé demain sur
la page d'accueil du figaro.fr est-ce
qu'on peut voir violence
en marge du mouvement et donc changer la
vision des choses non parce que pour
l'instant c'est quand même assez
voilà ça n'a pas empêché la
manifestation de se dérouler
de comment dire apaisé du début de la
manif jusqu'à la fin c'est des petits
incidents mais qui change pas la nature
du mouvement par contre si ça se
reproduit samedi dans une dans une manif
un peu plus familiale etc là ça va
coloriser un peu le mouvement dernière
question rapidement Florent quelle est
la tendance selon vous cette réforme
va-t-elle passer 550
normalement elle doit passer je vous ai
dit le elle est votée normalement au
Sénat d'ici la fin de la semaine le il y
a une commission mix paritaire où se met
d'accord sur un texte et là plutôt une
tendance favorable auprès du texte du
Gouvernement puis après ça vient sur à
l'Assemblée ou normalement la
conjonction des voies de renaissance et
de LR doit permettre de voter la réforme
mais bon s'il manque 10 15 voix chez
Renaissance et 10 15 voix chez l'air et
ben il faudra peut-être passer par le 49
fois merci beaucoup belle conclusion for
embarcours on finit avec le 49-3 on vous
laisse merci de nous avoir suivi on vous
laisse avec ces images quand même pour
rester avec nous ces images de la fin de
manifestation aux abords de la place
d'Italie nous revient dans un petit
quart d'heure avec point de vue et point
de vue spécial vous en avez l'habitude
c'est à 18h mais ce soir on parle de
cette journée de mobilisation de cette
réforme des retraites avec trois invités
particulièrement intéressants je vous
retrouve dans un petit quart d'heure
ouais à peine allez à tout de suite on
vous laisse avec ces images
[Musique]